foreign
Java course Java is one of the most
popularly used languages for desktop app
development and if you wish to learn
Java full stack then you're in the right
place but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update so
let's look at what's in store for you
first we'll learn about Version Control
Systems like get
followed by which we'll understand core
Java Concepts like operators Loops
inheritance encapsulation and so on
moving ahead we have a section covering
Maven and Jenkins
now it is crucial to understand
front-end app development tools as well
the next section will include tutorials
on HTML CSS and angular and finally
we'll conclude the session by learning
database Management Systems like SQL and
mongodb so I hope you're excited to
learn all of this
now let's Jump Right In in today's era
the internet and smartphones have become
an integral part of our Lives we use our
phones for almost all of our day-to-day
tasks earlier we used to shop at malls
queue up in front of Banks and make our
travel bookings at travel agencies but
now we can do all this in the comfort of
our homes using smartphones all of this
is possible because of a high level
programming language called Java hi guys
welcome to this video that will tell you
everything you need to know about the
class-based object-oriented programming
language Java Java is an object-oriented
programming language that is used in a
distributed environment on the internet
it is a high level language that is easy
to read and understand Java is popularly
used in console graphical user interface
web and mobile applications game
development and also to make embedded
systems apart from these Java is also
used to develop software for devices it
is used not only in computers and
mobiles but even in electronic devices
like televisions washing machines air
conditioners and so on online forms
Banking and shopping are possible
because of java Java is a computer-based
programming language invented by James
Gosling and Sun Microsystems in 1991. he
had a single motor while creating the
language it was right once run anywhere
this meant that the code would have to
be written only once but it could be
used anywhere they named this language
Oak because of the oak tree outside
Gosling's Office later it was named to
Green then to Java Coffee which was
named after the coffee from Indonesia
and finally to Java in 1995. there are
three editions of java each programmer
can learn any of these editions based on
the application they want to make
firstly we have Java standard edition
this Edition contains core libraries
like java.lank java.tutil Etc secondly
we have Java Enterprise Edition this
Edition has apis like JMS ejb JSP
servlets Etc and lastly we have Java
micro Edition which is used to program
Java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on Java is an
object-oriented programming language
based on C and C plus plus however it is
improved and simplified to solve the
errors in programming Java files are
converted to bit code format using a
compiler and then executed by the Java
interpreter the whole Java code is run
on the Java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main Concepts in Java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching TV you use the TV remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in Java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class classes are used
to organize code just like how fruits
vegetables and clinical products are
divided into different sections in a
supermarket there are a lot of features
in Java let's start by looking at them
one by one it has a simple syntax and is
very easy to understand and learn Java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the C and C plus plus
languages Java also has features like
garbage collectors and exception
handling this makes Java very unique the
most popular feature of java is that it
is platform independent here compilation
happens in byte code and because of this
Java can run on any machine it is a
reset your language as it contains no
virus Java has a feature of
multi-threading the feature of
multi-threading helps Java do
multitasking Java is a portable language
as it can run on any platform and data
type sizes are set permanently so Java
program has a fixed size of the code the
last of all Java is not as fast as C and
C plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops Concepts in Java Java has
four Concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in Java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the Java code secure data is stored
within the classes and it is not easy to
access the data the next feature is
inheritance as the name suggests the
attributes and characteristics of one
class can be inherited by another class
because of this quora stake less time to
create the code lastly we have
polymorphism which means using the same
method for different tasks in Java we
can use the same object or variable in
two different places where their tasks
will differ hello and welcome to git
commands my name is chidanand and I am
with the simply learn team today I am
going to cover a few essential git
commands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it I begin by
installing a git bash or the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once I'm done with configuring the
git client I am going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once I'm
happy with my local changes I'm going to
comment few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration I plan to use
github.com which is a cloud hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually I
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the get distributed Version Control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed Version Control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed Version Control tool it
allows us to perform various Version
Control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with Git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with Git is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like Windows
all flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a git server so for user one or one user
to share his repository with another
user he would need to collaborate using
something called as a git server so in
the present Market there are a bunch of
git servers which are popularly
available some of them are free some of
them come with a cost because they are
licensed a bunch of these servers that I
can think of are GitHub which is one of
the most popular git servers that is
around in the market for a long time now
it comes with two variants one is the
cloud hosted one which is the github.com
and then the other one is an Enterprise
server which comes as a black box that
can be installed into your data centers
so typically organizations who don't
want their source code to be put up on
the cloud but go for this GitHub
Enterprise servers wherein they buy this
servers and these servers are hosted on
their data centers other popular variant
of the git server is bitbucket this is
from the famous atlasian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jiram a in
recent times there's one other variant
of the git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a gitlab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and I'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that I'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
I will register Myself by using my
username or my email ID and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https Authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user 2. the first
thing that I got to do is have an access
to a git server where both user 1 and
user 2 are set up so once I have that I
can push my repository onto this server
and provide right kind of access so that
user 2 or the other developer whoever
wishes to collaborate with me on this
repository can use his credentials as
long as is registered properly on the
git server he can use the credentials
and pull down this repository and work
with this repository so this is the
https way of authenticating and sharing
repositories another popular way of
sharing repositories or working with
each other is called as SSH
authentication as many of you would know
SSH means nothing but creation of a
private and a public key a bunch of keys
public and private are created on the
client machine while when creative keys
I will be asked for a passphrase I need
to type in a passphrase and remember my
passphrase and then I take this public
key and kind of post it on to my account
within my git server so that whenever
I'm going to connect next time using my
command prompt or any of the tools it's
going to challenge me for my passphrase
as long as I remember my passwords
correctly I can authenticate myself and
get into the server so both https and
SSH are popular ways of communicating
with the git server having said this let
me just get started by installing the
git bash on my local system and then
fire up some of these git commands and
build up some repositories make some
changes in my repository commit this
changes and later use my GitHub
credential to connect to my GitHub
server and push my repositories out
there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that I can go ahead
and install it so I just type in git
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that I
find is a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
client I need this one so this is a git
client or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I may want to
use git from Windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open SSH that's fine
next card next card no I don't want any
of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the version that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good it's a git help
all right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iPhone Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also Global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my get demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
getting to the syllable all right as of
now this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment okay so let me create a
repository out of this how do I create a
repository of this is pretty simple I
just run a git init command
when I say kit init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it was
an empty repository so it initially is
an empty repository in this particular
folder for all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say git in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that Branch if at all I
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever I navigate to different
branches the branch name within this
brackets would change all right so far
so good so we created a folder we made
it a git repository by initializing that
with the git in it and then I'm not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository so I
use a touch command touch is a Linux
command it kind of creates this
particular folder if all you're not
comfortable with the file creation by
this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so I create a file called touch
master.txt and open up in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm going to write inside this
I save this and I come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this set tell you there's
no commit set you're in the master
Branch there is an untracked file and
this shows up in red it also gives you
all the command that is supposed to be
run so if at all you want to add this
file you would say git add and the name
of the file and then you're going to
commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so command
to add that is called git add I can
specify either the name of the file or I
can give a wild character saying git add
dot now if I run the git status command
again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
comment this file if at all that's what
I want to do so let me do that
I'll do a kit commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the get status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if a to error I run the git
log command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what I did I modified the
older file that existed I also added a
new file to my repository now if I run
the get status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with the message let's say is
this is my second commit
all right
if I do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice
I'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server I
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things I can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way I want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I'll log into my GitHub
account using my username and
credentials and let me go ahead and
create a new Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get Hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and push it
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs one is the HTTP s
URL and the other one is the SSH URL as
of now we do not have any SSH keys that
is set up so let me use this https URL
to connect my local repository with the
repository on this server
so I've done all these things I already
have the repository set up all that I
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server URL
so this would be the command that I need
to copy
which essentially links or ads and
origin with the URL of the git server I
just copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I am all set
I've got two comments in my repository
I'm done with all the changes so let me
try to push my repository onto the
server the command for doing it for the
first time is git push hyphen U this is
for linking the Upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
a branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username and the password with which
I have registered
I would say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text fit all I see
the commits they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we have
committed the change we have pushed it
so there's no timestamp of the push that
happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server now let me
demonstrate to you the SSH configuration
that is required for creating a pair of
SSH keys and ensuring that I connect to
the GitHub server using the SSH
mechanism so for doing that I need to
First create a pair of private and
public key the command to do that is SSH
Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I am
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I will click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase I hope I remember it
correctly
all right
triggered I've been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I will
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
create a repository
So Random readme file with some content
in it gets created and I can see there
are two URLs to this repository https
and SSH so this time let me copy the SSH
URL so that I will use this URL to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first repository earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text
some text file I'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
and save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file you want to add this file onto the
repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with a message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
I given some particular message
and this time around since I cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more I'll
then push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it posts the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here okay wonderful I had only
one commit now I see my second comment
so what was added as a part of the
second comment it says a new file was
added all this line that never existed
got added this is the second file the
content exactly what I pushed onto the
server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the change changes that has happened in
the repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
files that got added all this with one
particular message get status will give
you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the commit
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the URL of the
server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however my perspective
of Version Control tool you will have to
be really cautious about the chain that
you're gonna do in case the changes are
pretty local none of the developers or
none of the other users who are
collaborating with you would be affected
by this change you are good to go ahead
and make this change however if your
repository has been pushed to the server
and you're trying to modify something
from history this would have a very bad
or adverse effect on all the other users
who will be using it you need to be
really cautious while running these
commands in case your repository
contents are local if you've not pushed
your changes to your repository and if
at all you made some changes to the
repository maybe to fix a defect or to
include a new feature and you missed few
things you can go ahead and modify this
with some of these commands let's say I
have this simple repository called undo
undo repo and if at all I look at the
logs of these I have the commit
histories which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I added another file in C3
I've also added some file in C4 I made
some changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I
have added another file called M4 now
this is my commit history now let's say
I made these two commits but possibly I
want to Club them together along with
some other changes because whatever
changes I did did not really fix things
the way I expected you to fix so there
is a git command called git reset this
would allow me to go back in history to
go back to any of the snapshot get rid
of all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two comments would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the comment that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line what it says is 7 C2 now the head
which is nothing but the current pointer
which is earlier pointing to C5 it's
gone back to C3 now what happened to the
changes that were there as a part of C4
and C5 if at all you do a git status if
you see the changes that were part of C4
was some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a
new file got M4 got added if at all Duo
get status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the topmost comment
that exists as of now c4 and C5 have
been current rate of but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.text
and say one new file that was missed out
I make this change I go to a get status
all these files are still there I will
send it add dot I also get
m
C4
rewriting history
and I do a git
log
pretty
there you go so C1 C2 C3 still existed
and whatever was a part of C4 and C5 the
older ones I've gotten rid of this along
with those old changes I also added a
new file I made some changes and it was
able to comment it now if you look at my
git history it's all nice and clean
however do this activity only when you
don't push your git repository to the
server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and is not being pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a git server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so here's got C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here and there are a
bunch of people from the server who has
pulled this repository and all of them
are the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the C3 which is a wrong thing to do
and possibly you know he could have done
a better job of fixing this in in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
comment to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this comic
possibly gets rid of the C3 instead of
going back in history it actually is
taking your git history ahead but as a
part of this comment you're undoing some
part of the work that was done as a part
of C3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are your losing this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
pretty one nine
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C to our
another file in C3 I've added one more
file and in C4 I made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all I see the
contents of the git folder it contains
M1 M2 M3 and M4 and let's say looking at
the previous use case that I mentioned I
may want to get rid of this particular
comment
I want to get rid of the C3 which is
nothing but I've added a file called M3
dot text but I added it by mistake I
need a better way of fixing it possibly
I look at it later on but for now I
don't want this particular commit and
the changes that were made as a part of
that commit to exist so the better way
to do that is using the get revert
command so git revert and the commit ID
whatever I want to revert so if you want
to revert this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit reward at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
face this
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit It undoes
Whatever changes that were done as a
part of this comment so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me I say write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
M3 was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding it which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because git deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool in most of
the Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
Git You just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right by navigating to this folder
and let me create a repository here I
initial as a repository a DOT git folder
is created without any files in it so
let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees dot text
play on
has over 3K employees
I just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
first comment
so if I do a git log
I see only one commit and there are two
files and you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
and this created a branch but I don't
see any changes in the folder structure
or in the file that exists here I've
just created this Branch so if at all I
do a grid branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and
Baylor Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
blr Branch I've actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files this exactly two files the
way it was earlier because I've created
a branch from my base branch which is
the master branch and when I created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same
alright so let me create a file that is
specific to Bangalore branch
so I will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I see
notepad address dot text
I'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in
some arteries
outside Bangalore
that is the content of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I would sync it add
Dot and I would say kit
commit hyphen m
angalore
branch
comment
all right if you see this now I have an
address dot text which is there only in
the Bangalore branch that I'm presently
on now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout Master Branch if you remember
when I forged out or when I created a
new Branch from the master Branch I
didn't have this address dot text in it
so let me go back to git git checkout
Master branch and keep noticing this
particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you're in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears so this particular file is only
present in the branch and git is playing
around with the file system snapshot by
moving the pointers across and ensuring
that whenever I am switching to
Bangalore Branch I see this address dot
text when I go back to my master Branch
I don't say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository
get Branch demo this is what I'm gonna
put in as a description I would say
public I don't want any readme files in
it because I already have a repository I
will just say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is the SSH URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it here
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master Branch so I
would say git
push hyphen U origin master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says new Bunch Master is created so if I
go back to my server and it will refresh
if you see it is only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other brands that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the track
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if we get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if at all
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this under stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangle Branch to come back into
my master Branch so if I go to click
checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address DOT
type this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge the Bangalore
Branch changes and where will it merge
it will merge it into the current brands
that I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
will see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
foreign
branch that we had earlier which had
only one commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the Bangalore Branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I mean two branches the princess's
Master even if I'm in master Branch I
should see this address dot text that is
there even if I'm in the Bangalore
Branch the content is all same because
we immerse these two branches now that
I've merged this Branch I don't need
this Branch anymore so I would go ahead
and delete this locally as well as push
it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete Branch locally the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say get brands and I'm presently
in the master Branch so I can go ahead
and delete the other Branch so get
Branch hyphen D Bangalore branch
all right this got rid of our panel
Branch locally
if that's all I don't get Branch hyphen
V it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this Branch would still
exist on the server because Server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done we need to
specifically push our changes onto the
server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iPhone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in git go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new Branch
you issue a command git Branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
Branch from the existing Branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git Branch new underscore
Branch it creates a new underscore
Branch from the master Branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this Branch you would type in git check
out the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific Branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command git
push hyphen U origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new Branch are pushed
onto this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git Branch hyphen AV assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master Branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
Branch into a master Branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you're on the master branch and
if you issue a command get more much new
underscore Branch this would merge the
contents of the new Branch onto the
master Branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this Branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is git Branch
hyphen capital D and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this Branch from the server
the command to do that is git push
origin hyphen iPhone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
brands that you created on the server
hello guys this is vikesh so when we
talk about Java it is one of the most
popular programming language out there
and it was created way back in 1991 but
it was publicly released only in 1995.
it was developed by one of the famous
developers of Our Generation who is
James Gosling at Sun Microsystems and
then later Java was acquired by Oracle
and today Oracle owns Java Java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different aspects of how it is easy
and simple to use it's a write once Run
Anywhere type of programming language
again we will look at details into into
into this particular concept as well and
when we talk about the usage of java you
can use it to build web applications
mobile applications desktop applications
even command line applications and at
the same time you can also use it to
build complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing Etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's an object-oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in Java happens
around objects objects enable the
execution of the program objects talk to
each other to exchange data and messages
we will okay about a look at the concept
of objects in details in the upcoming
lectures it's a platform independent
language which means that again going
back to the previous point of write once
Run Anywhere it basically enables the
program to be run on any platform once
compiled so once you have prepared your
program and you have compiled your
program then your compiled program can
be run on any platform it is a strong
type checking language which means that
it will force you to respect the
contracts of the variables to the data
types for example if you have created a
collection which should accept strings
then you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly type
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in Java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a Java compiler and you have a Java
interpreter you first compile your
program and then you run the program
using the help of java interpreter Java
also provides automatic garbage
collection it's a really important
feature and if you talk about the
languages prior to Java like C or C plus
plus they did not offer this capability
and this capability made Java really
popular because it could automatically
find the unused objects and variables
and remove them from the memory to free
up memory space for the program
execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so there's they can be one
thread which is monitoring your
leaderboard score there can be another
thread which is displaying the speed of
the car there can be another thread
which is displaying the graphic there
can be another thread which is
displaying the sound so you see all of
these threads are working parallely and
Java provides the support to create such
applications using the multi-threading
capability it has Java is secure by
default because there are no pointers in
Java so there are no possibilities of
having any memory leaks or any reference
leaks from the application again if we
take the example of programming
languages like C or C plus plus you have
the concept of pointers and we we
witnessed lot of a lot of scenarios and
lot of incidents where there was a
memory leakage happening in the in the
production application which was which
was really a bad experience for the
organizations so Java removed the
concept of pointers totally from its
programming language it's also a very
robust language because it provides a
really great exception handling
framework out of the box which
developers can use and Implement to
build really resilient applications so
now let us understand how a Java program
is run so at first you basically write
your Java program and you store your
Java program into a DOT Java file then
you compile your Java file with the help
of the Java compiler once the program is
compiled the compiler is going to
generate another file which is a DOT
class file and this dot class file is
basically the compiled file or also
known as the byte code file so this byte
code or the dot class file code can be
run on any platform be it a Linux
platform or a Windows platform or a Mac
OS platform or any other platform to
give you some more context the first two
steps where you write your Java program
and your compile your Java program can
be run on any machine let's take the
example that you ran these two steps on
a Windows machine so you add your you
write your program and you compile your
program on a Windows machine which
generated a DOT class file then you
transported this dot class file to a
Linux machine and it also worked there
you transported your dot class file to a
Mac OS machine and it worked there as
well and that's what brings the platform
Independence concept of java that you
can write the program once on any
platform and once you have the byte code
available then you can run this program
on any other platform of your choice
okay so that was about how the Java
program execution works and how the
platform Independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download Java and install Java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the Java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for Java development
kit so the Java development kit is the
installation of the Java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or Java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like Java
runtime environment or JRE Java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other supporting libraries so let
us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the Java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can run the dot
class file using how does it achieve
this environment for achieving this
virtual virtual machine environment it
would need some runtime libraries and
that is provided by these class
libraries for example there would be a
runtime jar or rt.jar as a shorthand
which will be supplied to the program at
the runtime to make sure that the
program runs smoothly then there are
other supporting libraries as well which
your program may be using for example if
this program this dot class file is
let's say a calculator program then it
might be using a square root function
from java.math package so how do how
does the java.net package gets supplied
at runtime it would be supplied by the
other supporting libraries which are
present inside GRE so GRE will make sure
that your program runs inside the Java
virtual machine it gets the required
runtime libraries and it also gets the
libraries which are referred in your
program at runtime and this all together
will make sure that your program is
running so you can see jdk basically
provides GRE automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
GRE separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a Windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your class 5 to another
machine and there you just install the
GRE you don't install jdk there you just
install the runtime environment and you
can run the dot class file just using
the runtime environment let's get
started with inheritance
so inheritance is basically one of the
most important properties of any object
oriented programming language it's
basically a concept and a concept says
that what if you have a scenario where
you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example let's take the example of a
bank when you go to a bank to open an
account there are multiple types of
accounts there can be a savings account
it can be a type of current account
there can also be a different offering
for personal account and Commercial
accounts such as for businesses then you
may also have loan accounts which are
having different kind of properties so
all of these types of accounts are still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example all
of them will have to maintain some sort
of an interest rate for example all of
them will be used to either deposit
money or withdraw money so there would
be some kind of similarity across all of
these types of account classes but at
the same time there will also be some
sort of differentiality amongst these
classes the way you will calculate the
interest rate for a current account will
be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate for a
savings account and the same applies for
commercial account personal account Loan
account Etc so you see that we have some
common Behavior but at the same time we
also have some different Behavior so
whenever you have such scenario always
think about applying the concept of
inheritance in your application this is
another simple way to spot whether
inheritance can be used at a particular
place or not inheritance is also called
is a relationship so whenever you read
the requirements from a customer just
try to find the words which use this
particular phrase is a for example car
is a vehicle savings account is a type
of account similarly you will find many
other types of similar examples so
whenever you will see that is a
relationship between two different kinds
of objects or two different kind of
entities that means that there might be
an inheritance relationship being
applied between them and that's how you
will spot the usage of inheritance so so
far we have understood this concept that
there would be some sort of relationship
between the two classes what will be
this relationship the relationship will
be of parent child type there will be a
parent class some people also call that
as base class and then there will be a
child class so the child class will be
inheriting the properties and the
behaviors from the base class or from
the parent class I will be using Base
Class and parent class terms
interchangeably during this session but
the basic idea and basic premise is like
that only that there will be a child
class and there will be a parent class
and the child class class is extending
from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and I've just shown
you the uh what you see here is
basically the official definition which
is given by Java docs here we can read
the definition as well and the basic
idea which I told you lies in the parent
and child relationship and this is how
you can conceptualize it that you will
have a base class or a parent class and
then you will you can have multiple
children of it and then those children
can again have their own children and so
on so forth so this hierarchy this whole
inheritance hierarchy can go as deep as
you want it to be and that's the basic
idea and basic conceptualization of how
you understand and how you visualize
inheritance now let's move to Eclipse
IDE and try to understand this with the
help of an example so for this
particular case I have created a set of
classes basically which we will be using
to demonstrate the relationship of
inheritance and I've taken the simple
example of a bicycle so a bicycle is
again a very definition of any two
wheeler and bicycles can have multiple
types there can be an all-terrain bike
there can be a mountain bike there can
be a city bike there can be a bike which
is specific specifically made for ladies
and similarly there can be multiple
different types of bikes but all of
these bikes will have some similar
properties for example all of them will
have two wheels all of them will have a
seat all of them will have brake all of
them will have some sort of of some sort
of a speeding mechanism whether they can
accelerate de-accelerate so there will
be some commonality but at the same time
a mountain bikes features might be very
different from a city bike feature a
mountain bike features might feature a
mountain bike might have gears for
example whereas a city bike might not
have gears because you don't need that
much of a variation in inclination and
declination when you drive down the road
so I'm trying to conceptualize the same
example here where I've created a class
called bicycle and this is my base class
I Define two properties in the in the
bicycle class which is gear and speed we
will come back to protected in a while
but let's let's leave that there so I
have two properties which is gear and
speed I have a Constructor where I'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear and then I have three
methods here which says set gear apply
break and speed up when I apply brake
the speed is going to get reduced so
that's why you see minus equal to Unity
operator and when I'm trying to speed up
the speed is going to increase that's
why I'm using the plus equal to unary
operator so when you use the method
speed up the speed is going to be
increased by the value you supply in the
method similarly when you apply the
brake the speed is going to get reduced
by the amount you supply in the method
argument and that is my Base Class
bicycle gear speed and three methods now
let's have a look at the child class
so the way you will Define The
Inheritance relationship in Java is by
using this extends keyword remember I
told you to remember the extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual and then you
will use extends keyword and then you
will use the parent class name or the
Base Class name so here I'm saying class
mountain bike extends bicycle and here I
am providing an additional property
remember the whole commonality versus
differentiality equation so a mountain
bike might have an extra property to
adjust the seat height so that's the
extra property which mountain bike is
having
and then since this mountain bike is
extending the bicycle class this
mountain bike class has the
responsibility to initialize the bicycle
class as well and the way it will
fulfill that responsibility is by taking
all the arguments of bicycle class plus
the mountain bike class in its
Constructor and that's why you see three
different properties here you see the
start height property which is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start Speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class but this class is inheriting those
properties from The Base Class remember
the keyword inheritance here and then
once you do that how do you initialize
the Base Class Constructor is by calling
the super method this is again a keyword
in Java and you will use this super
keyword to refer to the base class
Constructor in this way so what you will
do technically is that you will write
super and you will supply the arguments
which is required by The Base Class
Constructor if I go back the Base Class
Constructor requires two arguments start
Speed and start gear
so I write super and then I write start
Speed and start gear so whatever I got
from here in the Constructor of mountain
bike I am supplying those values as is
to Super and Java will automatically
take care of invoking this particular
Constructor the moment it it Encounters
this kind of statement another another
thing to notice is that this super
keyword or super statement has to be the
first statement inside your Constructor
remember that whenever you are dealing
with inheritance and whenever you have
to initialize the super class
Constructor or the Base Class
Constructor use the super Constructor
invocation as the very first statement
inside your child class Constructor
otherwise Java will not compile the
program and then you will initialize the
local variable I should call this as
this remember I we discussed about this
in this in the classes session
okay and then it just has a method of
set height so there's no extra method
with this mountain bike is providing but
this mountain bike will have access to
all the methods which have been provided
here and all the properties which have
been provided here this mountain bike
can access everything from the bicycle
class and that's the whole idea of
inheritance that the child class can
access the properties of the Base Class
by extending the base class now let's
look at how do we invoke this particular
class so for that I have a simple class
name as inheritance demo which has a
public static white main method and then
I am initializing the mountain bike Plus
I'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
1 so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to start Speed and one
here goes to gear or the start gear and
that's how I'm setting the values so
when I call this particular Constructor
here the mountain bike Constructor is
going to this mountain bike Constructor
is going to get called and which in turn
is going to call the Base Class bicycle
class Constructor as well and everything
will be set accordingly and then let's
try to access the gear property remember
gear is not directly available in the
mountain by class but I am still able to
do mountain bike dot gear because child
class can access the parents class
properties
similarly the same thing goes for Speed
as well and seat height is the local
property of this particular class
mountain bike so it will anyways be
accessible so I can access all the
properties of the base class and the
child class itself seamlessly without
any differentiation now let's try to
call a method so here I'm calling the
method apply break remember apply break
was defined in the Base Class not in the
child class it's defined here so I'm
calling the apply break method and I
want to reduce the speed the current
speed by 1 and then I'm printing the
current speed saying that bike speed
after applying brake is Mountain by dot
speed so let's run this particular
program and observe the outputs
okay so the the first statement which
gets printed is at line number seven
which says gear is one because it's
coming from here then the seat height is
mountain bike dot seat height which is
20 which is the first argument here and
then the bike speed is 10 which is
coming as here and getting printed here
and then when I apply the break let's go
back to the apply break method the logic
is that whatever is the current speed
reduce it by the value I Supply in the
method
so if I Supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if I
Supply 5 here the current speed will be
10 minus 5 equal to 5 let's assert that
particular assumption as well yes we can
see that and similarly you can access
other methods of the base class as well
if I just do control space here and you
can see apply break is accessible set
gear set height speed up all the methods
which are defined in the base class are
accessible in the child class as well
this is the power of inheritance one
more thing which I said I will come back
to is around the usage of protected
access modifier
remember when we discussed about the
access modifiers in the previous session
I said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance that
whenever you define something as
protected it will be available to be
accessible in the child classes of the
base class so if I Define this
particular variable as as protected then
this particular property will be
accessible in the child class mountain
bike as well let's play around this
let's make this as private and see what
happens so if I make this private now
when I say private the scope of this
particular variable is within the class
only and nobody outside the class will
be able to see it and you can see the
effect of it I can see an error being
coming here in my inheritance demo class
because now mountain bike object cannot
access the gear property because the
gear property is defined in the base
class and now it is private that's why
the child class now mountain bike class
cannot access the property gear and the
moment you make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected access modifiers it is always
always recommended to use them when you
when you write any kind of inheritance
logic and inheritance logic as well
intentionally if you want to hide a
particular property from the child
classes just make it private and that's
all I want to cover in this particular
session where we dive deep into the
concept of inheritance we had a look at
an example using the bicycle and
mountain bike kind of construct and you
can apply the same kind of construct on
any kind of other other kind of business
requirement remember the is a
relationship
so that's all I want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another very interesting concept of java
which is about encapsulation let's get
started with encapsulation so again
let's understand what is encapsulation
in general and then we will apply that
concept to Java encapsulation if you try
to break that word if I just write it
here in the form of a comment it's n
capsulation just trying to break this
word into to to make it more visual so
you see you see a word called capsule
here so if you try to imagine a capsule
why do you create that and what's the
concept of a capsule capsule tries to
pack a lot of things inside a small tube
like shape and the concept of
encapsulation is sort of inspired from
that not exactly not literally but
that's the basic idea of of this root
word which is called encapsulation so
encapsulation basically means to
restrict accessing the properties of a
class to the outside world if you want
to protect the properties of your class
how do you do that you do that with the
help of the concept called encapsulation
so here you this is a sort of a security
feature you can think it think of it as
a security feature that you want to
protect the properties of your class and
you will use encapsulation to protect
the properties how you implement
encapsulation let's have a look at that
now so basic idea is to encapsulate the
objects create sort of a capsule around
the object which can provide that
protection layer and you will Define how
the outside world is going to access the
properties of the class if needed so
I've created a simple class here and
it's if you if you remember one of the
previous examples when we discussed
about classes I use the same class which
was the student class and I'm just using
the same class for continuity so I've
created a student class here and I have
created three different properties of
this particular class which is name name
of the student age of the student and
address of the student you see
intentionally I have used the keyword
private in front of these three
properties and that is the first thing
which you need to do to implement
encapsulation on your object that you
hide all the properties from the outside
world remember the moment you make
anything as private only the class which
is the student class itself only the
class itself can see these variables or
these properties nothing outside the
student class will be able to access the
name or age or the address directly from
the student class it's not possible
that's the whole idea of making it
private because you don't want the
outside world to access these properties
so you make those properties as private
then you create a Constructor the
Constructor has to be public so that
anybody can initialize the student
object because you want your object to
be accessible remember so you want the
objects to be accessible but you want
the restriction on the access of the
properties of the object and these are
the properties of the object so you have
restricted them by making it private but
that doesn't solve the problem because
there will be some illegitimate
consumers of the student object which
should not have access to the student
properties but there will also be some
legitimate consumers of the student
object which should be having access to
the properties of the student for
example the payrolls application will
need access to these particular
properties the examination application
will require access to these particular
properties so how do you do that you
create Getters we call them Getters
because they start with the keyword get
so you create a getter method for each
of the property you create the method
called as get name and this is the
naming convention with Java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property in camel case
so you write get name and this property
is supposed to return the name property
of this particular object and you here
you say return name so you're returning
the the name which is being stored by
the current student object whenever
somebody calls student object dot get
name and this is the way you have
restricted the access of this particular
object as well so remember you made it
private so that nobody can access it and
then you defined your own way of
providing access to the name property of
this particular class now if anybody
wants to access the name value of your
student object there's only one and one
way to do that which is via calling get
name so you have provided restrictions
and you have also provided prescriptive
guidance on how you are going to expose
the properties of your class that's the
second uh thing which you need to do to
implement correct form of encapsulation
on your object that that is to provide
the getter methods with the right
visibility you want to make them public
so that anybody can call them but since
you are governing which is what is
written inside the method you have full
control on what kind of exposure you
want to give for this particular
property similarly you create a getter
for age calling get Edge which Returns
the age and then you call get ad you
write get address and return the address
here it is simply returning it but if
you want to do more stuff here feel free
to do that like I said you govern the
control of how do you want to return the
name maybe you don't want to return the
complete name and you want to just
return the initials then you can split
the string trim the string and return
only the initial patients so that's the
basic idea of Getters now after you have
created the object there might be use
cases where somebody needs to overwrite
the values of the properties like name
age or address whatever Student's name
was incorrectly mentioned when they
called The Constructor and now they want
to override the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name with a new
name so in that case you need to provide
what we call as Setters and they start
with set that's why we call them Setters
and we follow the same kind of logic
that you provide these Setters for all
the properties of your class so you had
three properties which were named age
and address and you provided the Setters
for all three of them and how do you
provide that you write you again make
them as public because you want the
outside world to access this Setter
method to override the values of the
name this method is not going to return
anything so it is going to be y right
then you write the name of the method
which starts with set and then the
property name in camel case and then you
provide the new value which is the value
which should be which should be the new
value and this is the value which should
replace the existing value so whatever
new value you want to supply to supply
that as the argument of the setter
methods for set name for set age or for
set address and then you write this
particular line which says set the
current name property of this particular
object with the name which is coming in
from the argument so this dot name
remember this dot name represents the
current objects property because this
represents the current object so
whatever is the current object property
value of the name is just overwrite that
value with the argument coming in do the
same thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the in the set address method so this is
how you are going to provide the Setters
and the Getters so Setters and Getters
can also be generated in smart Ides like
like Eclipse so you just right click you
go to source and here you will see the
option of generate Getters and Setters
if you click on this it will give you
the list of the fields which are
available to be had to be having Getters
and Setters currently it says no fields
or all Fields have Getters and Setters
already Yes because they have it let me
just comment this and show this how this
work so for example let me comment all
the Getters and setters
so I'm commenting them and if I right
click Source generate caters and Setters
I get all the fields available for which
Setters and Getters can be generated so
you can select them and leave everything
as default hit generate and it is
automatically going to generate the
Getters and the setter you see all the
code of the getter and Setter is
automatically generated you do not even
need to write it and this is the power
of the smart ID is let me just uh revert
what I did
so you created everything as all the
properties as private and then you
define how you want to replace the
values by providing the Setters and you
define how you want the outside world to
access your properties so you have full
control of the class now you you control
the visibility you control how they are
going to get initialized you are you are
controlling how the properties are going
to be overwritten or set and you control
how the properties are going to be
returned so you have complete control of
the class so you have created a perfect
capsule here a perfect form of
encapsulation in this class and this is
how you can Implement encapsulation and
that's all I'm going to cover for this
particular session in the next session
we are going to discuss about
abstraction let's get started with
abstraction let's first understand the
definition of abstraction before we
relate this to Java abstraction
generally means hiding something when
you want to hide some details of of a
particular object from the outside world
you apply the concept of abstraction for
example when you drive a particular car
you just hit the accelerator and the car
speeds up now it's not only one action
when you hit the accelerator the whole
Machinery of the car and all the
components different parts of the car
work together to speed up they would be
engine they would be propulsion they
would be fuel they would be there might
be some if it's an electric car they
would batteries there would be whole
different kinds of pistons and plugs
which will make the car speed up it's
not only a single component it's lot of
different components under the hood and
that's the concept of abstraction that
we only show the relevant parts to the
user and we hide all the internal
details from the user that's the basic
idea of abstraction so a car
manufacturer abstracts away all the
inner technical details from the driver
and just gives the driver a single pedal
to speed up the car for a User it's a
very good experience because he doesn't
need to know about all the internals of
the car but the car manufacturer can
hide all the details and provide a very
simple interface for the driver to
interact with which is just a gas pedal
and that's the basic idea of abstraction
and we try to apply the same kind of
concept to Java in the form of
abstraction and Java provides this kind
of concept implementation with the help
of a keyword which is called abstract
now abstract is a keyword which can be
used in front of a class or a method
when you use it in front of a class the
whole class becomes abstract abstract
class is a type of class so the class
itself becomes an abstract class one of
the things to remember is that abstract
class cannot be instantiated but can be
subclassed remember we talked about the
concept of subclass and the parent class
when we talked about inheritance so if
you make a class as abstract class you
cannot call The Constructor of the class
us because you cannot instantiate it but
you can extend the abstract class and
create a child class class out of it
that's the concept of abstract class
another concept is abstract method you
can also use the abstract keyword in
front of a method and when you use
abstract keyword in front of a method
then that method is only declared
without an implementation you are not
going to provide any implementation of
the method and you are just going to
declare the method something like this
we will see a similar example in the in
the Hands-On as well but that's the
basic idea that you just declare the
method you are not providing an
implementation as to what does move to
Method actually does because that's the
whole concept of abstraction and it is
the responsibility of the child classes
which inherit the particular class in
which the abstract method would be
sitting so that child class will be
having the responsibility to provide a
concrete implementation of the declared
method let's understand this better with
the help of an exam example so here I
have created a class called graphic
object and I have made the class as
abstract class this is the keyword which
you need to use in front before the
class keyword and the class becomes an
abstract class now when you create an
abstract class it automatically gets
some properties the first property is
that this particular class must have at
least one abstract method and this is
how you define the abstract methods
where you just provide the Declaration
but you do not provide the
implementation of the draw method or the
resize method and the way you will
create the abstract methods is by using
the abstract keyword before the actual
method declaration starts so General
method declaration would look like this
and if you use abstract in front of it
this becomes an abstract method
declaration abstract class can also have
concrete methods so that is the Liberty
which abstract class gives you that you
can have abstract methods which are just
declared but you can also have normal
methods which are which where you can
also provide the implementation so you
can have normal methods and Abstract
methods as well in an abstract class
so this is the abstract class now if if
you want to provide an implementation of
the draw and resize method you have to
extend this abstract class so we extend
this abstract class by creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is circle.java
where you can see I create a normal
class and I use the extends keyword for
inheritance and I'm saying that Circle
class is inheriting from the graphic
object class which was my abstract class
and once I use this extends keyword then
I have the responsibility of providing
the implementation of the abstract
methods actually Java will force me to
provide the implementation of these two
methods if I do not provide all the
declared methods so there are two
declared methods here so if the circuit
class does not provide that the
implementation for both draw and resize
methods then Java will throw an error
and it will ask you to take an action
which can be either Define all the
methods meaning provide implementation
for all the methods or make the circle
class itself as abstract let's see if I
just comment this particular out I get
an error you see a red line here and if
you click on this particular balloon
here it will say either you can add the
unimplemented methods or you can make
the circle type as abstracts these are
the two options which you will get to
fix this particular error so an abstract
class can be extended by another
abstract class if the child abstract
class is not implementing all the
methods of the parent if you want to
implement all the methods then just
Implement them and keep and keep it as a
normal class and that's what I've done
here I've just created a normal class
here and provided the implementation and
once you provide the implementation of
both of the methods the error is gone
similarly I have also provided another
child class because it's there can be
there can be multiple children of a
particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object and it
also provides its own implementation of
drawing and resize because generally the
way you will draw a rectangle and you
resize a rectangle will be different
than drawing or resizing a circle here I
am not doing anything in the methods
because this is just to show you the
demonstration I'm just printing a Swiss
out saying drawing a circle and resizing
or drawing a rectangle and resizing a
rectangle and in the circle class
drawing a circle and resizing a circle
so one abstract class is the parent
class which is the graphic object and
two children Circle and rectangle both
providing the implementation of the
abstract methods which were declared in
the base class now let's go to the main
class where I've defined defined the
public static void main method and here
you see I have created two different
kind of blocks of code here one block is
where I'm saying graphic object creating
a reference of the graphic object named
as Circle and initializing the circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class and here is
the concrete class so whatever you
define on the right hand side whatever
is the type of object will be the type
of methods being caught so if you
created a circle object and then if you
call the draw method and resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class if you initialized it as
new rectangle then you are creating a
rectangle class object and then the draw
and the resize method will be called
from the rectangle class that's the
basic construct and that's how you will
initialize a particular class which is
using an abstract class so I I call a
graphic object Circle New Circle and I
call circle.draw and circle dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle and rectangle.draw
rectangle dot resize let's run this
program and observe the output so when I
call this particular block of code
Circle object gets initialized and then
Circle dot draw method prints drawing a
circle and circle resize method prints
drawing resizing a circle similarly when
I create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class
rectangle.draw prints this particular
line drawing a rectangle and rectangle
dot resize prints this particular line
which is resizing a rectangle and this
is how you will use the concept of
abstraction this another very
interesting thing which which is which
is going on here remember I told you I
do this and I I create I just put a
system out here
base abstract plus so if I do this here
if I create if I still write a
Constructor though Java says that it
cannot be instantiated if I still write
a Constructor of it and I do not do any
changes here and if I run this
particular program let's see what
happens you'll see the base abstract
class being called here let me just
reformat it by putting Ln here so that
we get a better output so if I run this
particular program you see base abstract
class is getting printed somehow though
we said that abstract classes cannot be
instantiated but still the Constructor
of this is still getting called somehow
when I create a circle class The Base
Class Constructor gets called and when I
click create a rectangle class again the
Base Class Constructor gets called this
is this is the power of inheritance
because in inheritance remember how it
works when you call when you initialize
a particular child object referencing it
with the parent object see the
references of the parent class and the
object is of the child us so whenever
you do it like this first the default
Constructor because I'm calling the
default Constructor here the default
Constructor of the circle class will get
called which will go here remember I
told you that Java provides the default
Constructor automatically if you don't
provide it so the default Constructor of
circle gets called but Java sees that
you are writing this code here which
says Circle extends graphic object so
Java is automatically going to call the
parent class and going to initialize the
parent class as well because that's how
it will be able to see these methods and
so so that's why it will automatically
call The Base Class Constructor even if
you don't call it explicitly in fact you
cannot call it explicitly Java will not
allow you to initialize the graphic
object class explicitly it can only and
only be called by Java itself indirectly
via the concept of inheritance if you
try to do this let's try to do this for
fun and and also for better
understanding so if I write graphic
object g o equal to new graphic object
you see I don't even get an option but
let's write it and let's see what
happens so you see that this particular
it gives basically an error because it's
not able to find the Constructor of the
graphic object class though even I have
defined the default Constructor here but
still Java is not able to find it
because this class is abstract so hence
proved abstract classes cannot be
instantiated explicitly they can only be
instantiated by the child classes
through the internal mechanisms of java
itself and that's all I want to talk
about in this particular session where
we looked in detail about the concept of
abstraction couple of more things which
I did not cover in the previous session
I just want to call them out for clarity
Java does not support multiple
inheritance when I say multiple
inheritance what it means that you will
not have a scenario where a child will
be extending from two base classes Java
does not support support it it does
support it with the with the help of
interfaces but I will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions but
here just understand this that you
cannot use multiple inheritance with
classes in Java a child cannot have two
parent or two base classes in Java Java
will not allow that it is also called
The Diamond problem because the child
class does not know whether to follow
the route of Base 1 class or the base 2
class if it is extending from two
different base 1 and base two classes so
a class can only extend from one class
in Java we can find a workaround of it
by using the concept of interfaces but
that's something which will be coming
later another thing to understand is
that when you create an abstract class
here these variables you can declare
declare these variables as well and
these variables will be accessible by
all the child classes as you access them
let's get started with polymorphism so
polymorphism is a very generic concept
we which means that a particular object
can take multiple form let's not even
call it as object let's make it more
generic a particular entity can take
multiple forms if any entity in Java
exhibits that kind of behavior then we
say that polymorphism is in action that
entity can be a class or an object or
even a method and in today's session we
are going to talk about that type of
polymorphism which is exhibited by
methods so we will see how a particular
method in Java can take many different
forms containing different Logics but
still having the same name and that
concept is called method overloading so
whenever you hear the word that you need
to overload a particular method or this
is Method overloading happening
technically or conceptually it's
basically polymorphism in action and
polymorphism is being applied on a
method here and that phenomena we call
as method overloading so in today's
session we are going to have a look at
how we can Implement method overloading
in Java so the basic idea of method
overloading is that the name of the
method should remain the same so you see
in this particular class which I have
created to demonstrate the method
overloading so this is the class name
and the method name which I am going to
overload is called multiply and that is
probably the first thing which you need
to remember to implement over method
overloading correctly that the method
name is going to remain the same the
type of the return of the method may
change here you see it's returning in
here in the first instance in the second
instance also it is returning int but in
the third instance it is returning
double so the return type of an
overloaded method can change another
another thing which which can be varied
between same method being defined again
and again is that the number of
arguments and the type of arguments the
first multiply method takes two
arguments of integer type the second
multiply method takes three arguments of
integer type and the third multiply
method takes two arguments of double
type so by using method overloading you
can vary the number of arguments and
also the type of arguments so the basic
idea is that you declare you define the
method using the same name but you do a
variation in the arguments or the return
types and that's how you technically
Implement method overloading in this
case in this particular case the
multiply is the method being overloaded
and in the first case it is accepting
two integer arguments and returning the
result of multiplication of those
arguments in the second case the same
method name multiply here the same
visibility public and the same return
type but this time three different types
of integer values can be accepted and
this method multiply method is going to
return the multiplication of three
integer numbers in the third case at
line 15 I again use the same multiply
name the method name but this time the
return type becomes double and this
method accepts two double arguments and
Returns the result of the multiplication
of these double values so the method
name is same but the arguments vary and
also the return type may also vary
that's the basic premise of how you
implement method overloading so whenever
you want to implement it keep the method
name same vary the arguments and the
return types and after that I have just
created a public static void main method
here I have initialized the class here
this particular class itself method
overloading demo and then I am calling
the multiply method on the object and
based on the number of arguments I
Supply the corresponding method will get
invoked that is something which Java
will take care automatic automatically
that's whatever type and the number of
arguments you supply in the call in the
invocation based on the number and the
type of the arguments Java will try to
find a matching method in the overloaded
methods if it is able to find the method
it's going to get invoked if it is not
able to find the method you will get an
error in fact you will get a compile
error itself while you invoke a method
which for which the definition is not
available for example if I try to just
copy this and make an invalid invalid
method invocation let's provide four
arguments and if I do that here itself I
will get the error because Java is not
able to find a multiply method in this
particular class which is accepting four
integer arguments so you will get the
compilation error itself before you can
even run the program but the basic idea
is that you use overloading with
multiple different types and the number
of variables so I'm calling multiply
three times let's run this particular
program and observe the output so let me
just bring this output down yep so first
I call demo.multiply and pass two
integer values 10 and 20. when this
happens this particular method gets
invoked and it is it returns a result of
10 into 20 which is 200. in the second
invocation I'm calling again the
multiply method but this time with three
arguments three integer arguments
specifically and this call is going to
match this particular method signature
and it is going to execute whatever is
written inside this particular method
which is the multiplication of the three
arguments being supplied so 10 into 20
into 30 which is 6000 the third case
let's go back here at line 25 the third
case of invocation of the multiply
method is accepting two decimal based
arguments 10.5 and 20.5 so Java is going
to look at the class and trying to find
a method which can accept decibel values
and there it is this is the method
signature which is going to match the
invocation Java is going to do this
matching automatically for you and here
whatever logic you have written inside
this particular method we will get
executed so 10.5 into 20.5 returns
215.25 and that's the output you get so
this is how you can use method
overloading in Java this is a rather
fairly simple example but you can make
it as complex as you want but a word of
caution do not use it too extensively in
fact lot of expert programmers do not
recommend using method overloading
because it becomes very confusing use it
only when you do not have any other way
out use it only where this is the only
way to write correct form of methods
with the right readability otherwise
generally there would be other ways to
avoid method overloading by writing
concrete purpose friendly method names
themselves maybe you don't need to use
the multiply name again again you can
call it as multiply two numbers multiply
three numbers multiply doubles so that
the method name itself is more explicit
and understandable rather than juggling
around different signatures of the same
method especially it becomes more
confusing if you are creating an
interface which is to be consumed by a
third party developers or third-party
application so try to use it with
caution that's what I'm trying to stress
here let's get started with method
overriding in Java so in the previous
session we discussed about method
overloading concept now in this session
we'll focus on another interesting
concept by which you can have the same
signature of the method again and again
be used in your code but in a different
way and this concept is called method
overriding method overriding basically
is used together with the concept of
inheritance you won't you will not be
able to use the concept of method
overriding without using the concept of
inheritance remember when we talked
about inheritance I spoke about the
subclass and the parent class concept
sometimes we also call the parent class
as superclass so the basic idea is that
if a super class defines a method
remember I'm using the word Define here
if the super class uses the defines a
particular method and then the subclass
again tries to define the method with
the exact same signature this phenomena
is called method overriding now when you
do method method overriding there are
some rules to follow and I'm showing you
a tabular structure here a table
basically which will show you what is
possible and what is not possible when
it comes to Method overriding so let's
try to understand this table so if you
try to define a method with the same
signature as a super class method the
rules follow as per the stable let's go
with the first one if you have an
instance method defined in the super
class instance method is the normal
method which you define in your in your
classes so if you have defined an
instance method in your super class and
if you define a method in the subclass
with the exact same signature then that
concept is called method overriding and
it will be a successful override
override also let me also explain what
override means here override means that
once you try to initialize the subclass
object you will be able to invoke its
own overridden method definition if you
call that particular method the
subclasses own instance method is going
to get invoked rather than the super
classes instance method we'll look at
that when we look at the example as well
but that's the normal scenario when
where your superclass defines an
instance method and subclass also
defines the an instance method with the
exact same method signature that concept
is called method overriding what if your
super class defines a static method
static method is is basically a method
which belongs to the class but not to
the object instance method is called
instance method normal method is called
instance method because it belongs to
the object you can call the method on
the object but static methods are called
by class so you say class name dot
static method name but when you when you
call instance methods you just call
object name dot instance method name so
that is the basic difference the static
methods belong to the class once you
have defined a static method the same
static method will be available to all
the objects of the class but instance
method are unique to each object so that
was a short tour of what static methods
mean so if you define a static method in
the super class and then if you try to
Define an instance method with the same
signature in the subclass you will get a
compilation error it will not be allowed
it's not allowed in Java to override a
static method from Super class that's
what it says next one if your super
class has a normal instance method and
then the sub class tries to use the same
signature but creates a static method
out of it then again you will get a
compilation error so that the overriding
of an instance method to a static method
is not allowed and the last concept is
again a very interesting concept and a
very popular interview question about
method hiding so if the super glass
defines a static method and the subclass
also defines the static method with the
exact same signature then the super
class is static method gets hidden it
basically hides the superclass method so
that's the basic idea behind over method
overriding so if you see technically
it's a form of polymorphism because the
same method is having multiple
definitions but when we looked at the
previous example the multiple
definitions were in the same class here
the multiple definitions are in
different classes and those classes are
having a parent-child relationship that
was about the theory of it let's go to
an example of it to understand it better
and I've used again the same construct
of bicycle and mountain bike which we
have been using in this in this series
just to maintain continuity so I have a
parent class called bicycle here which
has two properties gear and speed it has
a Constructor nothing unusual there and
then it has defined three methods set
gear apply brake and speed up set gear
is just setting the new value as the
gear value apply break is going to
decrement the speed by the value you
supply and speed up is going to
increment the speed by the value you
supply simple this is exactly what we
have seen before now mountain bike tries
to extend bicycle so mountain bike
becomes a child class it defines a
variable called seat height defines a
Constructor called super hair nothing
unusual so far also defines a Setter for
height center for the seat height not
exactly following the center construct
but this is just to set the height but
here things get interesting let me just
bring this down a bit Yeah so here it is
overriding all the three methods of the
base class and by overriding it is
providing its own implementation of the
same methods let's compare them here
when it overrides the gear and whatever
value you supply it adds 2 to the plus
two to that value and then sets that
value as the gear value but in case of
Base Class it was just setting the new
value as the gear value so for instance
for instance if you supplied one here
the gear value becomes one but here if
you supplied one the gear value becomes
three similarly when you apply break on
the mountain bike class whatever value
you supply will be subtracted from the
current speed and 10 would be subtracted
even more so if the speed is let's say
50 and your decrement you supply the
decrement value as 10 so it will be 50
minus 10 minus 10 equal to 30 but in
case of bicycle if the speed was 50 and
you supply 10 then it would be just 50
minus 10 40. so there is and there is
extra 10 being subtracted from the speed
when you apply break in case of a
mountain bike similarly for speed up its
increment of 10 in addition to what's
what value you supply so again if the
speed was 10 and you supplied 10 here in
the argument so 10 plus 10 plus 10 30
will become the new speed in case of
mountain bike but in case of bicycle if
you supply 10 and if the current speed
was also 10 then it becomes 10 plus 10
only 20. so that's the difference so the
basic idea I hope you get the basic idea
here is that you override the methods
and your own class provide its own
implementation of those methods that's
the basic premise of method overwriting
all good so far and you do not have a an
uh an obligation to override all of the
methods because here here we have the
concrete implementation of the methods
so here in case of mountain bike you can
skip overriding one of the methods if
you like to this is also fine there will
be no compilation error because speed up
has a concrete implementation in the
bicycle class as well so it's up to you
how much you want to override so let's
move to the main class now so in the
main class we have created the public
static void main method here and let's
look at what is happening inside the
class first we initialize the bicycle
glass so bicycle class reference and
bicycle class object nothing unusual
here we Supply the gear value and the
speed value then we print the gear and
the speed value we apply break on the
bicycle and then we observe the new
speed of the bicycle after applying the
brakes let me comment out the rest of
the code and let's observe the output
for only this part of the code which we
just walked through for this section so
if I run this as a Java application and
if I show you what I'm getting what I'm
getting here so bicycle gear is one
which is what is supplied in the
Constructor bicycle speed is 10 which is
again what is supplied in the
Constructor then you applied break and
when you apply break this logic gets
executed and you supplied one here so
current speed was 10 so 10 minus 1
becomes 9 and the new speed becomes 9
which is what you are printing here so
far so good let's move on to the next
section let me comment out the previous
section now and let me uncomment this
section so here I have a bicycle
reference but the object is of mountain
bike remember this concept this is this
is called Dynamic object binding concept
or dynamic binding concept again this
might be asked in your interviews so
here I am initializing the mountain bike
with a reference of bicycle remember
whatever is written on the right hand
side will govern the variables and the
methods usage we'll we'll see how that
works out what I just said so I am
supplying three values here 50 50 and 3
in the mountain bike uh if I go here in
the mounted by Constructor so the start
height start Speed and gear are the
three values which is supplied as 50 50
and 3. then I am accessing the gear and
the speed now remember gear and speed
are declared in the bicycle class but
they are accessible in the child class
due to the inheritance phenomena which
we have already covered so if I print
only this part I should get the expected
values mountain bike gear is three which
which is what I have supplied here and
mountain bike speed is 50 which is which
is what I have supplied here then I
apply the brakes now let's move on to
this section I apply the brake supply
the value as 1 and then I want to see
what would be the new speed after
applying the brakes so let's see what
happens when we run this particular code
so if I run this code after applying the
brakes the speed becomes 39 before
applying the brakes the speed was 50. so
what happened here is 50 minus 1
basically this this logic is getting
executed here 50 minus 1 minus 10 which
becomes 39 that's why you get the value
as 39 as the new speed similarly if you
want to call another method as speed up
speed up method was also defined here
where I'm saying speed plus the argue
event supplied plus 10 so the current
speed is 39 right now then I am speeding
It Up by 10 so by this logic 39 plus 10
plus 10 which will become 59 and then
I'm printing the new speed after
speeding up so let's see what happens so
if I go to run as Java application and
if I observe all the outputs the speed
was 50 initially after applying the
brakes the speed became 39 and after
speeding up the speed became 59 so this
was a quick demo to show you the power
of method overriding and how you can
override the behavior which is defined
in the Base Class let's get started with
exception handling in Java using try and
catch blocks so in the previous session
we had a look at the scenarios where an
exception can occur how do we see that
there's a runtime exception or there's a
checked exception or there's an
unchecked exception or there is a custom
exception now we did not talk about how
to handle those exceptions and now we
are going to focus on the handling part
so whenever you have to handle those
exceptions the way Java provides for
that is using the try catch block
so try catch block is basically a bunch
of syntax which you have to follow to
handle different types of exceptions in
your programming code
and the syntax of the try catch block is
pretty straightforward you write try and
you put curly braces and then you write
whatever code
which might throw an exception you don't
know that but it's always safer to
enclose your code in a try catch block
so that you know that if an exception
occurs in the try block then you can
handle it in the catch block so it's a
it's always considered a better practice
to enclose your application code in a
try catch block so that you can handle
the exceptions so you put this try block
and write write all the suspicious or
non-suspicious code which may or may not
throw an exception inside the try block
once you have done the try block part
then comes the catch block part
so let me go to the catch block
so this is how the syntax look like once
you have written the try block then you
write catch
and you put braces and you write the
exception type which this block of code
might throw or the exception type which
you are interested in catching you might
not be interested in catching all the
different exceptions but only a few Ones
based on your business requirements so
whatever exception type you want to
catch you are going to catch it like
this
and if an exception occurs in the try
code let's say you have specified an
arithmetic exception here and if any
line of code in the dry block throws an
arithmetic exception then this catch
block is going to catch that exception
and then inside these curly braces you
can decide what to do with that
exception whether you want to log that
exception or whether you want to read
through that exception whether you want
to embed some error code or get an error
code out of it or convert that exception
into a business or custom exception of
your own choice so it's up to you what
you want to do with that but catch block
will be able to catch that arithmetic
exception
similarly you can specify as many
exception types to be caught as you want
and keep adding more and more catch
blocks
remember that these catch blocks work in
a in a sequential fashion so if an
exception occurs here it will first go
to this particular block to match the
exception type if it didn't match then
only it will move to the second type if
it did match the first type it is not
going to execute the second type so that
is how the try catch block work
you can see an example here that if the
code here is throwing an index out of
bond exception then it is going to be
caught here and we are just printing the
index out of one exceptions message if
it is throwing an i o exception then I
can do this so you can keep adding
different checked and unchecked
exceptions in the catch block
you can also catch more than one type of
exception with one exception Handler so
rather than writing these multiple catch
Blocks individually you can combine
these exceptions together if your logic
of processing both of these exceptions
is the same
remember if the logic of processing
these two exceptions is the same logic
means whatever you write inside these
curly braces so if that code is going to
be the same for both of these exceptions
then why bother writing two catch blocks
just write one catch block like this use
the pipe operator to separate different
types of exceptions and write the common
code which is going to be applied if
your try block is going to throw an IO
exception or an SQL exception so that
depends upon you
that's the second piece the third piece
of the try block is the finally blocked
so we talked about the dry block we
talked about the catch block now there's
a finally block as well remember this is
finally and not final
the finally block is used together with
the try catch block when you want to
perform some cleanup operations
imagine you are opening up a file
Handler
in the try block you're doing something
with it and then you want to just close
the file Handler irrespective of the
fact if there was an exception in the
try block or not because even if there
was an exception the file Handler
resource is going to remain open and is
going to consume memory in your
application you might you don't want to
do that similarly if you opened a
database connection inside your try
block
irrespective of the fact of what happens
in the try block you always would like
to close the database connection and you
can write that closing code in the
finally block that's the purpose of the
finally block that you can write the
code inside the finally block which is
supposed to be always executed
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurs or doesn't occur
so now we have built a good
understanding of what is the try catch
what is what is the try blocks catch
block and the finely block now if you
just put it all together
this is how it is going to look like
that you write the try block you do
something inside the try block
then you write the catch blocks
after that you write the final block
you can write the finely block without
the catch block as well remember that if
you do not have any exception to catch
but you have some resources to close or
free up after executing the try block
you can skip the catch block and just
write try finally that is also possible
with that understanding let's switch to
the IDE and let's look at some example
so I have a writer helper class which is
having a method called right list I have
a try block here
and this try block is basically
initializing an error list adding an
item to the error list and then I'm
accessing list dot get one
remember when I added this particular
value let me make it 10 to make it more
understandable when I added 10 to this
particular list this goes to the index 0
position and here I am trying to access
index one position which does not have
anything
so in such case it might throw an error
because there is nothing at least not
get one so this is my method where I put
the try block code and then because I
don't want to end up in a position where
I get an index outer Bond exception
index outer bonds exception comes if you
are trying to access an index which is
illegal which is does not having any
value
so I'm putting a catch block and
catching the index out of bound
exception and just printing the message
of the exception and then for just for
Simplicity I'm showing a finally block
as well though I do not have any
resource to close here but this is just
to show you how this looks like in the
code
this is just to show you at that
Printing and printing assist out here
this is what my method is and if I go to
the main class the try catch demo class
I'm creating an object of the writer
helper class and calling the right list
method which we just worked through
let's run this program and see what
happens
okay so first I get this statement
saying entering try statement so if I go
here
I call this method the execution goes
inside the try block and I get this is
out which says entering try statement
then I try to access the second element
in the list because the position is one
this is going to index 0 and I'm trying
to access index 1 there is nothing at
index 1 so I get an error saying index
out of bounds exception index 1 out of
bounds for length 1.
because the total length of the list
currently is 1 because there's just one
element and that one element is sitting
at 0 and not one
so I get the exception which is the
index outer Bond exception but the index
outer Bond exception is caught by my
catch block and the system dot error dot
println is something which gets executed
and I get this particular
line this particular line
from this line number 17. and then
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurred or not my final block
always gets executed
let's fix this and see if the finely
block gets executed even if there is no
exception so now accessing gets you and
let's see what happens
foreign
no exception but the finary block still
gets executed so this is to assert our
understanding that the finally block
will always be executed irrespective of
the fact whether there was an exception
or there wasn't
now you can also Nest different try
blocks if you want to
let's look at an example where I have
multiple dry blocks so you can initi you
can write a try within a try within a
try if you want and you can go as deep
as you want but remember the more
indentations the more hierarchy you
create the program is going to get more
and more complex so always remember to
have that kind of trade-off
so I write multiple try blocks I
initialize an array I print added 10
obviously added 10 does not exist
because this array has just four
elements so this is bound to through an
index out of bound exception and I'm
catching that exception immediately in
the catch block this is the exception
printing assists out and just to read
through in the exception you can also
read through the Exception by just using
the throw keyword remember this throw is
different from the throws keyword which
comes in the method signature this is
just to throw any exception from your
code
so this is array index out of bond
exception for this try block
then I have another array index outer
Bond exception for this try block
which starts from here block 2 and then
I have another catch block for the block
one try block
so you can see it is already getting a
bit complicated where I have multiple
hierarchies but you can do that
so this is what is happening in this
particular program now let's try to run
this and see what happens and try to
decipher the output
okay so at first I get this particular
line which says
array index out of bounds exception in
block three
what happens here is that this line gets
executed
it throws an array index out of bounds
exception
at line 13 that array index out of
bounds exception is caught which was
generated from this line
and then we go inside the catch block we
execute this is out this is what you see
here the same Swiss out and then we read
through the exception
if we read through the exception the
exception goes to the enclosing try
block the enclosing try block is this
one
there was an exception rethrown from
this try block and now it has gone to
this try block
and now this try block block 2 will try
to see if it can catch this array index
out of bound exception yes we can catch
it so it can so so the block 2 again has
a catch block which catches the array
index out of bound and it prints assist
out here which says exception in Block
2.
which we see here and it again rethrows
the exception
and if it rethrows the exception so now
the block 2
now the block 2 is rethrowing the
exception so this whole code
is now rethrowing the exception if this
block 2 is rethrowing the exception it
goes to block one just going one
hierarchy up and then it sees if it can
handle the exception in the catch block
of this block one so yes the block one
try block also had a catch exception
which said array index out of bound E4
and here it just had a sys out
so if I just bring back the output yes
we do get this a particular exception uh
printed here which says array index out
of bounds exception in Block one this is
what you see here
and this is where the exception just
stops going propagated because I'm not
rethrowing the exception from this
particular catch block so that's where
the exception ends the reason you see a
hyperlink here is because the text
the text which I have printed here
exactly matches with the name of the
exception so Java is pretty smart in
that case if you use the exact same name
exception it will link it to the
matching class name in Java which is
pretty cool I also have a redundant
catch block here which does not have a
try block this is just to show you that
you can write a catch block without a
try block but it doesn't make sense it
is of no use so I can just remove this
particular catch block and the program
still will compile fine
so this was a quick demo to show you how
you can use try catch and finally blocks
and when would you use the finally block
and if you want you can use a nested
hierarchy of try blocks and you can
rethrow the exception from within the
catch block only to be caught in the
outside or the outer or the enclosing
block let's get started with hash set in
Java if you remember I covered in the
collections framework session that has
set is part of the set interface
hierarchy and sets have a property that
they keep the collections element unique
if you try to add duplicate elements to
the a set it will not accept that and it
will still maintain the uniqueness
property of the collection hash set
provides some additional features to the
set which is that in this case the
elements would be accessed in a random
fashion they will not be accessed in a
fixed sequence rather they will be
accessed in a random fashion hence the
name has set so if you read about this
particular class in the documentation it
will basically cover all the things
which I just described it also accepts
null elements if you want to insert null
but why would you try to insert null
that's the first question which you
should ask it again provides similar
kind of utility methods to the list
interface collection hierarchy we
covered like some utility methods to add
the elements to remove the elements to
check the size of the collection and to
check if an element exists in the
collection or not etc etc and we will
cover some of these methods in the demo
this is again not synchronized so this
is not a thread safe collection which
you should know so let's look at a
demonstration of hash set and how do we
actually create a headset how do we
operate upon a headset using different
utility methods so as you can see I have
created a class here which is called
hash set demo there is a public static
void main method and and then at line
number 10 you will see that I have
created the hash set and again it starts
with the concrete class here which says
hash set and you can obviously write it
as set as well which will also work fine
so we write the set type as string so
this particular set is going to hold
only and only string objects and nothing
else and this set is basically a type of
hash set again this is not mandatory so
you can remove that it will still not
complain and the program will run fine
if you want to specify a size please do
that if you do not want to specify the
size nothing goes wrong and it will be
initialized with the default memory
footprint but remember doing this wastes
a bit of memory so if you are running
this program on a machine which is
really tight on memory always put some
kind of initialization size based on
your knowledge of how many elements are
going to be stored in this collection so
after that at line number 12 we start
adding elements to this collection and
for adding the elements the method which
is provided by the hash set class is ADD
so you use the add method to add new
elements so at line number 12 line
number 13 14 and 15 I use the method
again and again to add some elements If
You observe the line number 14 and the
line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so I am trying
to add C twice to this particular hash
set and we will observe the output to
see what happens if we try to add
duplicate elements in the hash set
because if you remember the sets are
supposed to be unique they should not be
storing duplicate elements that's the
property of sets so that's what I
demonstrate by by adding duplicate
elements to see how it behaves and let's
do that let me comment the rest of the
code for a while and let's run just this
part of the code where I add C twice and
I print the hash set and let's see what
happens so I go to run as and I click on
Java application and I only see three
elements even though I added four I only
see three and C has been added only once
not twice now you might be wondering
whether this C is the C added at line 14
or the C added at line 15. so to
understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works so this
add method is basically returning a
Boolean value if the element is added
successfully this ad is going to return
true and if the element could not be
added successfully this add method is
going to return false so let's do that
let's store the result of these ad
methods let's call this R1 and let's
call this one as R2
okay and now we will try to print R1 and
R2 and see what happens so if we write
system dot out Dot println and I say R1
and then I just copy this after line 16
and write R2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which when we did
the ad at 14 and when we did the ad at
16 which actually resulted in C getting
added did C get overwritten or did C did
not add twice what happens
so we see that when we do the ad at line
14 we get true so it means that this ad
was successful and C was added here and
when I did the ad again at line 16 this
returned a false it means the hash set
rejected this add operation so this C
was not added so the actual C was never
overwritten the original C was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that
so that actually proves that the set
will maintain the uh the uniqueness
property and it will reject all the
duplicates subsequently that was about
the add property now let's understand
another interesting property of the
contains method contains method of this
set class is used to find if an element
exists in the set or not so you can just
use the hash set variable name dot
contains and just type the actual
element and this is going to return true
or false based on whether this element
is present in the hash set or not
present in the hash set if it is present
then this contains method is going to
return true otherwise it is going to
return false so let's run this method
and observe the output at line 21.
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain C or not and it returns true
because yes my half set does contain C
now coming to line 23 I use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
I'm again doing a sound and I'm asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list
so then I'm checking if what happens to
my hash set if I call the remove method
and I'm just printing the modified hash
set at line 24. so let's see what
happens with the effect of remove
operation okay so after removing a this
is what remains in my hash set and a has
been successfully dropped if I call the
remove method and then I try to just
iterate over the hash set to show you
how does this iteration work it again
works on exactly the same way it has
been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
column you write the collection name so
hash set and on the LHS of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and I'm printing all
the items one by one
so if I run this I am able to print B
and C because that's all which is
remaining in this hash set so this was a
very quick demo to show you the
functionalities of the hash set how does
hash set maintains uniqueness how do you
remove elements how do you add elements
how do you check for an element's
existence using contains there's also a
method to get the element of the hash
set if you want to so these are all the
different properties and methods
available in the hash set and do check
it check out the API documentation of
the hash set to learn about more methods
so that's all I wanted to cover in this
particular session where we focus only
on hash set and in the next session we
will be discussing about three sets and
we will also see an example of how do we
Implement presets in Java let's get
started with three sets in Java so in
the previous session we talked about
about hash set which is one of the
implementation of the set hierarchy and
today we'll be focusing on preset and if
you remember when we talked about this
collection framework I discussed briefly
about preset that the main reason you
will use tree set is basically when you
want to maintain natural ordering of the
elements if you are adding your custom
elements then you need to tell Java how
to compare and sort and order the
elements but that's for another day when
we'll cover about the detailed
comparable and comparator interfaces for
now what you can understand that
whenever you have to maintain the
natural order of the elements
automatically then you should use preset
along with that the set property still
holds true that this tree set cannot
have duplicate elements we should also
know that reset is not synchronized so
it is not a thread safe collection so we
we remember be aware that whenever you
are trying to use preset in a
multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
three set works as expect affected okay
that was about a brief theory about the
preset you can read about about it in
detail in this tree set documentation
class and with that let's switch to a
demonstration of the preset class so
I've prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight I am initializing that
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
on only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs I'm just saying new preset and
again this is not mandatory so I can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine after that from line number
but 10 till line number 13 I'm again
going to add some elements and again if
you see I'm adding elements in random
order I'm adding B and then I'm ordering
adding a then I am adding C twice just
to show you the uniqueness property of
the tree set does it still hold true or
not we will be able to figure that out
from this particular example and we will
also see if I am adding B before a will
it be printed in a fashion called BAC or
will it be printed in a fashion called
ABC we should also know that so let's
try to run this program and understand
the output
so if we look at the output we see a
before B but here when we added the
elements we saw B before a we added B
first and then we added a and then we
added C twice and as per the uniqueness
property of this set the second uh
addition statement at line number 13
returned false and set rejected this
addition because it could see that c was
already present in this particular
collection so C is added only once but
what's interesting is that b is added
first but B is added B is printed after
a so the natural order of the elements
in this collection is automatically
maintained by preset so what under the
hood reset does here that it looks at
the type which is a predefined type in
Java string is a predefined class in
Java so it will use its own sorting
algorithm to sort the strings based on
their natural order of sequence and in
the natural order of sequence a will
always come before B and B will always
come before c so it will automatically
apply that sorting and will present the
result to you if you are using a custom
class here let's say your own student
class or your own customer class or your
own account class in that case that
account class or student class or
customer class needs to tell Java how to
sort elements and for that you need to
write comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you you must understand that
whatever the type of class you are
specifying here should tell Java how to
sort the elements either Java should
know it automatically if it's a
predefined class like string or integer
or float or double then Java would
automatically know by default how to
sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
three set and specifying that as the
preset type then you should also tell
Java how to sort the customers whether
you want to sort them based on your
first name whether you want to sort them
based on their age their salary Java
doesn't know that so you need you need
to tell Java about that if you're trying
to use a custom class as the type entry
set in this particular example I'm using
string here and it will apply the
natural ordering let's put C here in the
very beginning to see what happens and I
can comment this as we have already
maintained and verified that c is only
printed once and added once so I'm
adding C B A and let's run this program
I still get ABC because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember I told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
headset again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
I use a hash set here sometimes it will
print ABC sometimes it will print BAC
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of
preset no matter how many times you run
it you will always get the same order
based on the Sorting implementation
available in the class type so that's
all I wanted to cover about preset
please read about read about its Java
documentation in the API docs to
understand what all other methods and
utilities reset provides but it's pretty
much similar to what we saw in the
hashtag example like remove or get etc
etc and contains Etc so all the all
similar methods are available in the
tree set class as well and that's all
we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we are
going to talk about an interesting
framework called Maps let's get started
with maps in Java so first of all before
we understand this particular diagram
and the classes in this map framework
let's understand why do we need map so
there would be instances when you would
write a Java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole mapping of the
employee ID to the employee name into
the Java program how do you do that you
need a key value sort of arrangement
where you can store the employee ID as
the keys and each of the employee ID key
would correspond to an employee name
which will be called the value so you
need a key and value arrangement in a
Java program to store that kind of
information and use that kind of
information in your program and that's
where map comes into to picture whenever
you have to store a key value
Arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice framework representation
of map and this is going to be a
theoretical lecture where we will
understand how this map framework Works
what is the property and what are the
different implementation classes and
then in the future sessions we will
again look at some examples of the most
popular map implementation classes which
are used in the Java world so again the
orange oval R interfaces the blue boxes
or the light blue boxes are the abstract
classes and the purple boxes are the
concrete classes so map is an interface
which will provide this kind of a
blueprint that every class underneath it
would be working on a key value
Arrangement when we talk about this key
value Arrangement so we have this keys
and we have the values so the keys here
are supposed to be unique the values can
contain duplicates remember this is a
very important concept that in map the
keys will be unique and the values can
have duplicate and because we want to
maintain the uniqueness in the keys part
that's why the keys are technically
stored as a set because we know that set
cannot contain duplicate sets are by
designed made to be storing only unique
elements so map uses the set class to
store its keys and to store the values
it generally uses a list class so you
can see map is basically reusing the
classes from the collections framework
sets for storing the keys and lists for
storing the values that's the basic
anatomy and basic idea of how map is
working now you see some classes here
called abstract map and sorted map and
again similar to the set hierarchy
whenever you see the sorted word and if
you look at the concrete class which is
called tree map this is going to provide
you some sort of an order sorting order
automatically and then you have the hash
map class and this class is going to be
providing a random access this will not
maintain the insertion order this will
not provide you a natural sorting order
this is just to store elements in random
order and the element here a single
element here is basically consisting of
two parts which is key and value always
remember that you also have hash table
here hash table is basically a
synchronized representation this is a
thread safe hash map and tree map are
non-thread safe so multiple threads if
you try to work in a multi-threading
program with these hash map and tree map
you are going to get very unpredictable
results but if you use hash table then
it is inherently thread safe so it will
only allow one thread to be to access
the hash table at a particular time you
will also you will also be thinking then
then it's always better to use hash
table right because you will never get
into those weird errors and you don't
have to migrate your program uh to a
multi-threaded environment whenever you
are trying to use hash tables yes that
is true but hash tables are slower for
the same reason because only one thread
can can access it at a time and that's
why hash tables are slower and hashmap
and tree map are way way faster because
they allowed multiple access at the same
time so you have to always be mindful of
what kind of collection type you are
using there are some external ways as
well to make these hash maps and tree
maps and headset and preset and
arraylist and linked list as
synchronized as well and we will talk
about that in a future session but for
now you can understand that hash map
entry map are non-thread safe and hash
table are thread safe there is another
class which is uh which is coming out
from the hash map class which is called
linked hashmap and linked hashmap as the
name shows it will basically carry two
properties it will carry the property of
hash map where the elements are stored
or displayed or accessed in random order
and at the same time it is also
providing the linked property of the
linked list where the sequence is
maintained so you can see you can
actually get the insertion order if you
use a linked hash map the way in which
you insert the elements would always be
the way in which the elements will be
accessed so you are getting sort of a
ordering property but the order is the
insertion order it's not the natural
sort order it's the insertion order
that's why the name linked hash map
because it brings the linked list part
of the link property inside the hash map
where the elements would be presented to
you in the order they are inserted when
you call the add method so that's what
we covered here we covered about map
interface we covered about hash snap
class which is going to store the values
and the access will be random the value
means the element means a key and value
which sometimes also call this as an
element you will see that a
representation Sometimes some some
people also call it as iterable element
it's all the same thing but it's a key
and value Arrangement pre-map also
stores the key value Arrangement but it
will provide you a sorted representation
and here the Sorting will happen on the
keys not on the values the Sorting will
be happening the natural order of salt
which will be maintained by the tree map
is only applicable to the Keys here
similarly linked hashmap it will insert
the elements but when you try to access
it it will maintain the insertion order
no matter how many times you access it
it will only be presented to you in the
order the elements were inserted and
hash table is very similar to hashmap
with the difference that hash table is
thread safe multiple threads cannot
manipulate the hash table at a time it
will only let a single thread access
itself at a time so that's the property
of hash table the most popular classes
are generally these ones hashmap three
map and linked hashmap very rarely you
will also see hash table but since we
have some ways to get these synchronized
so generally you would not see much of
the hash table implementation let's get
started with hash maps in Java and now
we are looking at the API documentation
of the hash map class you can see the K
comma V here these are the types of the
key and the value which the hash map
will accept you can NC K is basically
the type of keys and V is basically the
type of mapped values like I explained
it's basically keys are stored in a set
fashion and values are stored in a list
collection fashion this is not by
default synchronized so if you want a
thread safe collection then you would
have to do something else which I will
cover in the future sessions this is a
very brief overview of what hashmap is
but let's look at the example to
understand better and then I will be
able to explain it in bit more detail so
now we are looking at an example which
is basically a class which is called
hashmap demo I have a main method here
and then at line number 10 I am
initializing the map and as you can see
that on the LHS we see the concrete
class hash map and I can do this and
this will still work provided you have
the import here I had the import here so
it will work fine and I'm saying that
this map is going to contain a key value
Arrangement where the keys are the
string type and the values are of the
type integer and it's ultimately a hash
map here I I don't need to again provide
the generics because I have already
provided the generics here
the name of the map is just simply a map
and again you can specify your size or
you can skip the size based on the
memory requirements and the program
requirements now coming to the point
where you want to add elements to the
map now since this is a key value
Arrangement here the name of the method
through which you are going to add
elements is put so you call map dot put
and then you provide the key
comma you provide the value that's the
Syntax for adding an element or we
technically call that element an entry
this key value together is called entry
so if you have to add an entry to the
map you have to write it in this way
where key comma value is the convention
so I'm adding three elements or three
entries here which is a comma 10 B comma
20 and C comma 30. ABC are basically the
keys and 10 20 and 30 are the
corresponding values of these Keys
respectively
after that I'm I'm showcasing another
utility method of this particular class
which you can use to find the size of
the map so you can just call map dot
size and it will print the size of the
map after that I am printing the actual
map the whole map and then I'm using
some more methods but again let's
comment this code and let's understand
this code one by one so that there is no
confusion
so to start with I'm going to add some
elements some entries and I'm going to
print the size of the map and the map
itself let's run this program
so here you can see the size of the map
is printed as three because I've added
three entries and then when I call map
inside the system.out.print Ln method I
get the whole map printed here and this
is how the map will look like when it is
printed we can see key equal to Value
syntax here where a equal to 10 b equal
to 20 and c equal to 30 are the key
value representations or the entries
here separated by comma enclosed by the
curly braces that's how our map looks
like so far so good the next thing which
I am going to Showcase to you is the
contains method and since the map has
this set which is the keys basically
that's why map provides a method called
contains key basically you can check if
a particular key is present in the map
or not and if you know the key is
present then it's very easy to get the
value from the key math will provide a
method also where you can supply the key
and get the value so knowing the key is
the most important part and that's why
map provides a method called contains
key so you can call this method specify
the key which you want to check for the
presence in the map it is going to check
whether a is present in this Maps key
set or not if the a is available in this
Keys we can see a is available then this
condition is going to hold true and then
like I said if you want to fetch the
value then you can call the get method
providing the key you can fetch the
value from the key that's the that's the
core idea which you should remember so I
call map dot get specify the key and
this is going to spit out the value
which is being pointed by this
particular key in this case a is
pointing to 10. when I say pointing it's
not pointer remember it's just a
reference so map dot get of a is going
to get the actual value which this key
is pointing to which is 10 and then I am
printing this integer a which is the
actual value pointed by this particular
key so let's run this program and see if
this works so we get these two outputs
from the above and then this is the
output which is coming from the if block
so it checked whether the map is
containing a key with the name a yes it
was able to find that and then we asked
the Java program to fetch the value
corresponding to this particular key so
we just called map dot get of a and it
fetched 10 and it printed 10 here that's
why you see 10 here okay so that's how
you can basically use the contain method
and the get method now what if you want
to iterate over all the keys what if you
what if you have to use the all the keys
and you have to make some pattern or
make some observation about all the keys
in your map you can do that by iterating
over the key set and for that map
provides a method called key set so you
just called map.keyset and this is going
to fetch all the keys in a set
representation and will be provided to
you so here when I call map.keyset this
is basically giving me a set which is
containing all the keys and then I'm
iterating over the keys one by one you
would be familiar with this syntax by
now which is the enhanced for Loop
syntax and inside this I am printing the
key which is the current temporary
variable holding the current key and the
value pointed by that particular key at
that particular step and I'm again using
the same method get which I which I
showed you here
same method so you provide the key and
you will get the value so I'm going to
get all the keys hydrate over the keys
and then print the key and the value
let's see how this looks like so till
this we were good and here you will see
the output which is coming out from this
particular for loop from this particular
for Loop line 25 to line 27 where I am
iterating over the key set printing the
key and value one by one so this is how
to show you if you just have access to
the key set you can still iterate over
the whole map but what if you know
everything you have access to the key
set you have access to the values and if
you was if you just want to iterate over
it then you can use this particular way
and instead of map.keyset you're going
to use map dot entry set if you remember
map treats each key value Arrangement as
a single entry entry is the keyword here
so map dot entry set is going to give me
all the entries in the map and then each
entry is basically of type entry class
this is the representation of each entry
and we know how this representation
formed entry is the class basically
which is coming out of this map uh
collection hierarchy and then let me
just save this and then string is the
key and integer is the value held by
each entry inside the map so that's what
we are going to do we are going to pick
up all the entries in the map and going
to iterate over the entries one by one
by writing this enhanced for Loop and
entry is the temporary variable which is
going to hold each entry one by one at
each step and then it's very simple we
call entry dot getkey you will get the
key and you call entry dot get value and
you will get the value so it's much much
simpler than this one where you had to
do map.get to understand here it's very
implicit get key is going to get you the
key and get value is going to get you
the value so you just need to call map
dot entry set iterate over the entry set
and get each entries key and value and
print them or do whatever your program
requires to be done that's how you will
use it so let's run this one as well to
verify if this works okay so this is the
output which is coming from the last
Loop this Loop basically you can see key
I did not put any space that's why you
see key a key B and Key C together let
me put a space here and put a hyphen so
that the output looks better and let me
rerun this yeah this is much better so
you can see the key a value 10 key B
value 20 and Key C value 30. this is
coming from this particular for Loop
which I just showed you so this is all I
wanted to cover in this particular
session we went deeper into the hash map
representation and we saw a bunch of
methods contains key key set entry set
get put Etc and we showed how we can use
the hashmap for different purposes in
the program in the next session we'll go
deeper into the tree map concept and
we'll also look at a demo of tree map
and we'll understand and how it works
let's get started with three maps in
Java now if you remember in the last
lecture we talked about hash maps in
Java and we also had a look at an
example where we saw how a hash Map
works and how we can use a hash map we
also had a look at different utility
methods of the hashmap as well now in
today's lecture we are going to focus on
tree Maps which is an another type of
map as we discussed when we were
discussing about the map framework and
the main property of a tree map is that
when you enter elements into a map they
will naturally be sorted or naturally be
ordered now when I say naturally ordered
what it means that if you put the keys
as let's say integer then the tree map
will automatically sort all the map
entries in an integer sorted fashion
where you'll see the natural number
sorting uh Behavior like one two three
and so on similarly if you store Alpha
bits or strings then they then those
will be sorted in a natural sorting
alphabetical order starting from A to Z
so these are the uh these are the data
types which the Java is already aware of
on how to sort them like integers
doubles floats strings Etc but there can
be a case where you have your custom key
this particular key is your own custom
class if that is the behavior or if that
is the scenario then in that case you
will have to provide an implementation
to Java to know how to sort those
elements because Java doesn't know for
example a student class or an account
class Java doesn't know how to sort that
so if you have that kind of scenario
then in those cases you will have to
provide your own sorting implementation
and we will cover about what kind of
sorting implementation you can provide
in those kind of scenarios in the
upcoming lectures for now we will look
at have a look at an example of tree map
where you can see that I have created a
class which is called tree map demo and
I have initialized a tree map with the
keys as integer and the values as string
so this means that each entry of the map
will have key as the integer value and
the value of that particular entry will
be of string type so basically an
integer to string mapping is what each
entry of this tree map is going to store
so nothing different here you would have
already seen this kind of this kind of
initialization for any kind of map and
after that at line 11 I use the standard
put method of the map and I started
storing the values so at line 11 I'm
saying store 3 and a so 3 is the key and
string a remember this is not a
character this is a string we because I
have specified string here if you
specify a character here and if you try
to store a string this is going to throw
an error and you need to fix that so I
store 3 as the key and a as string as
the value similarly at line 12 I store 2
as the key and B as the value and at
line c i store 1 as the key and C as the
value so these integers are the keys and
the string are the values and if I just
put them and if I just try to print them
what happens what kind of order can we
expect let's try to analyze that so I
right click on this I go to run as and I
go to run as Java application it will
run the program because I have a static
void main method and now you see that
the map is printed in a different
fashion than the way it was added we
added the map elements in this sequence
that we added 3A first 2B second and 1C
as the third element but when we started
printing them we saw one C printed first
to be printed second and 3C 3A printed
third so what this denotes that this
tree map because the key was integer
here it automatically sorted these Keys
into a natural order sorting and it
provided when I tried to access the map
it provided the access in that salted
sequence only no matter how many times
you run this particular program it is
always going to return the map in the
same format in the same sequence the
sequence of representation of the
elements is not going to change and you
can basically do the similar behavior
for example if I just change this to
string and integer let's do it like this
and if I again swap the elements here as
well I say a comma 3 and I say B comma 2
and here I can say C comma 1. if I do
this I just switch the keys and values
position now the string is the key and
the integer is the value and let me just
put these two before a so that we can
demonstrate the behavior of the tree map
properly so I am inserting B2 first and
C one second and A3 third and I just
save this file and now let's run this
file and let's see how the output comes
so now you can see that since the key is
now string it has applied it has
automatically applied the natural
sorting ordering of strings which is
starting from a going till z and that's
why you see a entry as the first entry B
entry as a second entry and the C entry
as the third entry again no matter how
many times you run it or you iterate
over it you try to access it you will
always get the sequence in the same
fashion so this is a basic overview of
how tree Maps work now you can and I
would strongly recommend you to go and
read about all the other methods which
are available in the tree map which you
can use for example how can you remove
elements how can you uh how can you
iterate the elements of the tree map Etc
in fact the iteration is is going to be
exactly the same way as we have seen in
the case of hash Maps because iteration
Behavior doesn't change but to uh if you
want to see what all different kinds of
methods pre-map support it supports a
lot of different methods we can't cover
all of them in this short tutorial but I
would strongly recommend you to go and
read the javadocs API of the tree map to
get familiar with those methods so that
you know what kind of functionalities
pre-map can provide in this we are going
to talk about the maven here now we will
be talking about that how exactly we can
make use of Maven here in performing
various kind of operations whether it's
a burial compilation with this kind of
stuff there so let's talk about it why
exactly we use Maven here now Maven is
something which is a kind of a build
tool which is there for most of the
job-based projects here so this tool
also helps us in building up the source
code by downloading some couple of
dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that uh the project is dependent on and
he requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a jar based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the day-to-day work of a Java
developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now uh Maven also helps us in
getting the uh specific jar files for
each and every project so if you are
going you can pretty much make a jar
file bar file or your file any kind of a
package mechanism you can follow for
your Maven there so to download the
dependencies we don't have to actually
go to the official website of each and
every software you can easily get it uh
the dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnreepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific uh project over here so it
totally depends on how exactly you want
to download and you want to get together
a specific repository over here so mwin
repository.com is the one if you visit
you will be able to download and go
through all the jar files dependent jar
files as independencies which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is on Maven
all about so let's see on that part so
Maven is a popular open source Bell tool
which is uh developed by the Apache
group and the primary ownership of this
tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once Maven is
written in Java and it can be used to
build projects written in C sharp Scala
Ruby Etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a jar
based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a Java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build perspective tasks
on the projects
right now Maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as in
Project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take care of all the following same
builds dependencies reports distribution
releases mailing list so all these uh
things are being taken care as in this
particular process here and ultimately
it's an availability inside the maven
that how the overall build process needs
to be automated and standardized here so
all these particular mechanisms is can
be followed as such over here so that we
can have a good standards and the
simplifications implemented as such here
now what exactly is an Maven repository
all about
so Maven repository is something which
is uh kind of a directory or it's kind
of a location where we have all the jar
files packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
Java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the pump files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows Maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositives from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for our specific Maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right now the local repository will be
primary present onto your PC that's the
way that how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it on to the Internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is safe so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from remote repository it's
first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and Central repository is refers to the
miemann drip Community repository there
where you will be able to see each and
and every dependency present on that
repository so Maven downloads the
repositories from here in the local
repository whenever they're needed or
whenever required all these dependencies
are cached locally from where it will be
referenced in the next or you know
whenever we want to refer that we will
be able to do that particular reference
easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories are Maven
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
Maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in Maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project Palm
reference to the XML file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this XML file in this particular form
reference file as such over here the XML
file is which is there in the project
home directory so Maven is something
which search for the pump file in the
current directory if it's able to find
that particular pump file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise the it will hold
there itself so this powerful is very
important because it will act as a kind
of a build script and primarily the
maven tool will be able to process each
and everything which is configured as
such in this specific XML file there and
according to that only it will function
or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
jar files so the Java libraries which we
need in our into our particular project
so while working on the project we may
be having the dependency on couple of
dependencies so these dependencies we
have to actually download or we have to
actually refer and once these are a
particular information or these details
are referred so what will happen that uh
we need to download these uh specific
dependencies from the particular Maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then Maven will try to download it from
the central repository and cache it into
your local repository but first of all
it will look on into the local
repository and if it is not present in
local then only it will go to the remote
or the central Repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goes there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to performing the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugin cm then we have the build profile
so build profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven's build script
here
then with different build profiles are
added to the pump files and which
enables the different uh build as such
here so depending on these profiles we
can actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build order
missions needs to be performed here then
a build profile helps in customizing the
build for the different environments so
that also we can perform as such while
work forming or while working on the
different components and the different
management here so a build profile is
something which you can configure you
can utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to design on that
particular Factor so these are something
which we need to take here or we need to
work according to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here
now usually when we go for the uh Maven
there so we have to use some couple of
Maven plugins now the goal of using
these uh specific plugins is to automate
some of the basic stuff like compilation
creating the VAR file creating the jar
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so Maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh we know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and you
can pretty much have some specific goals
executed with the help of these build
plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in Maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of Maven here so the maven executable
when it's deployed so it usually uh
reads the palm.xml file which is the
build script here now once the specific
bounded XML file is being read out so it
will process the components it will uh
you know download or it will process the
dependencies plugins life cycles phases
and goals and even the build profiles
and uh if any kind of interaction is
required so it will try to connect to
the central repository or remote
repository and according to that it will
provide the information and provide the
details as such so Maven repository is
something which is very important
because it's ultimately trying to
connect to the maven repository and try
to achieve the various kind of
automation here so it's very important
because ultimately it's trying to help
us to go for the complete end-to-end
build automation when we'll go for a
specific Palm based build automation
so um Maven is going to read the
palm.xml file then download the
dependencies defined into the power XML
file and that dependencies are cached
locally from the remote or the central
repository now then create and generate
a remote a report according to the
requirement and execute the life cycles
phases goals plugins
Etc so it will process the boundary XML
file then and whatever the plugins and
goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build
lifecycle is something which is a kind
of a collection of different steps there
and this is something which is followed
uh to perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the bevel level which
you can utilize to perform a various
kind of particular steps execution for
your project
right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds these are the different phases
and these stages which we normally
follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific Maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of Maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of benefits the first
one is that Apache Mi one helps manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation releasing and distribution
in project management here so the tool
simplifies the process of project
building it increases the performance of
the project and the building process all
together and the task of downloading jar
files and other dependencies is also
done automatically we don't have to
indulge in any kind of download part as
such manually over here
right and Maven provides easy access to
all the required information so Maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the particular or built onto this
Jenkins or any kind of build tool there
right in Maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the specific palm.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair right so let's talk
about the demo now so let's see that how
exactly we can go for this demo and we
can perform the various kind of
automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so Maven will be available as in 3.6.3
here now I'm going to run a particular
command called mvn archetype generate
here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
type
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will download some
of the binders there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so couple
of a particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that vertical
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
which kind of version we want to follow
so I'm going to follow like five here so
I'll press five
then a group ID which is there so it's
basically a kind of a group mechanism so
I can say like com dot simply learn so
that's a value which I'm providing here
artifact ID I can make it like a sample
project or something like that I can do
so that will be the artifact uh ID which
is there so version I'm keeping the same
only so and uh yeah so package same here
so I just want to create so I'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that our
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact ID you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the pound.xml
file now this palm.xm file when I open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group ID
you want to follow so this is a group ID
this is the artifact ID so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the J unit dependency is added but if
you want to keep on adding your own
custom dependencies you will be able to
do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular Maven project a
power.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the Target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of Jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the Target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is the way that how we can actually go
for a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo in which we
have find out that how exactly we can go
for a particular project uh preparation
with the help of mvn executable let's
get started with Jenkins Jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for Sun Microsystems
way back in early or mid-2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wider option since it
is released under MIT license and is
almost free to use Jenkins has a vast
developer community that supports it by
writing all kinds of plugins plugins is
the heart and soul of Jenkins because
using plugins one can connect Jenkins to
anything and everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial I will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing Jenkins post which I will go
ahead and install Jenkins on event those
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well so once
I have Jenkins installed and configured
properly I will get into the user
administrative part I create few users
and I will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users I will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and I will
also show you the powerfulness of
Jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule I
will also connect Jenkins with GitHub
GitHub is our source code where source
code repository where I've got some
repositories put up there so using
Jenkins I will connect to GitHub pull up
a repository that is existing on GitHub
onto the Jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from GitHub
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of Jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter Whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
build being good or building propagated
to some environment and all these
scenarios you would need the continuous
integration servers to be sending out
notifications so I will get into a
little bit details of how to configure
Jenkins for sending out emails I will
also get into a scenario where I would
have a web application a maven-based
Java web application which will be
pulled from a GitHub repository and I
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
Tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually I will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the Master Slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a Master Slave
configuration so I will bring up a slave
I will connect the slave with the master
and I'll also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally I will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environment in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what I'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic War file and as long as you
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt
differently on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control C and then bring down this
prompt and your Jenkins server would be
down other older versions of Jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a Java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so Jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your Jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate Jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
the subtle changes in terms of user
Administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
Administration otherwise all the
commands are all the configuration or
the way in which I'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running Jenkins as I
mentioned earlier Jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in Java so all that it needs is Java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the
recommended RAM for running Jenkins and
also like any other open source toolsets
when you install jdk ensure that you set
in the environment variable Java home to
point to the right directory this is
something very specific to jdk but for
any other open source tools that you've
installed there is always a preferred
environment variable that you got to set
in which is specific to that particular
tool that you are going to use this is a
generic thing that is there for you know
for any other open source projects
because the way open source projects
discover themselves is using this
environment variables so as a general
practice or practice always set this
environment variables accordingly so I
already have jdk 1.8 installed on my
system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so
I'm not going into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I've just set in a Java
home variable
if you say this C colon program files
Java jdk 1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
alright one other thing to do is ensure
that in case you want to run Java or
Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java hyphen version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch Jenkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file with a generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
even begin your installation for now I
don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes in to the
Jenkins configuration C colon program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with this I don't want to change
this I would just say go ahead and click
installation
foreign
so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default Jenkins Launches on
the port 8080. so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I will have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it'll crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see there is a whole
lot of plugins which are bare essential
plugin that is required for Jenkins in
order to run properly so Jenkins as a
part of the installation would get all
these plugins and then install it for
you this is a good combination to kind
of begin with and mind you at this
moment Jenkins needs lots of bandwidth
in terms of network so in case your you
know your network is not so good few of
these plugins would kind of fail and
these plugins are all you know all
available on openly or or mirrored sites
and sometimes some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install you'll
get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just ensure that you
know at least most or 1995 of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I get a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you would kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line you are
a little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can you
can kind of visualize it like a thread
that can be run on this particular
instance as a thumb rule if at all
you're on a single core system number of
executors two should be good enough in
case at any point in time if there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually Jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the CPU usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the Jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are with a valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
an example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this a demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install jdk on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git a git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well if you want to do this
any other tool that you're going to
install on your system which is your
continuous integration server you will
have to come in here and configure
something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it will crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
managing games let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
with hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so I will
just say you know first job this is good
for me I just give a name for my job I
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me I don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
it should be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one
two three four five
right come up come up come up all right
so five stars is all that I'm gonna put
in and Jenkins got a little worried and
she's asking me do you really mean every
minute oh yeah I want to do this every
minute let me save this and how do I
check whether it gets triggered every
minute or not I just don't do anything
I'll just wait for a minute and if at
all everything goes well Jenkins would
automatically trigger my second job in a
minute's time from now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific role I can
have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so getting to manage Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for it to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you would need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I've installed
the role based access plugin I would
need to just set it up and check that
you know I would go ahead and create
some roles and ensure that I assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
configure all right let me see where is
this configured configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I have just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer
and I'm adding this role at a global
role level so I would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if we hover over it you would see some
sort of a help on what what are these uh
you know permissions specific to so what
I want is like you know it sounds a
little you know different but I would
want to give very very little
permissions for the developer so from an
Administration perspective I would just
want him to have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
I'll check you know have read-only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user I would
call this user as yeah developer one
sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured out of the
system and developer one is a user that
I have configured so still have not set
any rules for this particular user yet
so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular Global root and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and this permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in let
me quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
right bucket is one of the git servers
has so many plugins that is available
okay so bottom line Jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of Jenkins for you to connect or
for in order to connect Jenkins with any
of the containers or any of the other
tool sets you would need the plugins if
you want to connect or you want to build
a repository which has got Java and
Maven you would need to install Maven
and GDK on your Jenkins instance if at
all you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build build a job on
Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube and
get sonar Cube to run analysis on that
and get back the results in Jenkins all
of these works very well because of the
plugins now with that let me connect our
Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just
at the Java file how do I build my Java
file how do I compile my Java file I
just say Java C and the name of my class
file which is hello.java and how do I
run my Java file I would say Java and
hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says get job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN performs
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I gonna do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay get job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system or
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and it
can you can build a war file and even
deploy it into some other server for now
what we're going to use Maven is just
for building and creating a package out
of this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server and then you
can freely download I'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the Tomcat all right so download Maven
first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this mobile there is
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know I'm having again is
is one open source build tool so you'll
have to set in a few configurations and
set up the path so mvn hyphen iPhone
version if I specify this after setting
my path my one should work and if at all
I Echo M2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my one it is always set here so once
you unzip my one just set this m to home
variable to the directory where you
unzip your my one also just set the path
to this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your Maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system
so I'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this way you download Tomcat server and
I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let Tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port Clash
so what I've done I have configured
Tomcat to use a different port so if I
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloy
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go Tonk itself is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already config
so now the change happens here where
after I get this since I said this is a
simple Maven repository I will have some
Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this Warfare was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I would
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
continue container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right since we're very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I would say this web application War
file that is already built so I would
need to configure this plugin to pull up
this war file and deploy it onto the
Tomcat server for deploying onto the
Tomcat server I will use the credentials
of the user that I've created okay so
let me go to configure this particular
project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my Tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed
okay so let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance
so take the war file that is fine found
in this particular folder and then you
know context path is MN web use the
deployer deployment credentials and get
into this localhost which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this and let me
run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if I
type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date time stamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkinson's test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different iPad that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization where in you're heavily
reliant on the Jenkins server you don't
want your Jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
Distributing the load that is there on
the Jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some of the machines or some other
sleeves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows uh you know Windows based.net
kind of a projects where you would need
a Windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
Linux the next based are systems you
also have a Mac you you support some
sort of an apps or something that is
built on Mac OS you would need to build
you know Mac based system as well so how
are you going to support all these needs
so that's wherein a beautiful concept of
Master Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I'll set up
a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guide so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I make him random I make
him you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or I made a
setting for the master so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so I'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server and Jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to a Jenkins master so I would
say new node I would give a name for my
node I would say windows node because
both of these are windows only so that's
fine I'll just give an identifier saying
that Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86.
C column program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run it from here so this is the
directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guide
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they're allowed to specify this
particular level so imagine this way if
I have a bunch of Windows my system I
name it as Windows star anything that
says from Windows I can give a regular
expression and say that anything that
matches Windows run this particular task
there if I have some MAC machines I name
all these Mac agents as Mac star or
something like that and I can delegate
all tasks you know saying that start
with whatever starts with mac and this
node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web start because we got a
we got to use jnlp protocol okay that
sounds good directory I think nothing
else is required availability yes will
keep this agent yep online as much as
possible that sounds good all right let
me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
not bad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
path there I also want to download this
agent.jar
I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 18. jar I copy this or I cut
this I come back to my folder my Jenkins
node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command prompt right here and then
lost it so I'm saying in the same folder
where there is agent.jar I am going to
launch this a particular agent Java
hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is the
URL of my server in case the server and
client are on different locations or
different IPS you have to specify the IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to Connected very well so let me come
back to my Jenkins instance and see you
know if at all you see earlier this was
not connected Let me refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials of the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of sign it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running on
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down all
right so successfully we've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it will
create a workspace right here all right
so good so let me just come back and let
me kind of put up a new task here I will
say that you know delegate job is good I
say freestyle project I'm going to
create a very
I don't want you to connect a gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
Echo
relegate to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label right
so now I am going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
you know Windows node so this job will
be delegated around there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it ran
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it creates a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary Master job is in SQL
program files under Jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of Master Slave configuration or
distributed built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up the one quick way to
do that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a colon program files
colon Jenkins directory because that's
where our whole Jenkins configuration is
present but we would don't want to do
that let's use some plugins for taking
up a backup so let me go to manage
Jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use so this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens if there
are too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and if the files are being
changed at that moment instead a bit
problematic for Jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically you try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the amount of artifacts possibly
don't want this guy I would just say
save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular
configurations so how do I do that I
just come back to my managing cans
come back to backup manager and I'll say
restore Hudson or Jenkins configuration
today's topic is learn HTML in 10
minutes
first we'll go through a quick
introduction to basic web architecture
to understand how the internet works
then we'll understand what exactly HTML
is
after that we'll have a look at what CSS
then we'll go through JavaScript
and in the end we will create a simple
web page using HTML and CSS to gain a
better understanding of the HTML tags
so without further Ado let's begin
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the IP
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is so your browser starts by
loading the main HTML file and then the
CSS and JavaScript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have the
server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's IP address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an IP address
we put a domain name over that IP
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is HTML HTML is the most
widely used markup language for
developing and structuring web pages on
the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is CSS then now CSS is a
simple design language used for making
web pages look more beautiful and
presentable
it can be attached to any HTML element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is Javascript
now JavaScript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now HTML short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs div
containers tables and more HTML tags are
nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags
so now let's write a simple HTML code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language so for this I am using
the text editor that is Visual Studio
code you can go ahead and download this
text editor from their official website
so here I've created a simple dot HTML
file in my vs code and I've added the
initial HTML files
now let me explain to you uh one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be served to the user is in fact
an HTML document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your HTML page next up you have the HTML
tag that is used to contain all the web
pages HTML code right so it contains an
opening and closing tag with contents in
between them
the HTML tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the Lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the HTML tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
Pages title description additional meta
tags and CSS code so here I've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
HTML
in 10 minutes
[Music]
all right you can also add CSS to the
Head tag by using the style tag and
change the display styles of HTML
elements that are being used the next
section is the body tag now the body tag
contains all the displayable contents of
your web page including headings
paragraphs div containers tables and
more
now the HTML header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first up let's have a look at them I'm
going to create a simple H1 heading tag
and the message I'm displaying is this
is
the first heading
all right
after this I'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so I'm gonna add a P tag and Save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
[Music]
also add line breaks which are helpful
from time to time if you want to provide
a single line break in your content you
can do so by adding the BR tag so here
let me just add one for
better understanding now the HTML div
tag defines a division or a section in
an HTML document that is used as a
container for other HTML elements now
these elements can include content areas
sidebars page bars page headers Footers
Etc
this tag is used to apply styles to HTML
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the HTML image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say IMG
within which I mentioned the source
[Music]
adding the HTML logo so let me just
mention that here
and then I'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file and
when you look at the browser
you can see that the first heading is
displayed then your paragraph tag is
displayed followed by the second heading
and then the image now let me show you
how you can add styles for some of these
headings and paragraph tags so here in
back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
I'm going to change it to Career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so I'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when I look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
HTML tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website welcome to this
crash course video on CSS
this video will help you understand all
the concepts of CSS and provide lots of
Hands-On examples
we'll start with understanding selectors
Box model grid layout flexbox
differences between grid layout and
flexbox and some more basic topics then
building on these Basics will make an
app bar learn how to create animation
and Transitions and finally we'll move
on to CSS Advanced functions so let's
begin
in this video you will learn what are
CSS selectors and what are their
different types so let's start by
discussing the agenda for this tutorial
so in this tutorial we will learn what
are CSS selectors and what are their
different types we will also look at an
example to how to work with CSS
selectors
so
what are CSS selectors
CSS selectives allow you to select and
style HTML elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their ID
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more let's discuss
the most common selectors there are
several different types of CSS selectors
the most common of them are CSS element
selectors CSS ID selector CSS class
selector CSS Universal selector and CSS
group selectors so what is the CSS
element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a CSS selector it means it will
select all the P elements on the page it
will style all the P elements to the
central aligned having blue color
this is a CSS selector
it is set to P this means it will select
all the P elements on the page it will
style all the P elements to be Center
aligned having blue color
let's look at what it looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with the text color
blue
CSS ID selector
the ID selector uses the IDU attribute
of an HTML element to find a specific
element
an ID should be unique within the page
so you should use the ID selector to
find a single unique element to find an
element within a specific ID use a hash
character followed by the ID of the
element
so here we have used the hash paraben so
all the rules will be applied to the
HTML element with ID equal to para1 so
this is an ID selector
it will be applied to all the HTML
element with ID is equal to para1 as you
can see it is applied to the elements
having the ID paragraph and all the
other elements are defaultly styled
CSS class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the HTML class attribute to
select an HTML with a specific class use
a period character followed by the name
of the class so this style will be
applied to all the elements having the
class name class 1. this is a class
selector it is denoted by a period
symbol all the elements having a class
named class 1 will be styled with
centrally aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is tiled and all the
other elements are set to default CSS
Universal selector
the universal selector flips all the
elements on a page the universal
selected is assigned by a star character
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a style sheet as you can see
it is denoted by a star Mark all the
elements inside our web page will be
centrally aligned and the color will be
set to Blue as you can see all the
elements are centrally aligned and the
colors are set to Blue CSS group
selector in stylesheets there are often
elements using the same style to
minimize the code you can group
selectors to group The selectors
separate each selectors with a comma
here we have group selectors for H1 H2
and P
so style is applied to H1 H2 and P
elements only
it is better to group The selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors P H2 and H3
so style will be applied to only element
having P H2 and S3
as you can see so all the elements of
PS2 and S3 are centrally aligned and
colored to Red in this video we will
discuss what is the Box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the Box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
web page is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes CSS Box model
typically describes how this rectangular
boxes are laid out on a web page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different ways but every box
has a Content area and options
surrounding padding model and margin
areas
the following diagram demonstrates how
the content padding model and margin CSS
properties determine how much space and
element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media it is
bounded by the content Edge and its
dimensions are given by the content box
width and height
the Border area is the area between the
Box padding and margin it dimensions are
given by the width and height of the
water
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin the
dimensions of the margin area are the
margin box width and margin box height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the Border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let's jump to an example to
understand the Box model better
so we are on the sublime text later to
get started I have created a box theme
simply run background color pink the
font size 30 pixel and we have set the
border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learned with background going all
the way to the end
I have also removed all the padding and
margin from the page so that the boxes
are pushed just at the corner of the
page as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the Box
if you save the file you can see the Box
increased by 20 pixel from all the sides
paddycasters inside the background of an
element it goes around the content of
the element most of the buttons inside
the CSS be designed using padding so
that the background of the button
becomes wider than the actual text
the next thing you can do is change the
border of the element if you change this
border size to 15 pixel we get a nice
solid background of color green
the Border goes around the padding of
her element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixel
of border around the padding which is
around the content
now we'll see the working of the margin
if you add 30 pixel of margin to an
element you can see the spacing on the
outside of our border
so let's add the 30 pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the Border module is used to space two
elements apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
we'll make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the Border 20 pixels and
make it color red
this is 40 pixels
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
you can see the different styles here in
the computer tab you can see the Box
model
this is a Content area this is the
padding area this is the border and this
is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the border so you can when you click on
this area you can see the margin gets
highlighted
the body area gets highlighted of 20
pixels this is the padding and this is
the content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and width so let's
try adding height and width we'll give
the height 50 pixels and will give the
width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content Area 15 to 50. in this tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout then we will move on to the
features of the grid system and some
basic terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand the grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid is a set of intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout
so CSL grid layout is the most popular
layout system available in CSS
it is a two-dimensional system meaning
it can handle both columns and rows
unlike flexbox which is largely a
one-dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the CSS rules to both the parent element
which became the grid container and the
elements children which become the grid
items
the CSS grid layout excels at dividing a
page into major regions or defining the
relationship in terms of size position
and layer between parts of a control
built HTML Primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows
however many more regular layouts are
either possible or easier with CSS grade
than they were with tables for example a
grid container's child element could
position themselves so they actually
overlap and layer similar to the CSS
position elements
so here the features of the CSS grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes you can create a grid with fixed
track sizes using pixels
for example this sets the grid to the
specified pixel which fits to the layout
you desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new FR unit designed for this purpose
you can place the items into a precise
location using the grid line numbers
names over targeting an area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items not given
an explicit position on the grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout the grid layout
specification is flexible enough to add
additional rows and columns when needed
features such as adding as many columns
that will fit into a container are
included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content more than one item can be placed
into a grade cell or area and they can
partially overlap each other
this layering May then be controlled
with the Z index property
so here the basic terminologies you
should know to work with the grid system
better
the grid line is a dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid they
can either be vertical or horizontal and
decide on either side of rows and
columns
a grid column is a space between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
with a grid template columns property
on the other hand a grilled row is a
space between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template rows property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
CSS grid
and in Grid design a gutter is basically
the width of the space between columns a
guitar margin is a white space formed by
the adjoining inside margins of two
facing pages in a book or space between
columns on a page
so with this let's now move on to the
Hands-On demo and see how the grid
system works in actual world so we are
on the Sublime Text Editor open with a
project with some basic background
Styles and nothing inside the body
you can see this is the basic background
style we have pre-applied just to have a
good look of the Box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it so let's
create a grid and give it a class name
grid container
and inside of it we'll put our different
grid items so we'll just create
different grid items and give them a
class grid item followed by a clock
number they belong to
so that we can easily distinguish
between them
foreign
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so that are
easy for us to visualize we have not
applied any styles to them other than
the visual Styles
so we'll go back to our code
let's go back to the CSS styling sheet
so to create the grid we'll open our
style sheet we need to display grid on
our grid container so we'll select the
grid container and set the display to
grid
if you save now
you will see nothing changes this is
because the gray itself doesn't Define
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same to make the grid look
actually great what you need to do is
Define columns and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column we'll set
the size to 100 pixel line 150 pixel
foreign
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 156 column on
the right and then the grid captures our
next row
but what if you want a box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them here we'll use a fraction
in it so instead of a 150 pixel column
we want one fraction of our size and
instead of 100 pixel we want the two
fractions of our size
so we'll just replace with two fractions
and this with one fraction
now if you save the file and go back to
the page
you will see the items on our left here
in our first column are twice as the
largest item on the second column
and that because of the FR unit we have
defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
the item one is the twice the size of
the item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four Columns of a size
100 pixel wide you can just write repeat
command and inside of it how many times
you want to repeat the size
so we will just delete this
and use repeat
we'll set the number of times we want to
repeat and the size of the
columns
now if you save the file you will see we
have a four Columns of 100 pixel wide
we can do the same things for row just
set the grid template
rows and Define the size you want
foreign
all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid Auto
rows and this will determine the size of
all the rows that is added after the
template rows suppose we want all our
rows to be 100 pixels
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid Auto rows to 100 pixel
um
now you can see all the rows are now 100
pixel tall
let's change our column back to 100
pixel and 150 pixels
so that it will be easier for us further
we just delete this grid Auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row Gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
now you can see the gaps between the
rows and columns
now we want the same value for both The
Columns you can use a grid graph
property and mention the space
we'll just delete this two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid Gap
and set the
size to 20 pixel
now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells so for
horizontal positioning we could use the
justify items and we can set that to
Center
so that centers each atom within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
you can also set it to start
or end
or space around
we will leave this to Center
to vertically position the content we
could use the Align items
the Ally items also accept the same
values
we can set it to Center
we can also set this one to start or end
just we'll keep this to Center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them in a proper manner
you could use a justify content and that
will align the content horizontally
within the container
you can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to Center
to align the content vertically we could
use the Align content and the line
content also accepts the same value we
can set it to Center
or start
if you inspect the elements
you can see they are aligned centrally
between the container we'll just close
this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows you too much in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2D
nature in this video we will learn what
is the flexbox and how it is useful in
designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox
flexbox also called flexible Box model
is basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a CSS for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assign width in terms of percentage
or fixed width and then use the float to
arrange the items on the page
suppose for example you want to arrange
three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from width height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible Box
model is the ability to alter the item
width and height to best fit in the
containers available in the free space
Flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the Box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more effective than small
scale layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
okay so let's jump to some code and
learn how this product properties work
okay so we are in the subline text
editor to get started let's add a div
inside a body here and we'll give a
class of flexbox container since this
will be the container where all our
flexbox item will decide
then inside this container we will add
another div and give it a class flexbox
item and one more class flexbox item one
which will help us to understand which
items we are referring to when we style
our elements individually
foreign
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because I have already
applied some of the styles to these
flexbox items let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the items tiled
just a basic styling so that we get the
Box on our page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item 3. just save the file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
Now to create a flex container
we will add display Flex to our Flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we will just add display Flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are in the
same height and they are all in the same
row you will also notice that if you
shrink our browser the items adjust
themselves accordingly to fit within the
browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the mean axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container let's make it a center
save the file
now you can see the all the elements are
in the center of the page another thing
we can do is if we want our layout to
have a spaces between the elements we
will set the justify content to space
between
you can see all the items are evenly
spaced if you want to lay out your items
on the cross axis we would use the Align
items property the default value for
this is stretch
so if you want to keep the size of our
items we will use the center and then
all our items will be Center vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible with flexbox you can
do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container now
let's just delete everything and we'll
just keep the display flag
now if you want to have a column layout
instead we will use the flex direction
and change it to column select Direction
column now if you refresh the page you
will see all the items are shown up in a
column
now we can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as
opposed to a flexbox container items the
flexbox contains only for laying out and
spacing between your items as well as
the positioning of your item inside the
container the actual flexbox item
properties are used to override those
item Properties or to apply different
sizing to these elements now if we want
our first item that it does not shrink
when you shrink our browser we'll set
the flex shrink to zero to our first
item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to zero
now if you go back to the page
and try to shrink this
you'll see the first item Remains the
Same it does not shrink
now in the same way you can set the
items to grow into position with the web
browser suppose we want our Flex box
item to to grow with the as the page
grow and cover all the empty spaces so
we'll set this Flex grow to 1.
now you will see the all these empty
spaces are taken by the second item
let's say we want a second box to be the
center of the container instead of
stretching to full height we can use the
Align self property and set it to Center
now you'll see that the alliances
property overrides the Align content
property of the container
you can see it is centrally aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the flex
boxes
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the flexbox to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is CSS display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is the display property
the CSS display property controls the
layout of the element on the page
the default value of the display
property is block or inline
let's jump back to our Sublime Text
later to see the various display
Properties by using an example to get
started I have a really simple example
setup as you can see inside my HTML add
the two paragraph tags and I have a
formatting with the background color of
sand color and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drug display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default like how P elements behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the P element is a
display block
so here this looks something like this
what display blocks does is it means
that it is going to take the entire
width given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if we change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is in line the inline display
value turns any element into an inline
element
these elements will appear on the same
line without breaks
now if it says here this will display in
line now all the P tags will behave as
an inline element
now if you go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes a minimum
amount of space possible as you can see
here the cyan color takes a minimum onto
space to fit all the content inside of
this p
so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible
now one of the demanded fear is we
cannot change the height and width of
the inline element
if you change here height
to 200 pixels
and with 200 pixels and Save
just go back and refresh you'll see
nothing happens this is because in the
inline display property you cannot
change the height and width of the
element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value the
inline block value is a hybrid of inline
and block element elements assign
display inline block appears on the same
line with the other inline elements
a characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements are also
like block elements in that you can
change the width and height of the CSS
now if here if you try to change the
height and width
of the element
just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and weight
property works this is one of the major
difference between inline block and the
inline inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
if you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back to
refresh you'll see both the element
disappears
the display name removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page this causes accompanying
elements to behave as if this element
does not exist in this video we'll
discuss everything we need to know about
CSS positioning
by the time this video is over you will
be able to position the elements in CSS
like a pro
so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the SS
question property and its different
types after that we'll jump to practical
example to learn how to work with these
properties
so let's get started
so what is CSS position property
the CSS position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page the top right bottom and the
left CSS position properties are used to
determine the final location of the
element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
web page they are static fixed selective
and absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned you can also use the top
bottom left and right properties to
further Define the element position on a
page so let's discuss each of the
properties individually
CSS static position
this is a by default position for HTML
elements
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page
it is not affected by the top bottom
left and right properties
it is important to note that having a
static equation is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is CSS fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's window and does not move
even when you scroll the window
the next is CSS related position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other CSS properties
we'll discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is CSS absolute position
the attribute position is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is HTML
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties I have the
simple example setup currently we have
three elements with just basic coloring
style
we have not applied any position style
to them
now let's click on this element 2 and
inspect it
just go to the computed
and type here position to see the
position of this element
so you can see the currently the
position is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is the
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static if you go here and change your
position to relative
you can see nothing changes
relative Act is the same as static with
the only difference is that the relative
allows you to change the top left right
and bottom of this element Let Me Show
an example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to a 20 pixel from the left
let's set the top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixel from the top and even overflows
the element below this is because
relative position when applied with the
top right left and bottom actually takes
that element out of the document flow
so let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom
so let's make this position to Absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by just saving
the absolute value completely removes
the element from the document flow this
is useful when you want a particular
element to be a specific position but
you don't want to disturb the other
elements positioning
accelerated positions the element inside
the some parent container that it can
reference now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if you change the here body position
to relative now the this nav bar will
position the element according to this
body so if you go here and refresh this
you can see that this 2 is in its
relation to with this container
and this is the relative is very useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to Absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top this is because
fixed position elements are always fix
based on the entire HTML element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements one unique feature of its
element is they stay in the same place
when you scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element 2 will stay on the same
position
C the two elements is stick to the same
but absolute does not work that way when
you change this here to Absolute
you can see it is not straight at the
top now
this is one major difference between
absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the CSS position super EV in this
video we'll discuss the differences
between both the layouts and we'll
discuss which one you should use
I will also show you both the layout in
a practical example without diving too
deep
so let's first understand the theory
CSS grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas text boxes for one dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating a more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages
whereas the flex items is used to design
the responsive Pages without using too
much of positioning or float in our CSS
code to work with the CSS grid layout
you have to add display grid property to
your element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the display Flex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and the flexbox
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling here on the page we
have a header which is blue in color
this is the sidebar with a red
background this is the main content and
this black color is a footer of the page
here you can see this all these items
are stacked on top of the each other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page this is the main
content of the page this is for the
sidebar and this is for the header area
of the page
for The Styling part we have used some
basic styling just so as to understand
the example better
now we can turn the body into a grid by
setting the display property to the grid
so here under the body we set the
display to grid
just save the file and refresh
you can see nothing changes because by
default the CSS grid starts creating
rows automatically and adds the content
in these rows that's why it didn't
change
we can change it by adding the grid
template column property in our body in
our case we'll need two columns one for
sidebar and other for the main content
let's set the side area to 30 percent
and we'll keep the main area to Auto to
cover the remaining spaces
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are broken into the
skills we created
we'll also Define the rows for our
header and we will use the grid template
rows
we'll set the grid template rows for the
header to 60 pixels
for the sidebar and for the main content
we'll set it to auto
and also for the footer we will keep it
60 pixels
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are adjusted in a
2d manner just as we wanted
this shows the power of the grid and the
flexibility it provides to the developer
however we can see that the items are
not positioned properly in the header
and the footer
this is where the flex block comes into
play as discussed earlier flexbox is
about positioning elements in a
one-dimensional area
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
navigation list class here
and we'll add display as Flex
now if you save the file and reload
you can see these are sitting next to
each other
by default the display sets them into
the rows
now we want the contents to be in the
center of the main axis
so we will use the justify content and
set it to Center
you can see the items are now in the
center of the main axis
to Center them vertically we'll use the
Align items and set it to Center as well
this will position them in the center
across the axis
for this to work we have to specify the
height um so we'll set it to 100 percent
okay
so now you can see the items are aligned
centrally both on the main axis and the
cross axis
let's now add some spacing between these
items
so to give some spacing between we add a
margin to navigation item class
foreign
set the margin to 0 for top and bottom
and 10 pixel to left and right
if we save the file and a refresh you
can see we have the spaces between the
items
in this video you will learn how to set
a background image on a web page you
will also answer the basic properties of
the background that are used to set the
image
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial in this tutorial we'll
discuss what is CSS background image
after that we'll discuss some of the
basic properties of the background image
in the end We'll add a background image
to our web page by adding the code to
our text editor
so let's begin by discussing about the
background property of the CSS
the background image property specifies
an image to use as a background of an
element
the background is defined in the body
element of the HTML code
to add a background image on an HTML
element use the HTML style attribute and
the CSS background image property and
mention the path of the image inside the
URL attribute
there are several properties of the
background that are used to define the
image on a page some of the common ones
are background image background repeat
and background position
by default the image is repeated so it
covers the entire element
let's switch to the text editor and see
how we can add the background image to
our page so we are on the Sublime Text
Editor let's start by opening a style
tag
the background image is always set on
the body tag so type body and open the
curly braces
the background image is always set on
the body tag so open a body type with
curly braces and start typing background
image
use the URL value of the background
image to set the path of the image
make sure the image is in the same
folder as of the HTML file here we have
our file nature3.jpj
so mention the path inside the double
quotes
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a web page
as you can see we have the image on the
web page let's format this image a
little bit we'll start by setting the
background size so type background size
and there are three values to the
background size first one is Auto
it will set the image as it is
save the file and let's see how it looks
on the page
as you can see the size of the image is
as same of the original size
the color value will set the image size
that will be fit to the web page
as you can see the image is set to the
whole web page
you can also set the image size to
manual let's say you want the image size
of bit 500 pixels so
now as you can see the width of the
image is 500 pixels next we will set the
background repeat property there are
three values to background repeat first
is no repeat with no repeat value the
images will not be repeated on a page
now as you can see the images are not
repeated
second is repeat X it will set the
images to be repeated on the x-axis
as you can see the images are not
repeated on the x-axis
similarly repeat the images on the
y-axis
as you can see the images are not
repeated to the y-axis and there is a
default value repeat which will repeat
the images on the web page
so let's keep it to cover
so let's keep the background size to
cover and set the background repeat to
no repeat
let's save the file and look it on our
web page
now as you can see the image is fully
fit to the web page
let's add a text above our image to see
how it looks like so I'll add a
paragraph tag
and type some random text here
let's set the text color to red and
align it to Center
I'll type P and open the curly braces
I'll set the color to red
foreign
to Center
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
as you can see we have a text above our
image which is centrally aligned and the
text color is red in this tutorial we
will learn how we can add colors to our
page using different methods we will
start with discussing colors and then
see the hex value and RGB format of the
colors in the end we will do an example
to understand how we can add colors to
our page
CSS uses the color values to specify the
colors on a page they can be specified
using predefined color names hex or RGB
format there are nearly 140 standard
color names hexadecimal is a six degree
representation of a color the first two
digits RR represents the red value the
next two are green value and the last is
the blue value
all the other colors can be created
using the combination of these three
colors there are several websites
available where you can know the hex
value of the different shades of color
as you can see the black color is
signified by hashtag and the six zeros
the red is hashtag FF and the four zeros
followed by it the RGB color value is
specified using the RGB property this
property takes three values one for red
green and blue the value can be the
integer between 0 to 225 or a percentage
as you can see the black color is
signified by zero zero zero the red by
25500 the Blue by 0 0 255 and the green
by zero two fifty five zero now let's
move to an example to understand how we
can add the colors to our page
in this example we will see how we can
add colors in different ways to our HTML
so we are on the Sublime Text Editor as
you can see we have the standard boiler
bit ready with an H2 and a paragraph on
our page open the style tag and make the
font size of the paragraph to 25 pixels
so it is clearly visible
let's start by adding colors to our text
just by color names HTML supports nearly
140 standard color names
we'll make the color of the paragraph
green for that just type color and set
the color to Green
as you can see our paragraph is changed
to Green
let's try one more
this time we will add the color red
just refresh
as you can see the color is not changed
to red
there are nearly 140 HTML standard
colors that is supported by the web
browser
you can also add colors using the RGB
format there are many websites available
to know the RGB or hex value of the
desired color once such is HTML
codes.com
as you can see in the HTML course.com we
have the hex value and the RGB value of
the desired color
let's try one
we'll add this color with the RGB value
171 229 and 27 to our paragraph So for
that just type RGB and the color code
you want
as you can see the color is not changed
to our RGB value let's try one more
this time we'll use this RGB value to
our text
you can see the colors changed to a
desired value
in this way you can use the RGB format
to change the colors
the next way is using the hex values
hexadecim is the six representation of a
color the first two digits are red next
one two are green and a last are the
blue value let's see how you can use the
hex values
as you can see the hex value for this
color is hash 31787f
we'll use this value to our text
to add the hex value you have to use the
hashtag followed by the color code
you can see that color is changed to a
hex value let's try one more
you can see the hex value for this color
in hash f14a07
just copy the desired value to your file
thank you
can see the color changes
you can also add color borders to our
heading do that just mention the Border
style along with the color code
we'll add the Border color red to our H2
now you can see we have the border
around our S2
I hope you have understand how to use
the color values to a web page there are
mainly three ways by which you can add
the colors to your web page they are
hacks RGB values and the color names in
this video we will discuss what are
keyframes and how you can use them to
add animations to your page
we are going to discuss what are
keyframes and will try to understand the
syntax of the keyframes so let's get
started
the keyframes are used to specify the
animation code in the page they are used
to change the animation from one pattern
to another
keep in mind that the keyframes do not
have any selectors on them
they are not tested inside anything they
are on the root of the CSS page you
write at the rate keyframes and the name
you can name it anything you want we are
going to use that name later on to call
the selector in this case we are looking
at from and 2 from implies the initial
State and to the ending State here in
this example the element will start from
0 pixel and will go all the way to 100
pixel so what we are going to do right
now is we are going to jump to the
keyframes and work out some examples to
understand the working of the keyframes
better so we are on the sublime text
seter and this is a simple setup we have
created one HTML element name box and we
have a CSS body of padding 50 pixel and
the Box element is an inline block
background red with heightened with 200
pixel
and also I have an animation stat
declared on the box
currently it's doing nothing because it
is calling keyframes called my frames
but we have not yet created any keyframe
we will discuss what this animation line
means at later stage but right now I
need those lines to be able to explain
you to the functioning of the keyframes
you can see we have a box on our page
with the color red and padding 50 pixels
around it we are going to write add the
keyframes and I am going to use the name
my frames then we'll write prompt
condition to have the starting State and
let's just keep the height 200 pixel and
then we want it to grow and we will set
it to increase till 500 pixels so let's
just create our keyframes
okay
this is a form condition
we'll set it to 200 pixels
and we want it to grow till 500 pixels
just save the file
now as you can see our box is going all
the way to 500 pixel and when the
animation is done it resets back to 200
pixel and starts again because the
animation is looping you can also put
multiple style declaration for example I
am going to write background pink in the
two condition
just save the file
you can see that the animation is
starting at red and ending at pink now
instead of saying from N2 we can also
say from zero percent to hundred percent
this is as same as doing from N2 but
what it enables you to do is you can add
something in the middle of here say 30
and we will make the color any different
so in the place of prompt we'll write
zero percent
and will replace two with hundred
percent
let's just add one more condition in
between say 40 percent
so at forty percent we want the color to
change to say something uh
greed
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so as you can see it starts with red it
turns to Green in the middle and then
all the way converts to Pink as you can
see there are lots of interesting things
you can do with the keyframes all of the
things that I am showing you today are
just like how this works to really get a
great understanding of how it works you
just have to open an editor and start
experimenting on it
okay so now let's go back to our code
and learn about animation property
so here we have the animation name my
frames
the animation name should be as same as
keyframe's name to work it properly
the animation duration specifies for how
long we want our animation to last in
this case 2 seconds
let's just change this to say
10 seconds
just save the file
now as you can see the animation is
going at a slower speed just to cover
the 10 seconds update
let's just reset it to two seconds
the timing function is used to mention
the transition there are some keywords
such as easy and linear easy node and
some more the animation delay is
interesting to understand it means how
long we are going to wait once the
animation is triggered before the visual
starts happening
let's change it to 3 seconds
as you can see the animation starts
after the three seconds
iteration count specifies how many times
the animation should happen here we are
set it to infinite
which means animation will keep on going
let's change it to something say 5.
as you can see after the count of five
the animation stops
we will set it back to infinite
animation running State can be paused or
the running state in this video we are
going to break down everything there is
to know about the CSS animation
CSS animations make it possible to
animate transitions from one CSS style
configuration to another
animation consist of two components a
style describing the CSS animation and a
set of keyframes that indicates the
start and end states of the animation
style as well as possible intermediate
now to understand this better I have an
example so let's get started now
so we are on a Sublime Text Editor now
to get started I have a very basic
example with HTML and CSS
I have a parent element here
and inside this parent element I have a
div class child
so when you go back to the page it will
look something like this this pink color
is the parent element and the small box
with the red color is a child element
whenever you hover over the element the
child elements move from left side to
the right side of the parent
we want to talk about animation
in case there are two different ways to
animate one is the CSS transaction
property which works well with only
simple animation
if you want to learn about CSS
transition property you can refer to the
last video on CSS transition
there is a full-fledged animation
property which is used for more complex
animation
I am going to show you how you can make
this simple transition into animation
for this example we'll make this child
element move all around the Box using
animation
so let's go back to our code
so just like the transaction property we
have the several properties in the CSS
animation as well this consists of like
timing function fill in mode and several
other functions in the CSS animation
so to convert the transition into
animation all we need to do is write the
word animation and you write the
animation where you want it to happen in
our case here is our hover so we write
the animation here and as you write you
will notice that you have more
properties in animation than transition
in general you write everything in this
animation keyword because it is easier
we can write it separately as well like
animation delay duration animation name
but
we will use the shorthand property of
the animation
so we'll select the animation and the
first thing that the animation leaves is
the animation name
so we will give some name to this
animation
say
example
this is just like transition we can
specify our duration
in our case we will use one second
so we have given the name of the
animation
will give the duration we can define a
timing function which will be ease out
this is all the code we need for our
animation
this line is same as writing this
individually like animation name
[Music]
animation duration one second
and animation timing function
which will be ease out
so let's say is in
so for the better understanding let's
just remove the shorthand property and
use it individual properties
now just save the file
let's understand briefly what each of
these properties blue the animation
duration property defines how long time
an animation should take to complete if
the animation duration property is not
specified no animation will occur
because the default value is 0 second
the animation timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
animation
now comes the keyframes keyframes are
used to define the animation name we
come down here and write at the rate
keyframes
followed by the name of the animation
the keyframes has to be put outside any
selector
keyframes essentially determine what a
animation looks like between the value 0
and 100 percent
so at our animation we want to have this
Translate
so we'll write 100 percent
and we'll write
transform
translate X
100 and save the file
now when you save and go back to the
page
you will notice a smooth transition of
the animation
when you hover over
one thing you will notice that as soon
as the animation is over the Box goes
back to the original place
the reason for this is all the process
happens inside this keyframe
this one
as soon as the animation is done the
default set kicks in
if you want this to stop in the
transform State like box should be here
is on the right side
we have to specify it in the animation
property we'll set the animation fill
mode to forwards so here
we'll set the animation fill mode to
forwards
just save and then when you go back to
the
page and refresh
you'll see the Box stops on the right
side and doesn't go back to the original
state
now that you have a basic understanding
of the animation and its different
properties let's work around our main
aim to move this child element all over
the parent element from this to this
side to this side to the side so here at
the keyframes we'll just delete this and
we'll start with zero percent
so here at the zero percent
will set the transform and translate X
to 0.
after that add a 33 percent
we want
this box to move down so we'll work on
Translate Y
so
we'll translate the Y to hundred percent
at 66 percent
we want both the x axis and y axis too
to move from here to this side
so we'll set
translate x 200 percent
and Translate
why 200 percent
and finally at hundred percent
you want to translate X
back to 100 percent
on the upward side so when you save and
refresh
you'll see we have achieved our Target
the child elements move all over inside
the parent element
to watch it little bit more slowly let's
change the time here to three seconds
when you go back and refresh
you can see the Box move little bit
slower
so
with the animation property we can go a
step further we can tell our animation
how many times to repeat the order of
the animation
among other things
so the animation iteration count
property specifies the number of times
an animation should be played let's set
it to 3.
so here
you set the animation iteration ground
to 3.
the animation Direction property is
defined whether animation should be
played forwards backwards or in
alternate Cycles
so for the animation Direction we'll set
it to alternate
now if you save and go back
that's one
two
and three after the three count the
animation will stop and you must have
noticed that the Box were moving on the
alternate rounds
let's go back to see it again
this is the first cycle now it moves alt
on the other direction and now on the
other direction
so this is for animation you can see
animation property is as same as a
transition property with some more
functions answer properties you can add
more complex animations to the page with
the help of this animation property the
CSS transition property is the simplest
way to add the animation to our website
and in this video we are going to see
how to use it
so animation is a good way to catch
attention on the page and if done
properly it increases the user
experience
the most basic way to animate something
is by transition
according to the mdn definition
transaction enables you to define the
transition between two states of an
element basically when the state of an
element changes such as hover Focus or
anything else you can change the CSS
property through a transition there are
handful of transition property let's
discuss what they are and how they work
so we are in our Port pen I have a box
that changes the color on the hover
the first topic that we are going to
start is with the transition duration
property
the transition division property
specifies how many seconds or
milliseconds a transaction FX takes to
complete
so here I can write transition duration
and I can write here a number take note
that here we can enter time in
milliseconds or seconds I will suggest
you to use the millisecond since
JavaScript does not accept time in
second
so I will enter here 500 milliseconds
now
when you go here and hover over this box
you see the color changes from pink to
Green in about 500 milliseconds
let's change this to say two seconds
and see the difference
now if you hover over this box
you see it takes two seconds to change
the color from pink to Green
[Music]
the next one we are going to look is a
transition property the transition
property sets the CSS properties to
which the transition effect should be
applied
suppose we want to rotate this box when
hovered over
so first we specify the transform
property here and we'll set it to rotate
45 degrees
now here we'll specify the transition
property and set it to transform
now if you hover over this box you see
it takes about 500 milliseconds for the
box to rotate to 45 degrees while the
color changes instantly
suppose we set it here to 2 seconds
and Save
now you'll notice the Box will take to
about 2 seconds to rotate to 45 degrees
while the color will change instantly
you can see the difference here
now the next property is transition
timing function
the transition timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
transition effect
the default value is ease ease means it
specifies a transition effect with a
slow start and then fast and then end
slowly
suppose here
will set the transition
timing function
to ease
there are four major values for this
timing function they are is linear ease
in and ease out
let's see one by one in detail
so the linear function specify the
transition effect with the same speed
from start to end
so if we change here to linear
you see it rotates with the same speed
from start to end
now if we change this to ease in
the easy specify the transition effect
with a slow start so now if you hover
over this
you see the Box rotate in the slow start
and then increases the speed at the end
the ease out specifies a transition
effect with a slow end
so if you set it to ease out
you will see at the end the speed
decreases
the last property we are going to
discuss is a transition delay the
transition delay property specifies when
the transition effect will start
the transition delay value is defined in
milliseconds or in seconds
let's set the transition
delay to two seconds
and just remove this
now if you hover over this box you see
it will take two seconds to rotate the
box to 45 degrees
so you can see after the two seconds the
transition property takes place
now if we change here
to background
you see the Box will rotate instantly
while the color will changes from pink
to green after two seconds
so this is a transition property is it
as simple as it can be in this video you
will learn how to add interactive horror
effects to your element
we'll do an example where we'll create
horror effects to our buttons so in this
tutorial we will discuss what is a CSS
over effect and then we'll do an example
to understand it better
so what is the CSS over effect
a CSS hover effect is a style technique
where the user interacts with an element
with a pointing device but it is not
necessarily activates it
it is triggered when the user hovers
over an element with a pointing device
now let's jump to an example
in this example we will create the hover
effects which will look something like
this we have different hover effects for
all the buttons
so let's get started and see how you can
make this all by yourself
so we are on the Sublime Text writer
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will write our HTML
and CSS code respectively
start by linking the CSS file with the
HTML file
now we will add four anchor tags we will
specify the class name for each of them
so that we can style them separately
later
put all the anchor tag inside the div
tag and name the class
middle
we'll name the class BTN btn1 BTN btn2
BTN btnc and BTN btn4
foreign
times
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page right now as you can see we
have the port text on our page
with this we are done with our HTML path
now let's shift to CSS and design the
text and add the hover effects so in CSS
you will start by setting the margin and
padding to zero we will also add the
background body color
as you can see the margin and padding is
now zero and we have a good background
color
now we will Design the buttons and give
them proper formatting we'll start with
the class middle
set the position to Absolute
the top property affects the vertical
position of a position element the left
property affects the horizontal position
of equation element the transform
property applies a 2d or 3D
transformation to an element this
property allows you to rotate scale and
move the elements
as you can see the elements are now in
place
now let's format the buttons
set the position to relative
display block
will keep the color as white
font size 25 pixels
we will use the font family as Montes
red
keep the text decoration to none
we will set the border to two pixel and
solid
we keep the text from permission repeat
we'll keep the text transformation as
uppercase
foreign
allows you to change the property values
smoothly over a given duration
the before selector is used to insert
something before the content of each
selected elements
keep the position to Absolute
foreign
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
now as you can see all the elements are
in place with proper background and text
we have the padding and Border properly
formatted and now we can add the hover
effect to this button
now we'll add the hover effects to the
first button
as you can see we have the hover effect
on our first button ready
in a similar manner we can add the
effects to the second and third Button
as well
we'll just copy and paste this above
code below and make changes to this code
we'll set the width to 100 here
and hike to zero
we'll change it to height hundred
percent
just save the file and refresh the page
as you can see both the buttons have the
horror effects now
it's time to add the hover effect to our
third button
now we'll add the hover effect to the
button third
just save the file and go to the page
as you can see all the three buttons are
ready
now it's time to add the hover effect to
the post button
we'll set the color to Hash FFF
foreign
this will change the text color to red
when we hover over the fourth button
set the position to Absolute
keep the width as 200 percent
we'll set the background to hash dcd159
foreign
keep the transition to 0.8 seconds
set the height to 180 percent of the
page
now to add the hover effect
write the following code
just save the file
refresh
now you can see we have all the hover
effects on our Pro button
as you know the asset animations is a
powerful concept that is used to make
your web page engaging and attracting
visuals to your website
they make the user experience smooth and
entertaining
so in this video we are going to learn
how to create some cool CSS effects
using just HTML and CSS so without
further wasting any time let's jump to
our Sublime Text Editor so we are on our
Sublime Text data for our example
purpose I have used one image from an
unsplash.com and we have created a
simple class div clock container for it
now let's go and style these images to
get a 3d effect so first let's design
the body part
we'll set the margin and padding to zero
itself
we set the width to 100 percent
and will set the height to 100 vertical
Heights
we'll keep the display as Flex
and will align the items in the center
and will justify the content in the
center as well
now we'll design our container class
so for the container class we'll set the
position to relative
we'll set the width to 360 pixels
and we'll keep the height to 640 pixels
we'll set the margin top to 150 pixels
and will keep the background to White
we'll use the rgba format
we'll use the transform property to
apply a 2d or 3D transformation to an
element
so we'll use the transform and we'll use
its properties we'll keep this two
30 degrees
we'll set this Q to
say 25 degrees
and we'll scale it to 0.8
let's discuss more about these
properties
so
the translate profit defines a 2d or 3D
translation the scale defines a 2d or 3D
scale transformation
and this Q property is used to give
transformation along the x or y axis
now let's design the images
we'll keep the position to Absolute
we'll set the width to 100 percent
and will keep the transition time
to 0.5 seconds
let's go back to our page and see how it
looks up to this point
so as you can see we have the images
aligned as we want
on a flat side
milk we will create the 3D
transformation when we hover over it
so let's go back to our CSS file
so for the 3D effect we are going to use
the edge child property the end style
selector allows you to take a single
argument that describes a pattern for
the matching element indices in a list
of siblings
foreign
image separately so for the fourth image
we'll use the transform property and
we'll translate it to 160 pixels and
minus 160 pixels
foreign
let's copy this code
four times
okay we have to set the opacity as well
so we'll set the opacity here
to one
the opacity property says the
transparency of the element
just change that number of the nth child
elements so here we'll keep it to 120
pixels
minus 120 pixel we'll set the opacity
to 0.8
for the second element let's keep the
translate to 80 pixels
minus 80 pixels and we'll set the
opacity
to say 0.6
and for the last image
will translate it to 40 pixels
and minus 40 pixels and we'll keep the
opacity to say 0.4
so now when you save the file and you
will go back to the page
let's see how it looks
so if you refresh and hover over it now
you can see the image has a 3D over
effect over it there are four layers to
the image and we have
design the opacity according to the
image layer
so this is a 3D image hover
the next property we are going to
discuss is a 3D perspective image
so for this let's use a new set of
images
so we'll go back to the unsplash.com
again
and let's select one image
this one looks beautiful
so let's copy the image address
and mention it under the image tag
just save
[Music]
now when you go back to the page
you'll see you have your image here
now let's add the 3D perspective Image
Design over it so under our CSS file
let's first design all the elements
let's keep the margin and padding to
zero
let's keep the width of the container
elements 200 pixels
or say hundred percent
let's keep the minimum height to save
100 vertical Heights
and we'll use a background color of hash
let's design the image as well before
going back to the page
so we'll set the perspective to save
4000 pixels
the perspective property is used to
determine the distance between a z plane
and the user in order to give a 3D
positioned element some perspective
let's keep the width of the image 20
percent
will keep the position to Absolute
keep the left margin to 50 percent
and drop to 50 as well
we'll use a transform property
and use the translate value of it to
minus 50 percent 10 plus 50 percent
we'll use the transform style property
and set the value to preserve 3D
the present CD indicates that the
children of the element should be
positioned in the 3D space
so just save the file and let's go back
to the page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see we have the required
background image and we have the image
over
in a required position
now it's time to style our image
so we'll use the transform property
and we'll rotate
we'll use the rotate X property of it
20 degrees
foreign
States
it results in the transform function
data type
the transformation is taxed as the three
dimensional Vector it coordinates how
much the element moves in each Direction
let's set the Box shadow
to minus 80 pixels
60 pixels
15 pixels
has an rgba value to
0 comma 0 comma 0
.4 let's say
let's set the transition to all 0.4
seconds
and we'll set the transform style to
Fraser 3D
so just save the file and let's go back
to our page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see the image is flat for
and ready for 3d effect
now let's Design This 3D horror effect
on it
so for the 3D over effect
we'll use the cover property image
colon Google
or the image
will set the transform
rotate x 0 degrees
rotate red to zero degrees
and translate 0 to
0 pixels comma
zero pixel comma 0 pixels let's check
this one again
this is right
now we'll set the Box Shadow to
0 pixels 0 pixels zero pixels
0 pixels and rgba
0 comma zero comma zero comma zero
just save the file
and refresh
now when you hover over it you will see
that the perspective of the image
changes
so this is a 3D perspective image
now there are many CSS effects that you
can design using these properties
in this video you will learn what is
navigation bar and its importance on a
web page
you will also learn how to create a
basic navbar using HTML and CSS
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
we will start with what is navigation
bar and why navigation bar is required
in a web page
you will look at some of the
well-designed navigation bars on
websites after that you will work on the
code to create the basic navigation bar
using HTML and CSS
so let us Begin by discussing what is
navigation bar
a navigation bar is a graphical user
interface intended to Aid the user in
accessing the information it is usually
placed at the top of the page a
navigation bar needs standard HTML as
the base navigation bars can be created
either vertically or horizontally
so what makes a navigation bar so
important
an aggregation bar is an important
element of website design since it
allows user to quickly visit any
sections within the website if we have
ever visited a website without a
navigation bar you may have found it
difficult to locate the page you need
you may have also had to click back
several times in order to find a link to
the next section you wanted to visit
thankfully web design has become more
standardized in the recent years and
nearly every websites now include a
navigation bar keep in mind that you
want to keep people on a site to explore
further a well-designed navigation bar
is an important part of the user
experience now let us look at an example
of a navigation bar on a website we are
on the home page of Amazon website as
you can see this is the navigation bar
that has several elements on it as the
user clicks on these elements they will
be directed to the different sections of
the website the navigation bar allows
the user to easily boot through any
section of the website
by clicking on the best service button
you will be redirected to the best
sellers page on the Amazon
now we are going to create a navigation
bar with HTML and CSS that's going to
look like this
we'll have the following sections with
sub menus and some of them
make sure you have a text editor to
write the code I'll be using a Sublime
Text letter for this purpose we will
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will be writing on
HTML and CSS code respectively
let's start by adding the standard
boilerplate
keep the title as CSS navbar
link your CSS file with the HTML file by
using the link tag and hdf attribute
this navigation bar is going to consist
of a bunch of your tags which means an
another list and list items
let's create our first another list and
this will be our main menu of the
navigation bar
I have options such as home about
contact services and news so this is
going to be our main menu
um
save the file let's see what it looks
like right now by opening it inside our
browser
you can see it is just an unordered list
with no menu at this point let's go
ahead and add our sub menus home will
not have any sub menus but the about
list item is going to have a sub menu
add another UI tag inside the Ally tag
this will create a sub menu inside the
about item save the file
just copy paste it and paste it inside
the UI tag
name them as team
clients
careers and Legacy
just make the indentation properly
if you see this is a browser you'll see
that we'll have the sub menus inside the
about let's do the same thing for
contacts just copy paste this whole
section and place them inside the
contacts list rename them according to
your wish and save the file
if you go back to the browser
you will see that we'll have the sub
menus inside the contact as well
as you can see this is our complete sub
menus without the styling all the HTML
content is ready now we are going to
write the CSS for it in the CSS file
let's apply the background image first
because it will make the page look a
little bit nicer
I have my file on my computer make sure
the image file is in the same folder as
your HTML and CSS file I am using a
tech.jpg
and for the background size I will set
it to the cover which is going to adjust
it to the image screen and it's going to
cover the whole background of our web
browser
keep the font family as aerial
let's see what it looks like at this
stage you can see we have a background
image and the font is changed to Ariel
foreign
list does not have any margins or
padding by setting it to zero
also put the list style to run because
we don't want to have any kind of bullet
under our listing
now another list list items they are the
main items that are going to apply the
style to the list items of the main URL
tag
float that all the text to the left
and set the given formatting
we will set the background color with
the hash value
003542 you can choose your own value
from our website known as color
picker.com
we will fix the line height to 40 pixels
this will Center the text vertically
text align to Center
this will align the text horizontally
and font size to 20 pixel
font size 20 pixels
let's see what it looks like now you can
see the text is floated to the left
now let's tell the actual menu link so
the menu link will be ulia
UL Li a
keep the text decoration
to none and color white
keep the display as block
now it's time to set the hover effect of
our array the URL hover will set the
formatting when the user hovers over the
menu
foreign
color of the hash value D E1 FCB
save the file and let's see what our
page looks like up to this point
you can see we have the hover effect
over our menus and we have the sub menus
under the main menu we want our set menu
should be visible only when we hover our
menus so we will set the UL Li to
display none and we will set the hover
effect to the block
okay
let's save the file and see what our
page looks like up to this point
now you can see our navigation bar is
ready
with all the sub menus and menus at
proper places we have this nice hover
effect over the menus
in this video we will discuss some cool
tricks that every web developer should
be familiar with and which will help you
during the time of your designing of
your web page so let's jump onto the
Sublime Text Editor and see these tricks
so the first trick is called the CSS
blend mode the CSS background blend
property sets the blend mode for each
background layer and you can blend it
with image or with different colors with
the help of this property we can blend
background image or blend them with
colors
so here's an example of the CSS blend
mode here you can see the images are
blended with different colors
so let's see how we can achieve this
so for our example purpose I am going to
use this image
to our page
so in the body tag add the image URL and
the location of a file
keep the margin left and margin right to
auto
now let's add some style to a body tag
in the blend mode there are several
modes such as normal multiply darker and
lighter or screen
let's blend that image with one color so
you can select the color from this HTML
color codes I'll use this color for my
purpose so just copy paste here
and in the background blend mode let's
keep it to lightened
now if you save
and then refresh here
you can see we have Blended our image
with color
let's go back and change here something
different
let's keep it to darken
let's try something friend let's keep it
to screen
so as you can see there are several
properties for this blend mode and you
can use according to your needs the next
trick is called clipping the CSS clip
Pass Property creates a clipping region
that specifies the region that should be
shown on the page
so let's understand this with the help
of an example here we'll create a div
and give this class any class say TR
the easiest way to generate the clip
value is to use a generator
there are several websites that give the
value of the clip
so we'll use this
website to generate our clip value
suppose we want a hexagon shaped image
on our page
so here you can adjust it according to
your needs
the any shape that you want
here you can see the clip value just
copy paste it from here
now here we'll use that class that we
are specified
we'll just copy paste the clip value
here
will keep the height to say
50 percent or less than 60 percent
set the width to 60 as well
select the color you want to give to a
clip image
I'll use the same color from the
previous example
so just copy paste this color code
keep the position to Absolute and the Z
index to minus 1.
just save and go back to the page and
refresh
now you can see we have the clipped
image on our page let's try something
different
um let's say I want
a left Arrow
so just copy paste this
clip
value clip path value
[Music]
just save the file
and you can see we have the arrow on our
page another must-have for web
developers is animations
CSS allows us to animate almost every
property that we use in the CSS
let's look at one example so here an
HTML file we'll just add one div tag
first
and to start with animation we'll have
to mention a keyframe the keyframes
allows us to create different steps for
our animations
we'll keep the keyframes name to Blink
so here in this example we'll create a
box and we'll add different colors at
different points of animations right so
we write zero percent and we'll set the
background
to Indigo
which change the colors five times so
just copy paste this code five times
we want next change at 30 so we'll set
the background here
suppose say red
foreign
we wanted yellow
at 70 we wanted green
and finally we'll change it to say blue
so inside the div tag we'll mention the
height and width of the Box first let's
say 400 pixels and width also 400 pixels
now I'll mention the border of the box
so just set it to say 1 pixel
solid black
now for the animations part
will set the animation for 10 seconds
and for infrared number of times
write this webkit so as to support in a
Google Chrome
okay
now just save the file and go back to
our page
and here you can see we have the
animation on our box
you can style each and every element in
HTML using animations
another thing you can do is add PSS
gradient the CSS gradient property
allows you to add smooth transitions
between two or more colors
for this purpose you can get the
gradient value from a website called CSS
gradient.io
here in this website you can get the mix
and match of the different colors you
want to use let's look at an example to
understand better
so here in this HTML file first let's
set the height
so we'll set the height to 100 percent
now inside the body tag
will keep the height as 100 percent
will mention one background color
let's select different color this time
so we will use save this color
this time
just copy paste the value here
now for the gradient value just go back
here in this website and you can select
the color you want
let's say I want a mix of this color
and
you can change the shades from here
now when you're done with the colors
just go back below and copy this
code here
to your page
now when you go back to the page you
will have a beautiful gradient here
let's try one more
this Tamil linear gradient
just copy this value to your code
just save the file and go back to the
page
and you will have a linear gradient here
in this video we are going to learn some
of the more advanced features that can
be used to optimize your web page and
add some extra features to it
so let's get started so the first
function we are going to discuss is CSS
sudo class
a CSS sudo class is a keyword added to
the selector let's specify the special
state of the selected elements
so low class lets you apply a style to
an element not only in relation to the
content of the documentary but also in
relation to external factors like
history of the Navigator the status of
it content or the position of the mouse
like hover which lets you know if the
mouse is over an element or not
so the first sudo class we are going to
discuss is CSS hover
this pseudo class is used to add a
special effect to an element when our
Mouse pointer is over it
let's work an example to understand how
this works
so we are on a Sublime Text Editor and
we have added a standard wall update to
it
so first I'll create a box element
okay
we get the div class box
let's save this and see right now what's
the status of our page
so as you can see we have this simple
learn tag and the heading that we have
given and the color changes when you go
over me now add a style tag to define
the
styling of the box
so
we'll keep the background color of the
box as
printing
we'll keep the width to 300 pixels and
height
to 200 pixels
we'll set the margin to auto
keep the font size to 40 pixels so that
we can see the text clearly
and will align the text to the center
just save and go back to the page
now you can see
we have this box with the tag the color
changes when you hover over me
now to add the hover effect you just
have to mention the class with semicolon
and hover so we'll mention the class box
it's a semicolon and Hoover
he'll mention the background color to
which the Box will change any over Mouse
so we'll keep the background color to
say a CN color
just save and go back to the page
so if you refresh and when you hover
over it you can see the color changes
so this is how the pseudo over class
works
the next photo class we are going to
discuss is an active pseudo class the
active solo class represents an element
that has been activated by the user
either by pointing a device or by a
touchscreen device
let's work on an example to understand
how to use the active class to change
the color of active elements the
possible values could be any color name
in any valid format so we'll use the
same example with some minor changes
first
let's change this text here
we keep it to click here to see the
effect
we keep this part as same and instead of
over here we will use the active pseudo
class so we'll type active and we'll
keep the background clear to sand
foreign
to the center
when you refresh and go back
so
you see here it is click here to see the
effects now
to see the difference now you can see
when we are hovering over it the color
does not change it instead of it when we
click on it the color changes
so this is how the active over class
works the next Advanced Property we are
going to discuss is a CSS pseudo
elements
a CSS pseudo element is a keyword added
to a selector that lets you style a
specific part of the selected element
you can use one pseudo class element in
a selector
it must appear after the simple
selectors in the statement
as a rule double colon should be used
instead of a single column this
distinguishes the similar classes from
the pseudo element so the first two-do
element we are going to discuss is the
first letter Studio element this pseudo
element applies tied to the first letter
of the first line of the Block Level
element
let's work out an example to understand
this better
so let's add some content to the body
and we'll add an H1
which says welcome
and we'll add an H2
which says
this is an example
of first letter
to development
tile tag
text in the body to the center so we'll
use text align
just give proper spacing here
now to this H1 tag we'll add the first
letter sudo so to add the first letter
pseudo element let's use the double
colon and type first
letter
we'll keep the font family of the first
letter as say lucida
calligraphy
there's a spelling mistake
we keep the font size to 370 meters
we keep the color to red
and just add a text shadow
for better animation
so we'll keep the text Shadow to Pi
pixels
and pixels and color cyan
now when you save and go back
just refresh so this WC is a first
letter sudo element
as you can see we have changed this
first letter with a proper shadowing of
a c and color and a different font size
so this is how the first let us
pseudo element works
the next one we are going to discuss is
the before pseudo element
the before pseudo element can be used to
insert some content before the content
of an element
let's work out an example
so just add the standard boilerplate
inside the body let's add
welcome to Simply learn
we'll add the text inside the queue tag
the qtag defines a short quotation so
inside the queue tag
we'll add welcome
to get closed
to
and away
and again Q tag
in pre-learn
now that we have the text inside the
body let's add the styling
so we'll keep the font size to of all
the
text 230 pixels
this is the all selector we have used
font size 30 pixels
now before the text we are going to add
some symbols so we'll use double column
Q before
we'll add the content with some symbol
like this
keep the color of this
symbol to Blue
and we'll use the after pseudo class to
add the content
like this
we'll keep this color to red
now that we have everything in place
let's go back to see how it looks
you can see the symbols before and after
our text so this is how the before
Studio element works
so the next function we are going to
discuss is CSS loader
the CSS loader is an animation that
shows the visitor about the page when it
is loading it is helpful when a page
takes some seconds to load the page
content it is similar to the buffer sign
so let's see how to create a loader so I
hope you remember the concept of the
keyframes and animations
if you want to revise the concepts you
can watch the previous videos on the
keyframes and animations from the
playlist
so
let's create the loader
we have the standard boilerplate
so inside the body tag just add the
center tag and inside it
will add one H1 which says
welcome to Simply learn
we'll add five div tags with the class
A1 A2 A3 A4 and A5
together
just copy paste it five times
so this is A1 A2 A3 A4 and A5
let's open our style tag inside us style
tab we'll first add color to our H1
so
let's keep the color of our H1 to Orange
foreign
we keep the display to block
um keep the position to Absolute
we set the width and height to 10 pixels
each so with 10 pixels
and height 10 pixels
we'll use the calc function to determine
the left margin so to use the calc
function that add CLC
50 percent
minus 1 em
the calc function performs a calculation
to be used as a property value
keep the Border radius to say 1.3 em
s is related to the font size of the
element
1.3 em means 1.3 times the size of the
current font
we'll use the transform origin function
with a value 1.3 em
PTY to here
the transfer margin property allows you
to change the position of the
transformed elements
Ruby Transformations can change the X
and Y axis
we'll keep the animation iteration count
in finite
I will keep the animation duration to 2
seconds
let's save and go back to the page to
see how it looks at this point
so as you can see we have our heading
and you cannot see it but we have a
loader ready
and we just have to add some keyframes
and animations here
so
let's define keyframes
with the name of the animation rotate
so at zero percent
to transform
function to rotate it to
zero degrees
just copy copy this
at hundred percent when it's complete it
will rotate to the complete 360 degrees
so here we will give the value to 60
degrees
now let's design each of the
classes here that we have defined so
dot K1
the animation delay
will be of 0.1 seconds
so for each of the classes that we have
here we have to Define them with a
different color
so that when the loader appears we can
see them clearly with the different
colors so for this
A1 let's keep the background color to
say cyan
let's copy paste it
so that you don't if you don't write our
code again and again three four and five
let's make changes here so for the A2
appear after 0.2 seconds
the color pink
to 0.3 seconds
The Color Purple
green
0.5 seconds says color black
we have kept the animation delay to so
close like 0.1 seconds 0.2 seconds 0.6
seconds so that the loader appears in a
complete sink with each other foreign
so just save the file and refresh and go
back to the page
now you can see this is the loader we
have our heading and this is like a
buffer and it will show when you have
some content to load
in this tutorial we are going to discuss
what is responsive design and how we can
so let's get started making a website
with an adaptable layout is called
responsive web design and CSS media quiz
are one of the most important part of
responsive design
in the past building a website was much
simpler today a Website Layout should
adapt itself not only to computers but
also to tablet mobile devices and even
TVs so let's see how we can create
responsive web layout using CSS media
queries with the help of an example so
here we have a Sublime Text Editor we
haven't a standard wallet print ready so
let's create something
so let's start by creating the four days
here
we give it a class name box
with an ID box one
foreign
just copy it four times
let's rename this ID to box two and here
we'll type back OS
for the Box three will have
linen and the box or
will have Android
let's add some styling over here
so just open this time tag
we send the text align to Center
uh we'll check the background color
let's select some color
seller
you set the text color to white
and we'll set the font size to say
something
it's a file let's go back to and refresh
the page
let's figure it out
okay so of course this is not valid
so now if you refresh you see we have
our lives with Windows Mac OS Linux and
Android and with this background color
so
to design a responsive web pages use the
media queries so what are media queries
let's first discuss this
so a media keys are used when we want to
customize the website presentation
according to the user screen size with
the help of the video queries you can
display different markups based on the
devices General type mobile desktop
tablet to name it
is applied to the Target element
so to start the video query just type at
a rate and media
now here we'll mention the max weight
to save 400 pixels
the status media query you write the CSS
code that should take an effect when
this condition is satisfied
so here
will set the box one
to display block
now
if you go back to the page and you
refresh
you see nothing happens because we are
not made this display To None So first
go back to the CSS code
and secondly display to none
now you can see we don't have any
display here so let's inspect the page
first
so you'll see we have our contents here
now you can see this is the layout we
are currently using a current width is
685 pixels into high 255 pixels
now we are setting a Max width to 400
pixel this means if this width decreases
to less than 400 pixels how this CSS
score will kick in so let's decrease the
width here
so as you decrease
QC as soon as it gets less than 400
pixels rcss kit kicks in so we have our
Windows displayed here which is the box
id1 so this is how the media query works
let's add some more media queries to
understand it better so just copy this
code now
so now let's set this minimum width
to
4001 pixels
and maximum to say 600 pixels
now when this condition is true let's
say we want our box to
to display block
with color green
so this is the background color here
to let's say agree
now we will add one more media query
so just copy this code
[Music]
paste it here
so when the grid is from 601 pixels to
stay
800 pixels so we'll set the Box 3
display
to block and color
to get pink
so just save this unless understand it
on the page
so let's change the width of the screen
so see as soon as the width goes less
than 400 pixels we have our windows on
display
now we're going to increase the width
size
101 pixels it has a Mac OS display keep
on increasing it
now see the width is more than 1500
pixels and we have a Linux on display so
this is how we create the responsive web
design for the different devices in this
session we we're gonna cover the topic
of what is angular I'm sure all of you
use mobile and web applications
from social media to healthcare
e-commerce and net banking these apps
are used by billions of people across
the globe now the main reason we use
these apps is that they offer seamless
user experience and interface but how
would it develop to provide such
reliability one of the Frameworks that
is widely used to build such robust apps
is angular so let's dive into the
session now so here is a list of topics
that we're going to be covering first up
we'll see why angular was introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture advantages and
limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we look at some of the companies
that deploy angular so without further
delay let's begin
why angular now JavaScript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into HTML
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises this JavaScript ideal
for developing single page applications
that require modularity testability and
other features perhaps not however we
have a variety of Frameworks and
libraries designed to help us with such
thing with respect to front-end
development angular and JavaScript
together bring in structure and
consistency to your web applications and
also provide scalability and
maintainability
an angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angle angular is an
us JavaScript framework written
completely in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by Google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for Developers
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms
doubt here as to what exactly single
page application locations are that
will help you with that now these single
page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent Pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model type script data binding
and testing now let's look at them one
by one now the document object model
treats an XML or an HTML document as a
tree structure now here every node in
the tree structure defines an object
representing a part of your document
angular uses the regular Dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single HTML page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding Dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of HTML tags moving on to our
next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
JavaScript which helps you write
JavaScript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic JavaScript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is a mandatory for developing an angular
application but it is highly recommended
the main reason is highly recommended is
that it offers better syntactic
structure while making the code base
easier to understand and maintain now
typescript can be installed as an npm
package now to do that you just have to
run the command npm install hyphen G
type script on your command prompt next
up is data binding data binding is a
process that allows you to manipulate
web page elements using the web browser
now it mainly employs Dynamic HTML and
does not require complex scripting or
programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials Games Etc now incremental
display of a web page
data binding extremely convenient when
Pages contain a large amount of data
when it comes to angular it uses two-way
data binding so any changes meet in the
UI element is reflected in the
corresponding model state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state are reflected onto the UI
State this allows the framework to
connect a tonk to the model data via the
controller the last feature we're
discussing is testing
angular uses Jasmine to run its various
tests the Jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases karma is a
task Runner to the tests that use a
configuration file to set the startup
reporters and testing framework so with
that we've covered the features of
angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged MVC framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real Dom MEC short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for UI logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your JavaScript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed this
greatly improves the testability and
reusability of the same don't worry if
you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next Advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind you can literally
test every part of your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out of the box
solutions for Server communication
routing and mocking
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross-platform
and browser compatible
an angular application can typically run
on all browsers beat Chrome Firefox
Safari and platforms like Windows Mac OS
and Linux now many versions of angular
have been released ever since its
Inception all of these versions have
added to the efficient working of the
framework now here are the different
versions released first up goes angular
1. it was built on JavaScript and
completely based on controllers next
release was angular 2. now this
Incorporated the component based
approach wherein the entire UI was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic next was angular 4 it included
router reputation angular CLI or command
line interface 1.0 was introduced
however not deployed in this release the
angular CLI was optimized and commands
like NG update and NG add were added
the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in CLI
about the functions being used
in angular 8 IB renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the IV renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learned about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
last up is a steep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
Learners to begin with you need to be
acquainted with simple topics and then
move on to more advanced topics to
become proficient in this language
next up is limited SEO auctions
angular offers limited SEO options and
poor accessibility to search engine
Crawlers
it were both and complex now a common
issue faced by the angular Community is
the verbosity of the framework it also
poses to be complex compared to other
front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to Port Legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
Backward Compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular some of them are directors
modules decorators components Services
dependency injection pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your Basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js however
the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut in the beginning it could be a
little intimidating but once you start
using the tool becomes way more easier
to comprehend and understand what is
going on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like Nike Forbes
Google HBO Sony upwork among others
readily deploy angular so moving on
let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have node.js
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system next up is the angular
CLI now this command line interface is a
tool that makes it easier to bootstrap
and develop your angular applications
now to install the latest version run
the command npm install hyphen G at
angular front slash CLI you gotta run
this command on your command prompt and
finally to confirm installation check
for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an IDE or a text editor to type your
code now there are several Ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites I think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin here
I've created a folder called angular on
my desktop and opened it on my visual
studio code so to create your app you
need to open the terminal just go here
and
select new terminal
and now type in the command Ng
new
and provide the name for your app so I'm
just gonna say hello world
so now this is going to create
to see yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
Hello World in our case and it includes
a bunch of files and installs all the
necessary dependencies for the angular
application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say CD
hello world
and now use the command NG so
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that
you can see your UI
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser and it
says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but I'll brush through a few
of them
so the first mean component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app Root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is a part of the bootstrapping
piece all right so the index.html file
is responsible for deciding which files
are to be loaded correct the main.ts
file on the other hand identifies which
angular module is to be loaded when the
application starts so this is just a
brief explanation as to what they're
doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the app dot module.ts file now this
application module file can be thought
of as a core configuration of your
application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts these are all
typescript files hence the extension TS
now this file basically is the root
component of your application and then
we have the HTML file for the same which
defines the appearance of what you can
see on your browser so let me just
change the message that is being
displayed
so I'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are
then I'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our Channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the Bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now I'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is Gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as Lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application
so in this case here we have the logo
component then you have a sign in
component an image component and then a
create account component now all of
these components generally don't affect
the working of each other but however
when embedded they Define the UI of your
application
so I hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directors you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directors
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom HTML elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when I show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator Now The Decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the NG module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime Behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks so this was just a brief
introduction to what annular components
are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when I show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a Visual Studio code now here back in my
vs code I've created a folder called
angular demo within which I've created
an angular application called demo
components once executed the browser
looks something like this so if you
haven't watched a previous video on
getting started with angular that is
angular hello world I highly suggest you
go through that video first it helps you
create your first angular application so
um now let's go ahead and create our
first component now the command used to
create our component is NG GC and your
component name once executed it creates
four different files now let's just see
how this works on RVs code now what you
can do is head to your terminal and type
in the command Ng
g c
and provide a name for your component
for example I'm gonna just call my
component text component all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your Source folder within which
is an app folder and again here you can
see that your four different files have
been created first is the HTML file
wherein you can Define all the code that
you want for your component next you
have the CSS file for your styling then
you have the dot TS file which includes
the component decorator and finally you
have spec.ts which is basically a unit
test file all right and then in your
app.module.ts you can observe that the
component that you've created that is
text component has been imported that is
what the message conveys here all right
now let's go back to our
app.component.html now this basically
has all the corefair applications so so
let me just get rid of it
and I'm just gonna display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome all right so let me save it and
if you go ahead and look at your browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our
component.html file and here let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components all right now in
your text component dot TS file which is
your typescript file the selector
mentioned here is app hyphen text
component now go ahead and copy this
and in your final
comprint.html go ahead and create your
custom HTML tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
Incorporated in the final render so what
happens is that whatever is defined in
the component.html file is also being
rendered in your final output so when I
save this let's go ahead and check our
browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed so this was a
simple creation of a component now for
this let's give it some styling so here
go to your dot CSS file and provide some
styling see for example here I just say
text line
and let me say Center and also in my
app.component.cs I'm going to give the
same thing let's see each one
text align is Center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and Define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially so now let's
create another component just to give
you a brief insight into it let's say NG
GC image component
now here I'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so I'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here I've added the
logo so what I can do is back in my HTML
file I can go ahead and create an image
tag so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
and then let me say
image
Source equals so the source is basically
assets
[Music]
slash logo
dot PNG
and class equals
Center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
CSS file and provide any sort of styling
that you need so let me just see
text
align
to be Center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here I mentioned the code for the
image so let's save this I'm from the
dot CS file let's copy the selector
and create a custom HTML tag in our
final component.html file
[Music]
so there we go let's save this and check
the output
and there we go first the hello welcome
message is displayed next you have the
message displayed from the first
component and then you have the second
component so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final HTML file so moving on to our next
topic component decorator metadata now
as mentioned earlier the at component
decorator accepts a metadata object that
provides information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
CSS selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the HTML tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own HTML tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component correct
for the time being let's change it to
say n component
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser the message is not
displayed so what we can do is you can
copy this
selector and then include this
here
and now you can see that the same
component has been rendered onto your
output all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the UI
next up we have template URL now it is
the URL for the external file containing
the template for The View
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view next
up you have Styles now these are also
inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot CSS
file can also be included here
next you have the style URLs now this is
a list of URLs to your style sheets that
are applied on your components View
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain Services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally I'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this I'm sure you are
aware that angular uses the concept of
componence the entire UI of the
application is divided into several
components now what have all of these
components perform similar tasks be it
accessing the database rendering images
Etc now instead of writing the same
piece of code for every component you
could write the code once and then
perhaps inject the same code into every
component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes A and B now let's
assume that a uses the objects of Class
B and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of Class B is
created so that a can access its objects
with using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the code more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly di benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider Class Postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
Constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the Constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code let's assume that
the number and address class
Constructors now accept parameters when
we change the numbers class the postal
details class gets broken now to
overcome this what we need to do is we
need to pass parameter to the number
Constructor so this applies to address
as well the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible anytime the
dependencies change the postal details
class needs to be changed as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where class receives
its dependencies from an external Source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the Constructor to the
constructor's parameters so the postal
details class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using Di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules components all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo I'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these Services into classes so
the main thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience these components do
not generally execute tasks so to
execute these tasks we make use of
services so a component can delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
any network related issues
ETC to a particular service and these
Services can be made available to
components with the same thought what
I'm going to be doing is I'll be
creating a service that performs a task
of displaying an employee list later
we're going to inject the service into
the class using dependency injection so
let's head to our Visual Studio code for
the demonstration
all right so as discussed I'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then I have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee ID email ID
Etc so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
NG GC
and the name of the component I'm
providing is M info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so as
the four different files all right so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to create a service so to create that we
make use of the command n g g s
you can either give s or service and the
service name I'm providing is records so
let me just say record zero
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spect.ts file and the
dot TS file all right so now the service
contains all the employee data that
needs to be displayed right so let's go
ahead and write the data so first we're
going to make use of three arrays I'm
going to be displaying employee records
for three employees so I'll have to
create three arrays and provide certain
information so let's go ahead and do
that
all right so the array I'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and I'm going to be passing
information like name employee ID and
the email ID so the arrays of type
string
and within which let me just mention the
details I'm giving random information
I'm just saying Adam Taylor
and some random
employee ID
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so I'm going to be creating
three records so I'll just copy the same
thing and paste with the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
[Music]
and let me change the name of the area
as well
followed so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method Returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
I'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot info one
all right I'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
I'm just gonna return different arrays
here
all right and lastly info 3. all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data and
let's go back to our component dot TS
file here and then type in the following
code
so I've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct now as I
mentioned services are implemented with
the help of dependency injection so what
we need to do is we'll have to first
import the service into the component.ts
file the key reason behind doing this is
that when angular creates this component
and instance of the service class is
also made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so I'll say import
[Music]
records
services
I'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the provider's
area of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class right however to access
this instance an object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
Constructor method let's say Constructor
private
and the object I'm creating is called
our service you can give a name of your
choice and then I'm gonna just say
records service
all right now this object will help me
retrieve data from the service so let's
go ahead and use this in order to get
the employee details our ads have
created three different methods here get
info from service class 2 1 and 3 and
these methods will retrieve the data and
add it to our array here that is info
received all right and lastly we'll have
to create an unordered list in our HTML
file here we haven't added anything so
let me get rid of this
so now I have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the UI right
so as you can see I've created buttons
for three different employees
and then I've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info and then
I've
interpolated info which displays the
contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot TS
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom HTML tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy this here
and then in my app component.html let me
get rid of this
and then let me just create this
I've just created the custom HTML tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code I'll
write a heading
and let's say employee
details
and then I'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
I've I've added the image here so let me
just say logo
dot PNG
I've also added some styling to it all
right so now let me just save this and
have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when I click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the ID and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further Ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now I'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms Etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application you need forms to update
your profile or to enter sensitive
information or also to perform any sort
of data related tasks so now let's look
at the different types of form building
supported by angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one
so talking about template driven
approach in this method the conventional
form tag is used to create forms so
angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directors
now consoles can be added to the form
using the NG model tag now multiple
controls can be grouped using the NG
control group module so it basically
uses several module classes to provide
controls now if you don't get this don't
worry you'll understand better when I'm
showing you the demo
next up is Json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as Json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic HTML validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
Paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the
anti-packtern of updating the data model
via two-way data binding so it does not
use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created now these instances
help check the values of the field and
see if they are either touched untouched
dirty pristine valid invalid and so on
so this allows you to check every field
for the value it makes it easier to
understand which Fields value is invalid
or which field has not been entered
Etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so I hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features I am
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo so for that let's
head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
I've created a component called form
component and I've also included the
simply learn logo just to purify the
appearance so once you execute the code
this is what you want to see on your
browser so you just have the logo at the
moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to import to forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
ID and the password all right so now let
me show you how to import the forms
module so in your main
app.module.ts file you'll have to import
forms module from angular forms
all right and then in your Imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and start our form creation
so here in my component.html let's
enclose the entire form within a div tag
so here let me say div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
which says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now I'm going to create a div class for
every field so say div
class
equals form group
I'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this we have to do for all the other
fields so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
I'll also add the tag three for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type submit
and let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh user
registration form ready but I would like
to uh align it to the center so let me
just do that
so here in my CSS file
I'm just going to uh align all the div
tags in the center and the label tag to
the left so let me save this and look at
the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form was a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
NG model now this directive and added
into the input tag will provide form
controls to every input field all right
so here let's just go ahead and say NG
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this and back in
my browser let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like NG untouched NG pristine NG
ballot are added right so this indicates
that angular has recognized the form Tab
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the NG
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called NG
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the subwit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just say
form
NG submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when I click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate JavaScript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called NG form that is
assigned to a template variable
okay so this JavaScript representation
helps with validating all the fields so
I'll help you understand that better
so back in our HTML file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right and say Ng
form
okay now the mg form object includes the
JavaScript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file again let's just say
login
and along with it
I want login to be displayed so
I say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the JavaScript
representation So within form
I can
check for email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now
um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty and the form only accepts names
with the minimum length of 2 and the
maximum length of 7. all right so here
in my input tag I just mentioned a
required meaning this field cannot be
empty
and Min length
to 2
and
max length
to say 7.
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when I submit it
and I look here
within forms and here controls
and my first name you can see that an
error is shown here it says required
equals true that means that there is one
error now you can make use of these form
control objects you can leverage form
control objects to ensure field
validation and display a message
whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid or
touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable let me call it
name
and let's say NG model
all right here the readable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when I submit
again without the first name
you can see that the invalid
property is set to True correct so this
helps us use this property to alert the
user with the help of a simple if logic
so back in my vs code let me create
another div tag
within which I mentioned NG if
within which I'm going to use a simple
if logic so let's say ngf
name which is our template variable name
dot touched
and name dot invalid
is true
right then I'm going to alert
so I'm gonna
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
Danger
all right
so in my CSS file I'll have to mention
the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're gonna have the background color
red
for danger all right and here I'm going
to display the message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here so this
was a simple demonstration to show you
form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement say
suppose the length of the first name is
too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or uh suppose
they have missed out on filling a form
field then you can again alert the user
so you can basically make use of the
nested if condition right now just to
and help you understand that better let
me just show it to you
now back in my HTML file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
within which I make use of NG if again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then I display the message first
name required
all right
and if
the length of the first name is
[Music]
not 2.
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then I'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot Min length
if this is true then I'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when I proceed without providing the
name it says first name required but
when I type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if I type in
another character it accepts so I hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now I highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun so I hope this tutorial helped you
out I'm sure you all know that an
angular app is divided into several
components for example you have the logo
component you have the sign in component
an image component and say a create
account component
now these components are Standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
access in the database or rendering
images on The View
tasks like those now instead of having
to write the code for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
they're injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it now
the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells Angela that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these Services hold valuable
business logic and can also be used to
interact with the back end now for
example if you want to make Ajax calls
you can have methods to those calls in a
service and then use it as a dependency
in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are Singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module I'm sure
you'll understand the concept of
services better if we look at a simple
demo so in the next section we're going
to look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee ID and
their email ID we'll create a database
of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employees details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular Services
Hands-On so here first I've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
which in which I've created a file
called hello world so uh this was
previously used for a tutorial so the
name is just hello world so don't get
confused
however when you look at the browser
I've written an initial code here which
is angular services and I have the
simply learn logo so back in my browser
this is what the UI looks like
so uh to
understand the concept of angular
Services first let's go ahead and create
a component
so here I am going to say NG g c
e info
I'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app file we have the E info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then I highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so I'm just typing in the command NG G
here G stands for Generate and we're
generating a service and the name of the
service that I'm providing is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be a DOT TS file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file I'm going to
create an array that displays the
employee information in our case I'm
creating uh three different employee
records so for that I'll have three
different arrays so let me just call the
arrays info
received
one indicating this is the information
of first employee and this is going to
be of type string
and I'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and I'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now to retrieve the information I'll
have to create a method again I'm
creating three methods for the three
different employee records
so I'm gonna call the array get info
[Music]
from service one indicating it's again
for employee one
and
I'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
I'll tell you how the information is
being received
and I'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records so let me just
copy paste and here I'm just going to
change
the name of the methods
all right so uh this is the initial code
for retrieving information however we'll
have to create the employee record in
our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what I'm gonna do is
I'll create three different uh Records
for the employees so let me say info one
which is going to be of type string
[Music]
all right
and let me just give a random names say
for example I say John
Matthew
[Music]
all right
and employee ID say
if 354
and let me just give a random
email ID and say JM abc.net
all right so I'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh Records
so let me just create another one and
call it info two
and the name I'm providing is say Rob
listen
with a different employee ID says 673
and I'm just gonna make it RW at abc.net
and another record for employee number
three
and I'm just gonna say rows Adams
[Music]
with
some employee ID
and an email ID all right
so now we've created the employee
records so what I have to do is I have
to create a method that returns these
employee records correct so for that I'm
just gonna create another method called
get info one
which is of type string
and it just returns
this dot info one
all right similarly for the rest of the
two records I'm just gonna retrieve them
let's say info 2 and get info two
and again
I'm just gonna make it get in for three
and this is gonna return info 3.
all right so I'm sure you've got an idea
as to what I'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that I'll have to make
use of dependency injection
so here I'll have to import the service
that I've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service with data service
all right from
[Music]
slash data.service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular that when the component
is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our provider's
array so here let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so uh this property basically allows us
to access all the methods that are
defined in the service class
all right so here in my Constructor
method I'm just gonna say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here I'm just giving the
name d service
all right and which is of type data
service
all right
so now with the help of this property I
can retrieve information from the
service class so here I'm just going to
save
this Dot
info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service which Returns the
information of the first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info receipt one
so similarly for the next two methods
I'm just going to use the same piece of
code
let me just change it here
yeah
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the UI for it
here in my HTML file
I'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now I'm going to make use of the NG
for director
to basically Loop over the record and
display everything so for that I have to
make use of a particular variable so
I'll just say
let info
[Music]
of info receipt
so you can check here in our TS file the
array is info received correct so I'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first
employee record I'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a Class
A bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right I hope this was clear to you
so basically here the information is
being retrieved with the help of this
method right that is get info from
service one so in order to call this
method we'll have to bind it with a
button all right so that's what we're
going to do
let's just
copy this and here I'm going to create a
button
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with the name
button again
all right so I'm going to bind it with
the click event so what happens is that
when I click on it this particular
method gets called
all right I'm just facing the method
here
and finally let's just
provide the name employee one
for the button all right
so uh similarly we'll have to do the
same for the other two records as well
let me just
settle all right so what I'm going to do
is I'm just gonna paste the same
twice
and here I'm gonna just change the names
I'll say 2 here and this is again for
employee two
and I'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employed I'm sorry it's
going to be in four received two this is
going to be in four received three
and finally employee three
all right and lastly we'll have to
include
the selector that is app hyphen en4
in our main
component.html so here
let me just
create a custom tag alright and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that uh three
different buttons have been created for
employee one two and three and when you
click on it it retrieves information
that is the name the employee ID and
their email IDs so we've successfully
created an angular service and injected
it into our component to retrieve
information all right so now the last
part of the use case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail that is the
employee detail in the record all right
so for that we'll have to take uh input
from the user and in our case we're
taking the location now we're also
adding the same location for all three
employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit and
you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter
Etc all right so for that what we're
going to do is back in the HTML file
we'll create a form that basically takes
the input
so I'm just going to say um
[Music]
form
all right within which I'm going to be
defining a div class
[Music]
within which I'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside which I'll have the input tag
of type
text
and the name I'm going to be providing
it will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and I'll just
leave it blank and finally I'll have NG
model so if you're confused as to what
I'm doing here then I suggest you watch
the angular forms uh video it basically
teaches you uh how to work around with
angular forms
all right and now after this we're gonna
have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
and I'm going to just say add info
okay
all right so now when I'm creating the
form I'll also have to create a template
variable to access all the values within
my form so if I have to access the
location then I need a variable to
access it so here let me just go ahead
and create a template variable let me
call it frm
and I'm gonna make use of the NG form
directive
so this tells angular
that uh this variable can be used to
access all the values within the form
and since I'm using form here I'll have
to import it in my module file
so here
I just go ahead
and see
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
I'll just say forms module
okay so I've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my HTML file
what I'm going to do is that I'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct so I'll
have to create another method that will
update information into the records
so here in my component.ts file I'll
have to create another method and I'm
going to call this method update info
method
all right and uh this basically takes in
the template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do is
that it updates
the record correct so I'm gonna say this
Dot
D service
add info now you must be wondering what
add info is
I'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that I'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form dot value dot location
all right so now what happens is that
I'll have to again specify what add info
is and this method is going to be
defined in the service file correct
so here I'm going to create another
um
method that's add
info
and I'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since I'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info 1 info 2 and info
three I'm just gonna say this dot info1
dot push
off info
all right and the same for
the other two arrays as well
change these all right
so what exactly I'm doing is that I have
I have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also I'll
have to return it so I'll save return
this dot info
one
all right and I'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls the ad
info method in our service
and passes the value to it
and in my HTML file also note that the
button type here is submit
and not button so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
passed on to the method that is update
info so here I'll say NG submit
and I'm going to call the method update
info
and I'm gonna pass
frm as the argument and now let's see
this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now I can just go ahead and say type
USA
and when I say add info and when I check
on my employee one details USA has been
added to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so I hope this simple demo on angular
Services helped you understand the
concept better I highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of HTML CSS and
JavaScript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
Pages it is a free and open source
project based on GitHub and originally
created by Twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of Handy reusable bits
of code written in HTML CSS and
JavaScript it's also a front-end
development framework that enables
developers and beginners to design quick
and responsive websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid you don't have to spend
time working on your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page these
components could be navigation bars drop
downs progress bars thumbnails
Etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application so
let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it
first up is by using the bootstrap CDN
or the content delivery Network
now this enables users to load CSS
JavaScript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jQuery and other packages and
Frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that I am going to be
showing you I have embedded bootstrap
using npm alright so I'm sure you only
understand the concept better when you
look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what I'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post so so uh let me show you what
we're going to be doing
so here I've created a simple blog
for simply learn and I've added the
simply learn logo I've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer I've also mentioned their
tagline and when you scroll down you can
see that I've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course so this is for lean
sex Sigma the same for full stack web
development
as well
and the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally I've added a simple video
here to just make it more uh beautiful
so I've added a simple video
and lastly I've also linked our YouTube
channel so when you click on the YouTube
icon it will navigate to the YouTube
channel
to our YouTube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating uh using angular bootstrap
so I'm hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in so
first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that I'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and I'm just going to click on the first
link that I get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like so I'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that you can then click on live
preview
and once you do that
you can just
save view frame source
so here you can see that the HTML code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the title
and then you also have the CSS file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the UI there's code for navigation
bar and then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that and
lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
HTML file
so that is the best practice that Anglo
uses so we're going to make use of
components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that it has
certain dependencies so here it has the
bootstrap dependency and then you have
jQuery so we'll have to download them
so we'll have to install them and as
mentioned earlier we're going to be
installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code I've created a
folder called angular demo and then I've
also created a file called demo
components
and here
I'm just going to say CD
demo components
within which I'll say npm install
cheat query
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jQuery go
ahead and type npm install bootstrap
[Music]
alright so we've successfully installed
jQuery and bootstrap so now we need to
add the references to these JavaScript
files to do that go to your angular.json
file
and here we'll have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so now scripts
array we Define the relative path to
these JavaScript files so these files
are generally uh stored in your node
modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and then in your dist file
and then click on Js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
uh well I'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my Json file in my scripts
I'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path while providing by
providing forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jQuery so here there's
jQuery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here in the beginning
they've also included the CSS file so
we'll have to embed that as well so
here back in bootstrap
let me just add the CSS file as well
that's
bootstrap.nint.css I'm just going to
copy the relative path and just provide
it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to copy this
and just paste it in our
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so I think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
uh what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and take the code from The Source
here so I'm just going to copy the body
tag
all right so
I'm gonna copy this till the footer
and then I'm just gonna paste it in my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier I will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the UI in these
components
so let me just see if I've got
everything here
okay
so I'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components I've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so I just have to
type in the command
nggc first we'll create the component
for the top navigation bar so I'm just
saying NG GC so I'm just gonna say
components
navbar
[Music]
alright so uh the component has been
created so what I'm going to do is I'll
just
copy this
[Music]
here
all right and the next component I'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so I'll say NG g c
components slash intro
all right so
so I will have to take
this code here I'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so I'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
[Music]
so let me do that and then I'm gonna
have the main course content
component so for that I'll say NG GC
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're gonna copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until till the footer
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so I'll say
nggc
components slash photo
and the last part of the code I'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
HTML tags for these components and then
place it in our HTML file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the TS file
just copy the selector
[Music]
and then here
and then in our app dot component let me
just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
just going to copy the selector
and then for courses so
and add a hyphen courses
that as well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything uh is
displayed in that so here let me just
say NG serve so when you execute the
command you can see that the template is
being displayed so you have the
navigation bar you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now I'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tagline here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize and display the final output
so here
the first thing that I'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here I'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our nav bar component
let's go to the HTML code and here
instead of start bootstrap let me just
type in simply learn
[Music]
all right so when you save it and when
you look at the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that I want to do is
I want to add the image right a simply
learn logo
so what I've done here is I've already
added the logo uh dot PNG file in my
assets folder
so I'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this so that's going to be in
our intro files so here
image source is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
logo dot PNG
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change this part of the UI so the
information that I want to display is
this
I'm going to be displaying
world's number one online boot camp and
other information so what I'm going to
do is back in my vs code I'm just gonna
delete
this
and instead of that I'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online boot camp
and then within the paragraph tag I'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that I
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
and we save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message I'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then lastly
instead of this message here
I want to display the message or get
certified get ahead without programs so
back in our vs code
I'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you uh have a look at the
browser
Let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message gets
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what I'm going to do is I'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so I'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here I'm just gonna mention Style
and then say font size
and I'm gonna make it XX large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so I think I'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in RBS code
we'll have to go to the courses
component so here I'm gonna just type in
the code for the different courses so I
already have it here so the first thing
is this message that I want to display
let me just copy that
and for our first tag I'm just gonna say
postgraduate program and lean Six Sigma
and the next information I'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
[Music]
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the code and then
and here for our reference link I
already have the link here
so I'm just gonna paste that so once you
click on the more info button it will
automatically navigate to this page
all right
so let me see this
next up I'm gonna do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in full
stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
okay
let me paste that
and also provide a blind break
and then link I have it here so
I'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card I have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra code and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
[Music]
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that the information has
been added you can see it displays
postgraduate program in lean sex Sigma
full stack development and cyber
security so once I click on more info it
leads you to that page
that shows the overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to uh display a short video and then the
link to our YouTube channel so let's go
ahead and add that in our
cautious component
so what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from Google and then I'm going to
provide the source uh which is going to
be the video that I would want to
display
so I've received the code I'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on Google so
go ahead and just paste that also for
the source I have a video in my assets
folder which I have provided here
so when I save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right and once clicked it starts
playing
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for YouTube and then
the link to navigate to the YouTube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again I've pasted the code
for the YouTube logo so here you can see
that I've added the image that is
YouTube dot PNG in my assets folder and
I've provided the source
and accordingly I've also added
The Styling I've provided a white
background and I've also aligned the
text to the center of the page
all right and I've also displayed the
message saying check out our YouTube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then I provided the link to our
Channel on YouTube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the YouTube logo
and we have the message displayed so
once you click on the logo it navigates
to the simply learn Channel on YouTube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in footer.html I can just
remove this and
paste this I see simply on Solutions and
All Rights Reserved and I save it and
look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a Blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed it into your
angular for more responsive and better
user interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now I'm sure that you observed that the
URL changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create a single
page applications now these applications
are loaded just once and new content is
added dynamically applications like
Google Facebook Twitter and Gmail are a
few examples of single page applications
the best part of using single page
applications is that it provides an
excellent user experience and you don't
even have to wait for new pages to load
which by extension makes single page
applications extremely fast but how is
this new content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
so I'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it Hands-On
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our Visual Studio code
so basically the objective of our
application is to navigate to home and
the login pages so when I click on the
login icon here
it loads the login page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the URL changes
with a slash home appended all right so
this is the main objective of our
application so to create it let's head
back to our vs code all right so here
I've created a folder called demo and
underscore angular and I've created a
file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added now although
this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the URL while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your app dot module.ts file and
check if the app routing module has been
imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your Imports array
or with that or the initial setup is
done
Now to create the nav bar the code that
I'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap I highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so uh the code is already available I'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it and paste the code
in it so let's do that
let me say NG GC
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my HTML file
I'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go I've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file I'll just remove
all The Unwanted code here
and just specify the
custom HTML tag for my nav bar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when I open the browser uh
the navigation bar has been created
along with these different options
that's home about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content now again I have used
bootstrap to define the user interface
for these files you can easily find the
code online just search for a bootstrap
login templates and depending on your
requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
nggc
I'm just gonna call it login for my
login component
all right and then I'm gonna say nggc
home for the home component
all right
so I'm just going to copy the code for
the login component
so back in my login.html
file
I'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that I've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the footer message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what I'm going to do is
I'll just paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content uh
one thing I want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this I've just
added all the code in the same component
now I agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom HTML
tags in your home component
I'm just hoping you're following me
right now and also here in my assets
folder I have added a video and the
YouTube logo that needs to be displayed
uh when the home icon is clicked all
right so now that we've created the home
and the login components the next step
is to configure the routes for the
application
right so here you can see that we have a
file called app routing module.ts file
so here we have the routes and the
router module that is imported and we
also have a constant called routes which
is strongly typed two routes from the
router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path so here in my
routes array I'm just going to go ahead
and create the paths that is we have two
different uh routes right one is for
login and one is for home
so I'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
sorry within curly braces I say path
[Music]
and then the path that I'm going to give
is login
this is basically what will appear uh on
the URL all right and the component that
needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component as you can see the login
component has been automatically
imported
now same with
the Home Path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
foreign
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the nav bar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives
from the router package called router
link and router link active now these
are specified within the anchor tag the
router link basically holds the path to
the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more CSS classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're gonna have another director
called router link active
[Music]
and we're just gonna save active here
all right same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your UI
now despite of all this how are we
specifying where these components are to
be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router Outlet director now again this
directive is available in the router
package so we have to add that in our
app component.html file the background
so here just go ahead and type
router Outlet
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar which has
different options that is home about
services and Link and once the user
clicks on the home icon it displays the
content that is in the home
component.html file and once the user
clicks on the login component it
displays the content in the login.html
file all right it's as simple as that so
now let's go to the browser and see if
it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once I click on the home icon here
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our URL you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when I click on
this icon you can see that the path
changes here and the login component
gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular in this session we
will learn about the database and the
need for a database then we will
transition to SQL and see some basic SQL
queries after knowing what a SQL query
is we will see the features in
application superscript query and then
we will have a hand on some of the basic
SQL queries so hey everyone I'm amishad
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video One SQL basics for beginners but
before we begin if you love watching
Tech videos subscribe to our Channel and
hit the Bell icon to now miss an update
let's start with database a database is
a vast collection of data that is stored
and retrieved electronically from a
system in today's world data has become
the new oil which has mandate companies
and businesses to rely on an excellent
database to store the vast amounts of
data
every millisecond the tech Giants are
accumulating vast amounts of data that
need to be stored the database comes
with features to update and effortlessly
manipulate data and not only that these
database provider companies ensure the
data to be safe and secure they also
provide tools to extract useful
information to help the companies make
meaningful decisions
after knowing about the database let's
see how SQL communicates with the
database to get desired results
SQL stands for structured query language
the structured query language is the
standard language used by database
operators and developers to carry out
different operations from manipulating
updating and retrieving data from
relational databases
now let us see how we write a basic
query there's a customer table with
columns customer ID customer name age
gender date of purchase address item and
price
and we need to extract the customer ID
and customer name from this table
so we will write a query select customer
ID comma customer name from customers
semicolon when we will execute the query
in MySQL workbench we will get the
desired result that is the output table
with customer ID and customer name this
is how we write a query to extract the
information from the database we'll see
some more queries as the session
proceeds
now we'll see what the features of SQL
are SQL lets you access any information
stored in a relational database with SQL
queries data is extracted from the
database in a very efficient way
the structured query language is
compatible with all database systems
from Oracle IBM to Microsoft and it
doesn't require much coding to manage
databases
now we will see applications of SQL SQL
is used to create a database Define its
structure implement it and let you
perform many functions SQL is also used
for maintaining an already existing
database SQL is a powerful language for
entering data modifying data and
extracting data in a database SQL is
extensively used as a client server
language to connect the front end with
the back end the supporting the client
server architecture
SQL when deployed as data control
language DCL helps protect your database
from unauthorized access
ing SQL with its features and
applications let's go through some basic
queries in SQL
that is ddl data definition language DML
data manipulation language DCL data
control language TCL transaction control
language ddl or data definition language
consists of the SQL commands that can be
used to define the database schema let's
see ddl commands create command is used
to create the database or its objects
like table index function views store
procedure and triggers drop is used to
delete objects from the database
truncate is used to remove all records
from a table alter is used to alter the
structure of the database
DMF or data manipulation language
consists of the SQL commands that deals
with the manipulation of data present in
the database insert into command is used
to insert data into a table update is
used to update existing data within a
table delete is used to delete records
from a database table select this
command helps you to select the
attribute based on the condition
described by the where clause
clo transaction control language these
commands deals with the transaction
within the database commit commands
commit a transaction
roll back command roll backs a
transaction in case of any error occurs
save point it sets a save point within a
transaction set transaction it specify
characteristics for the transaction
dcn or data control language it consists
of the command such as Grant and revoke
which mainly deals with the rights
permissions and other controls of the
database system
Grant command gives user access
privileges to database
revoke it will draw users access
privileges given by using the grant
command now we will have hands on some
basic queries in my SQL workmench if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we'll see some basic queries
executing in MySQL workbench
so we'll start
and first query will run will be use
sys that is the database
this command is used to select the
database
in which we want to create or manipulate
any data now we'll see another command
that would create a table
foreign
to the customer table that would be the
columns
first will be the customer ID
and we will
act it as a primary key
the next attribute that would be
customer name customer underscore name
and its data type would be better
next set to that would be each
within data type
next attribute would be gender
with character data type
next we will add as date of purchase
with date data type
now we'll add another attribute that
would be addressed
with data type where care
next we will write the attribute item
that will be the item purchased with
data type webcam
next would be the price
okay for price we will make it as float
and let's shift this to next line and
now we'll execute this command
yeah you can see that the table is
created
now we have to insert values into it
for that we'll write a command insert
into
customers
values
and I have all the records written in
the notepad
so I will copy these
and paste it here
these are 20 records
like all the attributes they are in the
folder so we have written all the
records in the order only a customer ID
that will be 101 customer name that
would be Joseph age that would be 22
gender May date of purchase this is the
date of purchase address Pune
item that is vegetable purchased price
that is 80. so now we will run this
command and all these
records they would be inserted into the
table
and these are 20 commands 20 reports
you can see insert into customer values
the command has been executed and they
have been inserted into the table
now we'll see
the table
for that we'll write the command select
star
from
customers
here you can see the table
in the output grid
okay I will make sure you will see the
whole table
with all the 20 codes
yeah
you can see
all the 20 reports they have been
inserted
now see another command
foreign
and for that we would just
get the output as customer ID and
customer name in the output grid for
that we'll write the command select
customer ID
comma
customer name
from
customers
semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we will get both the columns
customer ID and customer name
in our output grid
now we'll see another command that would
be drop
the drop command just removes the
component from the database
so we'll write
drop
table
and table name that would be customers
and semicolon and we will execute this
command
now the table has been removed from the
database
to verify whether the table has been
removed from the database or not we will
run a command select star from
customers semicolon and execute this
command
and what we will get is Select start
from customers error code table says
customers doesn't exist the table has
been removed from the database so that
drop command worked here
now we don't have any table that is the
customer table has been dropped from the
database so we have to create that table
again
so we'll go at the top
okay
yeah
and we'll create the table again
and we'll insert all the records again
into the table
because the commands have run
now we will
run this command to see whether the
table has been created and the reports
have been inserted into the table or not
both commands have worked
now we'll see another command
that would be truncate the truncate
command just manages all the records
from the table
truncate table
name
semicolon
and just run this command
the command has been executed
now we'll see
yeah you can see that all the records
from the table has been vanished so the
concrete command worked here now to
carry other operations we have to insert
all the records again into the table
I'm going to do that
will again go put
and when this command
insert into customers values and all the
records
and we'll execute this command and that
command has been executed in all the
records are the enemy table so run this
command and check it
yeah you can see all the reports then
threaded into the table
now we'll see another command that would
be alter
alter command is used to update any
record into the table you will see alter
table
name that is customers
and now what we should do uh okay we'll
drop the column H from the table
so we'll write command drop
column
age
semicolon
I will run this command
the command has been executed
and now we'll check whether the H column
has been dropped or not
select star from customers
semicolon and we will execute this
command
yeah you can see the age column has been
dropped off the table
so the alter command has been executed
successfully
okay so now we'll see another thing uh
like if you want to comment something
during the execution you can do that
just write two minus signs and the text
this would be the command
and you can also use
slash
start and that
text
inside it and start and Slash
so this is also the comment section
you can write comment
with this syntax or with this syntax
they both work
now we'll see another command that would
be update
this is also used to manipulate data in
the table to update any report into the
table
so we will write update table name that
would be customers
and what we should update okay we will
update a record
uh we'll change the customer name and
address
and we have the primary key as customer
ID so we will use that so update
customers
set
customer name
equal to
James
coma
and address
equal to Boston
where
customer ID
equal to one zero one
okay you can see here in the table 101
customer ID the customer name is Joseph
and the address is Pune we have updated
command and we will execute it see okay
okay
we have an added here
uh yeah that's correct we'll execute
this command
where the command has been executed
successfully and now we check the table
with the command select star
from customers
you can see the row has been updated the
customer name is James here and the
address is Boston so the command has
been executed successfully
now we'll see another command that would
be delete
so delete command is used to delete any
particular record for any particular row
so we will write the command delete
from
customers
where
customer ID
equal to 102.
semicolon
so the second row that is with customer
id102 that would be deleted and we'll
execute this command
now we'll check into the table
yeah you can see
the record has been deleted
now we'll see distinct command that is
used to return different values so we
will write command select
distinct
and the column name for which we want
different values to be in the output
grid
we would select address
from
customers
and we will execute this command
yeah
these are the address so these are the
cities in the address
which are different and which are unique
and we have get that through the
distinct command
now we will see minimum command minimum
command is used to get the records or
get the data that is minimum of all the
data
so for that we will write the syntax
select
minimum
McMinn in bracket we will write the
attribute name or the column name
for which we want the data to be minimum
as
less price
this would be the attribute name
from customers
so you will execute this command
and what we would see is that 60 would
be the last price
like the customer table they have the
column price and in that we all we have
all the prices and from that the minimum
price is 60 and we have kept it at less
price
similarly we have the maximum command to
get the maximum amount from the column
we will use the maximum command
select Max
in bracket we would write the attribute
name
as
Max price
from customers
and we will execute this command
and what we get is 3400 it's the maximum
price from the price column
now we'll see another command that would
be count
command it Returns the number of rows
according to the query so we will run
the query and see like how it works
we'll write select
count
and the attribute name
that would be a customer ID
customer ID
from customers
semicolon
and when we'll run this command
we will get 19 as a result that is it
counted the number of customer IDs that
is 19 in the table
now we'll see another command
that would be average
so it just gets the average of the
numbers and how we do it write the query
select
AVG and the attribute name for which we
want the average
from table name
semicolon
and we'll execute this command and we'll
get the average of the price
from the customer stable
now if you want to add up all the prices
from the customer table you can use the
command sum so how you will execute that
command
select sum in bracket we would write the
attribute name that would be price
from
customers semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we'll get the sum of the prices from
the customer table
now we'll see where command where
command is used to filter records let's
see through syntax
so we will write select
star
from customers
where
address
uh yeah we will
where address equal to
Pune semicolon
and then we will run this command
and yeah this is the taper we will get
the records with addresses puning
so this is the functioning of where
command
now we'll see Group by command
that is used to just group the number of
rows that have the same values we will
see it through the syntax
like we will write
select
count
attribute name that would be customer ID
comma
address
from
table name
and group y
accordingly with address
now here the comma will not come here
this is the command select count
customer ID comma address from customers
Group by address
when we will execute this command yeah
we will get this table
that would be these are the different
addresses and these are the number of
times number of persons who live in this
address with the count with respect to
customer IDs
now we'll see having close with the help
of an example only
select
count attribute name that will be
customer ID
comma
address
from table name that would be customers
group y
address having
count
customer ID
greater than unit 3 view 44323
semicolon and then we will execute this
command
and you can see
the output we have got through this
command that is Group by command
close this and when we have added having
close having count customer ID greater
than three
we just got the customer ID count with
four
now we'll see another command
that is order by
select star from table name that is
customers
and we will order this output by address
semicolon
we have got the output with respect to
the address
the address has been assigned
alphabetically here
this particular topic which we are
called decided to work on it is very
interesting in this current scenario
because if you see carefully lot many
companies are moving towards nosql
database and there is a reason behind is
why mongodb is very very popular so it
is not actually replacing your existing
rdpms which is there in the market but
it is giving you complete different
approach where you can be completely
free
from all those restrictions what a
traditional rdbm message is going to
offer it to you so in this particular
tutorial we will be learning what
mongodb is all about and their
advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is the mobile DB so
as we know the mongodb is known to be a
call a traditional
document based database okay which
stores the data in a document
okay nosql means it doesn't say is like
no to SQL instead it says not only SQL
that means
it is not only SQL but it is supporting
the other approaches too okay so the
document based when you talk about it
actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records that means how the
records are related with each other so
that's how exactly it represents and it
is a pure schema free environment so
that you really do not need to have the
schema before you go and develop this
program so it has a pure schema less
involvement due to that it is giving you
far more better flexibility when you
talk about completely unorganized
environment
so what is nosql so the huge idea about
a nosql so it is completely into the
non-relational database like
traditionally if you see any
non-relational database uh you talk
about uh typical nosql uh it's purely
into the document base here no SQL does
not use any tables like in rows and
columns a traditional rdbps approach if
you see there they are using a complete
table structure like they talk about
columns they talk about rows and are all
about
so here in nosql it stores the
relationship data in the documents so
the different type of nosql databases
that are available like you talk about
called document based you talk about key
value base you talk about white column
based and glass based different options
are available for the nosql but the one
which we are using it mongodb it is a
purely document based database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mongodb installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're going to
start working on the first option called
mongodb installation
okay see mobile DB installation is very
simple if you open a website and go for
this website name called
um mobile DP download
we talk about mobile DB download you're
gonna see the official website called
mongodb Community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
Mac OS and by default detected my
platform however you can select depends
on which platform you have it and after
that you will be clicking on this
download
okay so it'll get ready for if you are
from Windows
I would say in this Windows you can
select appropriate option like two
options are available you can talk about
MSI or talk about zip my recommendation
is you can stick to the zip power
portion because it won't start any
mongodb Services behind the scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want a more video to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so here once the bongodb
is there so you will be seeing that two
files available inside the mongodb
folder inside the bin so once you
download the zip you will find two
different type of files are available
let me mention those
so inside the bin folder you will see
two files one is called mongod
okay the other file which is available
called Momo
D is to basically start the mongod
server and the Mobile T Mobile is
actually the client which will connect
with the homebody
clear so if you are in
Windows environment so once your Insight
is bin folder of your zip file you will
get the mongodb so you have to double
click on this it'll start a new command
prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the another binary
file called so to get start as a
client
okay since I am using the MacBook here
the concept is little different about
how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the move is being used into your code
okay everyone so now as we are in the
Macbook so here to start Modi we have a
very special way to start with so here
I'll start with my terminal and here I
would like to paste on very simple
command to start my mongodb database
that is called mongod
and after that you have to say hyphen
iPhone DB path it is a place where your
database will be starting and one more
important thing I forgot to mention like
mongoli would not start automatically
inside your
Windows machine unless inside your C
drive you have to create a new folder
name called data and under this you have
to create a new folder in equal DB
because automatically when the mode
starts it looks inside the C drive data
inside a DB folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forgot
whenever you're trying to use the mongod
so you must make have you must have this
particular fold structure in place in
your local machine otherwise this is not
gonna start every time I restart your
mongodb without this
location it automatically terminates So
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data DP folder ready with you
however you can also change the location
of this particular folder structure for
which we will discuss it little later on
but as of now we can see I'm giving my
location that is called hyphen iPhone DB
path slash data DB I hit enter you can
see now my mobile DB is starting now and
since it's stuck so I have to start the
new terminal now
front so here I open the another tab
and type
and I'm going to type mode now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay now to check
which of the databases are available to
you so you can just type show DBS
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there inside
your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create new
database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here name call
use
simply DB
if I say use simply DB it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside let's see now you can see you say
you simply DB it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means your current database
name was simplydb
so if you are not sure which database
you are in we can just type DBS
or DB
and it will show you that your current
database is simply DB
that's it so your database is set and we
are all good to go ahead with our next
level development
hello everybody and welcome back in a
previous videos you have seen like how
to create a database and how to identify
whether my database is there or not so
if you remember previously we have
created our database using use keyword
so if I just see my databases which we
have created is last time so how we can
check this out we can say
show
space DBS
okay so you can see we have a got
database list but we do not have any
database which we have created last time
is registered here that's quite
surprising because when we have created
our database it should be listed here
but it is not let's do one more time I'm
saying use
uh Excel DB
and I'm saying switch to sldb now when I
say once again show DBS
so I still don't see my database is
listed here there is a reason the reason
is according to the momodb rule unless
we have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now I want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb compared to the
relational database here the table which
is actually in rdbms it is called here
it is called
collection
okay
DB is still called DB here
okay that means the database will be
still called database but row what you
use this word in a traditional rdbm is
here it is known as called document
if you remember I told you like it is a
document based database so here every
single record what you try to insert it
is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document that's what exactly the
difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well we have to basically go and create
a new collection okay so what you can
say DB Dot
create
collection and here I can pass my
collection name I can say
demo
collection so once it is done I can see
it is collection is created in typical
language I can say the table is created
and now when I try to see same show DBS
I can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and I can see
the details are listed when I say show
DBS but there's a again another
alternative option available where you
can just do that without even saying DB
dot create collection
well
if I want to create a collection I
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection I
can directly use this statement name
called DB Dot
DB dot SL
student
dot insert and here we would like to add
the property like a name and here we can
say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
DB dot SL student.insert
and I hit enter you can see this
uninserted one and surprisingly when you
try to say
press enter you will see this SL student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line not
only create the collection for you but
also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the Json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value pairs
so DB is a predefined keyword SL student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one property call show
collections when I say show collections
I can list down those number of
collections or else I can set tables in
a typical rdbms language which are there
added in my system
so as a student in which I can see the
record is inserted so if I want to
confirm I can simply say
DB Dot SL
udent DOT fine find is a function
through which I can list out those
number of Records which are added I say
file and you can see that the records
are received at the same time when I say
DB dot the name call Demo collection
okay
db.democollection dot find
I'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when I write this
command called SL student.insert it not
only create a new collection for me but
also insert the record into my table
also called a collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear but
whenever you talk about DB dot create
collection many people always think
about what is the significance of having
this DB dot create collection
look DB dot create collection is having
its own significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always bring
some restrictions some terminology which
missed out whenever you talk about this
line
so having this DB dot create collection
you can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use TP Dot
collection input is insert so you might
be thinking what those cappings you're
talking about let me try to brief you
when I say DB Dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name call support student
okay when I say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
I say
capped colon
true
what do we say cap cool and true so you
are enabling the capping after that the
next parameter I'm gonna pass that is
known as call size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose I'm saying 5 to
4 and also we are saying two double
eight zero that is the size of 5 MB and
here we are giving call Max colon
5. what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever we try
to bring this great collection option so
Capital means you are enabling the
capping so what does that meaning is it
is trying to say in this particular
collection name called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either five or less than five
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 MB that means you're trying to
say either by adding the total number of
five records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 MB okay or else
the maximum number of five documents can
be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 MB and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to say DB dot
create collection this option is not
possible when you're trying to use this
so that's the benefit of having this DB
dot create collection and this is what
we always recommend
well now we would like to talk about our
next feature here inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database now we will tell you
like how to insert a document so far we
have already seen how to insert a
document inside a momotb now we would
like to also show you how we can insert
the documents using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogotv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called relation document and
second is called embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use embedded
documents because that helps you to
scale up your application without any
hurdle okay the embedded documents means
what that means the uh I would say the
parent record as well as the child
records both stores in the same location
fine so how exactly that is let's take a
look about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying DB Dot
student I do not have a student
collection or I'm just telling you DP
dot student
Dot
insert
here we would like to add
some records what I'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number I'm just saying
uh one two three four you can give
anything now the next one we will talk
about call name
this name we can say
student one
followed by the next one I'm talking
about which course the student has
registered so we can say
course inside this course we would like
to say the course name so let's say
course name we are giving the course
name called
MCA
okay followed by another property called
duration
okay I'm giving this duration
is called
three
years like that
after that
this curly braces is closing that means
C the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from course
you have about few more properties like
in coarse name and duration
I am closing this and starting the
another property and that is called
address
okay
sorry let me remove from here and from
address and address we can say one more
curly basis
and inside this address we can say City
given the name called what
Bangalore
the another one we are using that is
called state
um
let me remove this state
colon
ke
okay and the third property we're using
that is known is called country
here is saying IE that is called India
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and how to document both are
closed hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
I will say student have the registration
number
five
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated with them and now when I try
to say DB Dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
I can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object ID
and here you might have observed and
there also your option then what exactly
that ID is now let me brief you this ID
is nothing but a unique primary key your
mongodb has offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it so by default with
every single document
mogodb will associate this by default
property called underscore ID which you
can't even ignore
however you can override I haven't
provided any
underscore ID is a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single mongodb document if you
want to override it you can override
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value however if you want to override it
you can override the value of underscore
ID but you can't change the key name
let's try with some
another record so the same required if I
try to add
let's go
I'm using call
student2 and here I'm saying one two
three four five here if I want to
override it I can just say underscore
ID
colon I can get the value called what
one zero one
this you need to remember for I'm
overriding this value with 1 0 1 now
adding it now records are added now let
me call find now you see this time the
records when I fetched so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore ID in the second record it is
the one which I have provided
and remember one thing in Momo DB you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore ID as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons like in composite key which you
used to do in Tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore ID
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be given to you so this is
the first way of how the insert document
has been done we'll be telling you the
another ways where the other documents
are also added Okay so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records but I
also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in mongodb
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for VAR
my
EMP equal to now starting with
a typical object like this and after
that I will adding this and within this
I'm adding the first property called EMP
ID
colon one
after this okay now you can see it is
not understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call uh you
know the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now amp id1 and we
just give the second property called EMP
name
so
amp ID I just
remove this I just say EMP ID and I say
amp
Name colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here again I'm adding
another one that is called
amp ID column two
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
column three
and
colon
Cuba
added
okay and this curly process is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing and
once it is done come down and say DB
Dot
new amp
dot insert
okay and here you pass the name of the
object called my AFB
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted three that is known as called
work insert we are inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use DB dot The
Collection name is what your new AP
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object ID
okay so that is a really nice idea to
have
the ID to be provided
okay remember this statement
so you understood finally how we can
add the records in a book going forward
we will also talk about which is related
to your update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos okay but here that is the
first thing which you realize it how we
can perform those kind of operations in
very very simple and straightforward
manner okay everyone so now we have got
three records with us and in case if I
am planning to perform update on any of
my records how will I do this now so we
have a predefined functions a variable
name called update function let's see
how this update function can really work
so which use this statement name called
DB
dot what is my collection name which is
known as call our new EMP new EMP
okay dot
update
okay so what I will do I will say DB dot
new EMP Dot
update here
okay now when we talk about call update
we have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
is this I want to change what the name
how can I do this now very simple uh
to perform this what I would like to do
now I want to basically add few more
records to give you some more better
idea
uh you can see now here we have a call
admin ID name
so I just do one thing I just change the
IDS
one two three I just say four
I say five
ss6
okay and I
call this
again the 3D chords are inserted now let
me try to call find now we have total
number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated QA
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now I want to say DB Dot
new EMP
Dot
update here I would like to perform the
property like and what
uh
name I say EMP name
amp Name colon I say admin
okay
so I just close that and I use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value here we are giving
EMP name
okay what I want to do I say wherever
the name is admin change to what
admin new
that name I want to change it
closes close this
and run
now I can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here I will see uh the value called
admin new is updated but I have one more
admin called admin it is not changed and
there is something which you need to
notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update so
what mongodb does it starts from the top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop it doesn't carry
forward its search process for the next
level of results and that is something
which is
I really want to do that so in case if
you are planning to change those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a call name admin
second property we will call manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new underscore
manager and I want to update multiple
values what I will do here
I will put comma and say
multi colon should
okay same multicolon true that you want
to say hey I want to update multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
this time you can say it is saying and
match to and modify 2 that means two
records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have a more beautiful feature
available inside the mobile DB and that
is called how exactly we can perform
absurd
clear let's talk about upset upset is a
combinations of update and insert let me
try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about called update part
you see now
here we are trying to say uh
this point
yeah you see about multi-true we have
used
now here
this multi-true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2.
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there's a whole concept available in
called absurd absurd means if I try to
perform up certain means if the records
are not available it'll insert the
record
I want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-truth
okay so as I can see we're using
something called name and we are
performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi-truth
we are saying
obstruction
when I say upset rule so what happened
now they say unmatched zero and up
inserted 2 and modified with ID this
that means when I try to call this find
function you will be seeing now we have
a god
the another record has been added are we
clear now
as a new record
so upsa does what upset says like if the
records are found
I will update it if it is not I will
insert it that means if I try to call
the same thing manager 2
fine it is added as a new manager now if
I just try to say
uh
not manage it to I will call QA
QA and here we are saying empty equal to
new
underscore QA
and now you can see it is saying
unmatched one and I've sorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey I did not find any uh
inserted part but yes I matched one
record I found one record and the one
record is updated now that is very very
beneficial feature when you really want
to perform absurd so that is a
update plus insert
very important feature that depends on
the requirement if you want to add you
can certainly add this so the way we
have tried to add this upserted part we
can also try to perform the delete part
also
okay so mongodb also helps you to
perform the delete part and how you'll
be trying to add it now let's try to
understand here in my code if I want to
perform any delete path I have this
statement name called DB
dot the option we are using it that is
also collection name EMP
uh new EMP sorry
dot we have option you will remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here let's try to add the ID here or the
name which you would like to import so I
want to say like EMP name admin new so
we just say
p
name
okay
and then
scoreboard
admin new
remove
we can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only one admin
name is available
okay now in a similar way if I try to
remove
the property call uh new underscore
manager new underscore
detector now you can see the three
records are removed so it's not like
update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as I seen earlier like we have
perform the delete part now
when I try to say DB
Dot
new EMP dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now when it comes to C insert part we
have seen update part we have seen
delete part we have seen now it's time
to basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen But
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
Records into your application you can
also do that let's see DB Dot
uh new EMP
eror Dot
find
clear now so in find you can also
pick up the specific records too like
when I'm saying dot find and here we can
just say name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with the name
called admin
because it is the EMP name not a name so
let me change back to
now I can say it finds one record so
like that you can also apply a condition
okay enter your code now in a similar
line if you really don't want to offer
any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
Records to be shown so you have this
function available name call
limit
2 2 means only two records now you can
see though I have three records but it
is only showing me two records because I
have limit those number of Records into
my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the Sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do so here rather than
saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that also you can
mention so we can just say PMP name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so you can just say
descending order
hit
now you can see it is showing in a
descending order now if I just say minus
1 if you just say 1 what is showing you
in an ascending order so you can pick up
the specific property we have on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order so
that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search the records based on the embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have some records
added okay that is let me try to say
show
collections
our call SL student
and student
okay DB Dot
Dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records now if you want to
search the records based on their
embedded properties like I am talking
about address this is about property
number City
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this very simple so
you say TV DOT
student
Dot
find
okay so inside is fine you can provide
the specific properties like my
outermost property name is called what
address so we are using this option
called
address dot dot City
so we say City
are we clear colon
I'm giving a city name called what
Bangalore
okay let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly places here hit enter and
you can see now I find two records
because both the records belong to what
Bangalore so I'm getting this City
Bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have the other
details also
okay in which you can have the
conditions based on less than greater
than or whatever values you would like
to make it is available and possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
are we clear where the range which you
would like to consider so those are also
possible like you can see we have this
property name called what empid3n6
I just want to pick up only those
records whose ID is greater than what
two so what I can say DB
dot new EMP okay dot find
and inside this file we can say
the property okay so what's property
we're using empid we are saying EMP ID
here colon here we'll be using dollar GT
GC stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value called what one
okay close this
run you can see you have received three
records three four and six
in case if I just look forward for
higher than five
so you will see only one record so
greater than
let's call GT
okay same option if I just say LT
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide the
condition so called limit as I can say
find EMP ID the way we provide it so
here I will not use
less than
okay instead I'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in empid whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here we are providing EMP
ID and then
which is another curly braces and we're
using Dollar in is very important
property Dollar in Colon here you
provide the details I'm saying uh inside
so the property is three four six we are
saying
comma 6.
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this okay everyone so in our previous
example we have already seen lot many
activities this time we are trying to
offer you something very interesting
feature and that is known is called
working with indexing see momodb is one
of the most popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how uh one
particular uh document which is huge
document in case if you would like to
perform any sort of indexing inside this
how you will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing and with
indexing how you'll be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what I will do is in Step number one
previous records if I see I have a chord
uh four six three four one depends on
what earlier records we had it so we had
a call
new EMP
so DB dot new EMP
dot fight
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three records with me now let me
try to apply indexing without indexing
if I want to find a result what outcome
I'm gonna receive so to know about how
much time it gonna be taking if if I
have a got large number of records with
me I'll be using this statement name
called DB
dot the name is called New EMP
Dot
explain and here I will be using one
predefined functionality call execution
starts
execution starts
okay now here after the execution starts
you'll be using Dot
find we'll be using the first property
here
okay and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called EMP name
colon put in the name call
QA
okay let's close
okay now when I pressed hit enter
execution stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was hit enter and now you
can see a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
parse query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to Remember by
default
here when I try to run it says and
return one
Advance or need time total everything it
is showing me but one important thing
which you will see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and return one that means one result is
returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
just imagine a use case here
when I say total number of documents
examine 3 in case if I ever got millions
of records with me that means to search
the record it will examine all the
Millions number of Records to search the
result which certainly gonna be taking
huge amount of time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default index is applied on your
underscore ID DB Dot
new EMP
um
yeah DB dot newmp dot
when I say db.new emp.getindex is a
predefined function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore ID
that's the fact because by default index
is applied on underscore ID not on the
other properties
so I need to identify which of the
properties are required to be get
indexes mongodb advantages it is
supporting multi-column indexes and
that's what exactly we would like to see
so let's see in our next demo now we
will try to apply indexing on our own
property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say DB
Dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
um
new EMP
Dot
create index
here you have to pass two things number
one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so I am trying to apply on
EMB
ryogic name
and I want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon 1.
hit enter you can see now it is telling
me like uh number of indexes before one
and number of indexes after two that
means earlier index was available only
on one particular property now it is
applied on two properties
if you want you can check now you can
see there's another property is added
called EMP underscore
now if I try to execute a similar query
which I executed earlier
give it now you'll be seeing there's a
different statistics altogether
here if I see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one see now earlier the number
of document examine were three but since
this index is applied notice telling me
the total number of document examined is
one so performance is certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact I would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes into your code
okay so hope we all are clear and
understood about this concept so let's
go ahead and get this implemented into
our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so it is also a possibilities where we
want to also apply the index on other
number of properties too as you can see
in our existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new EMP which
contains two different properties one is
called amp ID in seconds called EMP name
just now we have applied index on our
EMP name but in case if I want to apply
index on EMP ID I'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes I'm having
this index applied on two different
property now we would like to say DB is
index applied on two different property
now we would like to say DB
Dot create
index and here in this DB dot create
index we can just
I will say DB dot collection name so our
collection name is called New EMP new
EMP
dot create index first Prime parameter
is certainly the name of which property
we are applying so here we are saying
EMP ID
and in this EMP ID we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we're saying
-1
okay now let's press enter and check the
status okay now you can see earlier
indexes which we have created that was
two and now it turns to three so it is
very clear that index is improving now
let's check this out
uh DB Dot
newmp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply in text or n number of
columns if you want
okay at the same time the way we have
created the index in case if I want to
drop an index so we can also drop so
what we can do DB dot new EMP
dot drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
drop
remember this point in case if you are
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which index so you
should have that particular index name
okay so here we are providing my index
name so it should not be uh I would say
the traditional name called EMP ID no it
has to be EMP ID
underscore minus 1 or
EMP name underscore one so this should
be the name I'm saying EMP
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the EMP name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say EMP name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was three
okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call empid and
underscore ID
so now we have
only two indexes left there is no EMP
name anymore this is how exactly you can
drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mover DB you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
indexing into our code now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation Works see in mobodb
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply some very simple code
Snippets into your ongoing
uh I would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate DB and here we have a
called student as a by default
collection in which we have some set of
records are already added
now if I just want to apply aggregation
now I would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is see ideally
when you talk about call aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
typical aggregation there so the Unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things now here let me try
to bring some of the important
well-known
I would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
specific
specific fields Donald project is
designed to select one specific fields
from a collection we used to talk about
called what
dollars match the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about called dollar group so it
does the actual aggregation fine we talk
about call Dollar sort
okay it basically sort the document okay
like that there's so many operations are
available which you will see one by one
in our aggregation Behavior now my first
example the one which I want to execute
I have a call student record with me
which contains a student name okay the
section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student
disappeared now here my first
requirement is we want to filter
data based on a section A because
students belong to different sections as
you can see now it is they belong to the
different section section A B C D so I
just want to filter the data based on a
section A
okay so for filter out I would like to
use dollar match let's see how it works
so I just would like to filter out only
those students who belong to the section
A
so how we would like to re use it now I
will say DB Dot
student Dot
aggregate and inside this we would like
to use this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this I would like to use another
curly braces
and I say
section
8.
okay and I close this close this close
the square bracket close this
okay so DB dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality is section a hit enter and
you can see now it lists down all those
students who belong to the section 8.
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records where this section is a and we
are using and operator Max is greater
than 80 there are so many students who
have a different marks like 1719 and
whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now remember not only the
section A but also marks were greater
than 80. so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we're starting
this curly braces
okay so after this match we would like
to bring and
reset dollar
and and again colon
again we are starting this is call
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section A
number one and after this the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks colon and once again
we would like to start curly braces and
here we use
dollar
GT that is called what a greater than
colon
80.
okay all are closed so you see like here
we have got this square bracket and noun
brackets
so
what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket again round brackets
okay
let's see where it is going on
so we're using this DB dot student dot
aggregate we will use this
yeah square bracket then curly braces
then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces and we
have a call and operator
after this and we have a call
this now square bracket then curly
braces section A
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks colon
dollar GT
okay and we are using what
colon
80. after that we are closing this
and using two more curly which is coil
packet in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that so DB dot student dot
Aggregate and like this it will be able
to get it now okay so in a previous
example that was the only missing point
was after this
uh this dollar match we didn't apply
this curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and I
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this I would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now I
just would like to bring selective
Fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything I'm getting it
so I really don't want to bring all the
properties from this document I would
like to selectively take specific
property
so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select a
specific record
so I just use this statement name called
DB
Dot
student okay dot
aggregate we are using it now after that
square bracket
then curly braces now we are trying to
say dollar
project
what you would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means I want
to zero means I don't want so whichever
property will be enabling it by giving
the one as a digit that means it is
it is expected to be displayed so I'm
saying one
comma I'm saying section
colon 1 okay and I'm also
looking forward for marks
call it one
that's it so now
you can see now I am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if I
go back and remove some properties like
I only want
student and section you can see I have
only students and sections are used
here if I just use this statement name
call
underscore ID column 0.
now you can see only
the names and sections are visible ID is
not because I really don't want ID by
default ID is shown but if I say 0 that
means the ID will not be visible here so
like that you can select
The Columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way now the
other thing I would like to use
what if you want to find out the student
name section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
the previous one what we have used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is a curly basis I'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this I'll
close this
okay and close this again
I'm opening it up
by using this option call
project dollar
project we are picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again and say
student name
student Name colon we are using one
comma
section colon 1
and
1.
Max colon 1 and now
closing this
now I can see I got those so the
requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from student
collection with the section is a so you
are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection gives you lot
many opportunities which you can utilize
it for your own and also it comes with
lot many predefined functions like in
some AVG and all so let's talk about
those functionalities too so this is the
first thing which we have seen
aggregations are taken place now in case
if you would like to perform the group
like if I want to find out the total
marks
Group by
okay section like each and every section
I would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how will I
basically do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because I would like to use a group part
so
thank you after this curly braces we
want to use dollar
group
okay that is called Group by in rdbm is
how you use it here we use this curly
braces again here we are passing this
underscore ID
okay you have to provide underscore ID
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar ID whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is a compulsory field you need to
have it after that
I'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon here curly braces
again
uh dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have I want to
use in Mark so I can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a JavaScript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now section wide I'm
able to get all the marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of Records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
how we are basically taking this marks
in my application fine so we are clear
about how we are picking that up but
what in case if I would like to take a
marks for the specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but only thing is what
will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get the
all the section marks but if you would
like to bring it only for the specific
section we know it variable what we need
to do so here
before I talk about call Dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar match
okay and here we are using this
uh option called section A
sorry
here in dollar match we are giving this
call
section
here we're giving a
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section we are able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so that's where exactly would like
to perform and there's another option
like in case if you would like to
perform at an average suppose if you
want to fetch the count of student in
each section and total marks and average
marks as well is so total marks as well
as the average marks we want to get it
so however I will able to take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also into our code how we have
taken call group underscore ID section
talking about section
total marks with the sum we are also
using this after that we can also use
the average
Okay so
this is we have taken group underscore
ID sum so here on which we will start so
when we say sum marks after that we can
just put curly braces
and we can just use count
okay and after this we'll be using this
column
curly braces and use
dollar
sum
okay colon one
okay and after that I'll put
comma here and we use
average
and insert is average I will use
in curly research we can say dollar AVG
okay colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and all brackets and
now you can see you've got the average
markings in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobo TV that really
create a difference of how the
aggregation changes the way how you
react to
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of or aggregation it's time
to talk about like how
when it works with mogodb mobile DB is
properly known for
I will say for replication that is
called high availability and that
feature comes by default with mongodb
you really don't need to install any
software for this because it is a
built-in feature for the mongodb uh so
when you download that it comes along
with this so no additional
configuration setup is really required
when it comes to the mongodb part okay
so let's get started and talk about how
mobile DB can offer the replication see
the idea behind the application is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so we talk about course application you
are replicating your data to wear to the
multiple child so here in mongodb we
have one concept available
okay that is known as master
okay and
slaves
okay Master is one and there will be
multiple sleeves okay so these slaves
where your records are actually stored
and this is a master which will be
responsible to replicate the data to all
its Childs when the request comes due to
that in case I have one particular
node fails so automatically the data
will be taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible we have a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have a one concept like
call momodb Atlas so there we can go and
get our cluster ready so here we start
with the concept name called
DB Atlas
let's search for mongodb Atlas and here
I see mongodb Atlas database as a
service see this is a free tool it's the
cloud environment where you really don't
need to install mobodb in your local
machine it is a cloud-based mobodb
support which is free to use with a
limited amount of space but yes for the
testing purpose it is the best suitable
so I can start with the start free or
else I can say the login here
okay from there onwards I can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is a place from where you can
start working on your cluster see as
I've told you like initially when you
will be working on this
mobile DB it will ask you to create a
cluster
initially
okay since I already have a cluster with
me
okay so I really don't need to create it
and as a free tier it will not allow me
to have more than one cluster setup
ready
so if I say create a new cluster
okay and I say by default AWS
okay and I get close to all this
notification AWS you can select any
other cloud provider and
8GB Ram Cloud backup cluster name you
can see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour reason being because I
already have a cluster with me hence
more than one cluster is not allowed in
a free tier cluster so I have to cancel
this but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default AWS
select your location okay give the name
of the cluster you want to give anything
you can give it here otherwise let it be
the by default name cluster and say
create cluster it will take a while
minimum two to three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you and your cluster once it is
ready it looks like that
Okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there any
questions when I click on cluster zero
you can see now here we have got three
nodes available one is called primary
node which is called Master as I
suggested earlier
and now we have called slaves
automatically when the Clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary in two will be
secondary
based on your package whichever you have
taken it you can increase the number of
nodes later on but as a free I am gonna
get or I will be receiving total number
of three nodes available here
so record whichever will be stored it
will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary notes and from the primary I
can insert the record and secondaries I
can read the records remember you can't
insert records into the secondary so you
can only insert a record only in your
privacy course secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you know whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because I haven't
stored any records as such
so I just go back to my cluster
so initially I would like to go back and
create few things now okay I would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the cluster
because when you cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now first setting is you have
to put it and remember the steps First
Step will be your network access so in
network access you have to go and you
have to say add IP address and in this
add IP address you have to select this
option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those IP addresses will be
whitelisted otherwise what you can do
you can see here in my options I have
given 0.0.0 that means all IP addresses
are
acceptable so all IP addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user so by default it is username and
password is given so you can go back and
create a new user and